e
e e
okay it's 10: a.m. we're going to get
going um representative wood would like
to lead us in the pledge
okay uh today is going to be our first
true grinder of a day um so we've got a
bunch of hearings uh executive session
will start at uh 10:10 and what will
happen is we will come in and out of
executive session as time allows um
there's going to be time limits today
for speaking um as I stated when we did
our orientation we have 75 bills so it
requires us to hear 15 bills a day um so
it's not a statement about any policy or
anything it's just a statement about
this is what happens when a committee
has 75 bills and everyone gets a public
hearing so with that uh I'm going to
open up the public hearing for cacr 5 uh
relative to absentee ballots providing
that no excuse shall be needed by the
voter to receive an absentee ballot or
repes recognize is representative Lane
for purpose of introduction of the bill
and representative Lane um when you get
done with your testimony can you please
fill out a pink card for me yes
sir um I was just fumbling for my notes
and can't seem to find them so I guess
I'm going to be doing this from for
memory for the record I'm Connie Lane
representative uh from uh marac uh
district 16 which is war two in
conquered and I am bringing uh cacr 5
the purpose purpose is to uh improve
access uh for voters in New Hampshire so
that they will have the same ability to
choose as 37 other states allow uh no
excuse absentee ballot um there like I
said there's
37 states that allow no excuse absentee
voting there are eight states that do
full wrin voting and in that um 37 our
states
like uh Montana Wyoming this is why I
need my notes North Dakota South Dakota
uh Nevada um so they're not all blue
states it is uh very much has been
endorsed by both Republicans and
Democrats
um as far as security goes uh most of
the um there have been a lot of studies
done about the security of absentee
ballot voting
and they have found one study said that
is as likely to get hit more likely to
get hit by lightning than it is to have
fraud in a absentee ballot
voter so every study has shown that the
fraud is infantes and all 37 states that
have done it have found the same to be
true because obviously they have the
same concerns about security that we
have and there are some safeguards that
they've all put in that we can adopt if
this constitution Amendment passes the
other thing that's important to remember
is that we need to listen to the people
and the vast majority of people in New
Hampshire and across the country support
this type of absentee
ballot and I think we should let the New
Hampshire people decide this rather than
have us sit here and try and guess what
they
want so for that reason I would ask that
um you uh give New Hampshire voters the
opportunity to make the choice and uh
I'll let all the others behind me uh
will be speaking uh speak to other
statistics and studies and I can take
questions if you'd like other questions
from the
Committee hearing none thank you okay
thank you
um Daniel Richard you fill out pink card
is it for cacr 5 it is okay you're up uh
you'll be up after the Secretary of
State's office I'm going to go ahead and
put mark on your pink card for you
though for cacr 5 rep uh Mr
secretary thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record I'm
David scanland Secretary of State and I
just wanted to provide the committee
with a little information uh on this
bill
um our election process historically um
has developed over quite a long period
of time uh since colonial times as a
matter of fact and uh we kind of eased
into the issue of absentee voting and it
was created and put in our
constitution uh and amended several
times to expand it from just general
elections to All State elections and
then local elections um but it has been
in the Constitution and used in
elections as a matter of necessity it's
for individuals that are not around
during the election and so they have to
vote by an absentee B Ballot or for
individuals that have some type of a
disability that prevents them from
getting to the polling place and being
able to
vote um the change that is being
proposed in the Constitutional Amendment
will'll change that from being a matter
of necessity to a matter of convenience
making it uh easy for people to uh
exercise the right to vote that simply
don't want to get up in the morning and
and go to the polling place and I think
that's fine you know if that's a policy
decision that the people of New
Hampshire will have to end up making but
when we start talking about convenience
in voting I think we also have to at the
same time talk about the security of the
vote and it's my belief that when the
the you know if a question like this was
going to be put on the ballot that I
think we have to address the other side
of the equation which is and I've said
this before to the committee but you on
one hand I think everybody in this room
would agree that it is important that
people that are qualified to vote have
the opportunity to do that uh in a fair
easy way the other side of the equation
is that people have the right to know
who's participating in the elections and
that those people are qualified and I
think everybody would agree with that
statement the problem is those
two uh statements there's a tension
there that is pulling against each other
because the easier that you make it to
vote the more you're backing off on the
security end of things in the extreme if
he get push too far to one side you
create a climate where voter fraud can
take place on the other side of that if
you are if you want to make sure that
the vote is secure that the people are
qualified and they've proven it and you
put these restrictions on you are making
it less easy for that voter to exercise
that right to vote and in the extreme
that's voter suppression so the job as
policy makers is find that sweet spot uh
in the middle where you know people are
generally satisfied that it's easy and
that they have confidence in the outcome
of that vote and so that's why I make
the point that if we are going to change
the
Constitution for convenience let's also
change it to make sure that there's an
expectation that voters are going to be
willing to uh uh prove their
qualifications so with that oh before I
go I'm going to make copies of this for
the committee I I was at a conference
where Charles Stewart who's a professor
at MIT uh gave a fantastic presentation
I would love if he could give it to the
committee sometime but he had this chart
uh has this chart that shows uh where
the different states are at uh in 2024
in terms of their voting Practices New
Hampshire is one of really two states
that still have the traditional election
day voting processes um the other states
have have thrown in vote by mail systems
the early voting
systems and so they're you know on this
graph they're all over the map um and
then there's there's a section in the
Middle where it shows all of the states
that are kind of equally position with
all of those items but in doing that
they have actually have three distinct
election systems that they have to run
at the polling place by doing that as
opposed to New Hampshire which still has
you know the single simple mode of
voting so with that Mr chair I'd be
happy to answer any questions other
questions from the committee
representative gasowski Gaz offski uh
yes thank you um in your opinion do you
think as uh we practice our voting now
we're in that sweet
spot I think the legislature has done a
good job balancing it but it is you know
depending on which part is in power you
know the the the scale Moves In One
Direction of the other but for the most
part and this is borne out with uh uh
some polling surveys that Andy Smith at
UNH has done voters in New Hampshire
have K high confidence uh in the
elections here and um and we've
maintained that over a sustained period
of time the questions committee
representative Mirad thank you Mr chair
Mr secretary are you aware of any states
that have more uh convenient voting than
New Hampshire but have uh problems with
security can you name any examples of
that well certainly there are states
that have very convenient voting and I
look at the West Coast uh Washington and
Oregon for example do everything by mail
um I think there are concerns uh about
those voting systems like we have
concerns about voting systems in New
Hampshire but they are not organized or
widespread you know Washington had an
issue in the last election where
somebody put an incendiary device in one
of their ballot dropboxes and destroyed
an unknown number of ballots
um um yeah I mean I think each state is
a little bit different further questions
to the committee representative
toner thank you um could you or do you
have knowledge of how many um
absentee ballots are denied per per
election just a rough idea not off the
top of my head I I know that there are
um that we do keep track of absentee
balot that were rejected for various
reasons and I can certainly get that
number for you I just don't have it uh
in my head at the moment further
questions from the committee
representative PM O'Brien thank you um
I'm trying to formulate my question is
it's it's a moving Target because things
keep coming up that I I'm concerned
about Washington and
Oregon are their votes processed
publicly the way they are here I don't
think that they are and I've thought
that they uh that that it would be
something that would be uh of great
concern to New Hampshire residents
should we ever adopt anything similar to
that because of that issue I'm not
follow I'm not completely familiar with
how they actually count their votes in
those States because it's all vote by
mail
uh I would think that they use Regional
counting centers to expedite that
process um New Hampshire's process is
very transparent and you know all of the
ballots are counted in processed at the
polling place results being released on
Election night and posted there it's
easy to get a recount there are appeals
to the bot law commission and to the
courts um and that lends itself to
transparency followup uh okay so this is
another question more accurately I'm
thinking about the red states in the
west that were mentioned um they're very
spread out ranches rural there's
probably more of a need in in my opinion
for absentee voting in that kind of a
community what is the
largest distance between a voter in
their Town Center in New Hampshire where
they vote how many miles is the most
miles away you think that that a a a
voter would have to travel to vote in
New Hampshire I think it's not a lot
because it's everything's done at the
Town
level every town has its own polling
place and so it's just a matter of where
that voter lives within their town to
their polling place should be fairly
close Okay further questions from Mr
secretary see none thank you thank you
um all right now we're on to General
comments from the public we've got 1 2 3
4 5 six so I'm going to impose a
two-minute time limit um on there uh
first up we'll be keeping up with our
tradition of letting state
representatives go first representative
Tim Horan you're up sorry Mr Rich he he
he fired one in he fire he fired one in
uh before I made my comment to you after
he made my com after I made my comment
to you but um but everyone going forward
will be on a two-minute timer um
representative organ welcome to election
law thank you very much I'm representing
Timothy Horgan from straford County uh
10 the which the town of Durham so I I I
um the right to an absentee ballot is
already enshrined in the Constitution
and uh you know some people may not
approve of absentee voting but it's if
you can't go to the polls for whatever
reason it's makes a huge difference it's
uh better than not voting at all um so
we the right to vote is a fundamental
right and that includes the right to
vote absente and the this uh resolution
merely expands the conditions um you
could AR if any of you feel that maybe
expands it too far this is the first
year of the bium we can't the people
can't vote on this until November 2026
so you have till you've got a very long
time to think about this until late June
in 2026 so I would urge you uh either
either to pass it if you're happy with
it or to retain it over the summer but
certainly killing it now is uh killing
it now in 2025 is just not the right
thing to do so I I I urge you to protect
the right to vote including the right to
vote absentee by uh well at least
refraining from it Ling cacr five thanks
will you be taking questions oh sure are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thanks next up is
Mr
Richard um just a quick thing before we
turn Miss Richard um Miss Barnes Jean
Barnes I'm going to write cacr 5 on your
card for you so I'm going to mark your
card because you didn't put the bill
number um without objection so uh thank
you Mr
Richard good morning ladies and
gentlemen I'm a little too loud here let
me back off thank you for hearing me
this morning uh I have two specific
reasons why I oppose this bill
constitutional first you are New
Hampshire runs its state election
process concurrent to the federal
election process so what most people are
not going to look at is the federal
oversight so I oos this bill because
what it does by creating a no excuse
absentee ballot is now you're creating a
different standard practice or procedure
that violates the 14th Amendment and the
federal election laws so you want to
keep that in mind because it's not just
about the state law you're doing both
side by side so that is a binding issue
also State Statute 659 colon
50b there's a problem you have a
moderator who has to examine the
absentee ballot to make sure that the
affida was properly executed if it's not
and you're going to create a no excuse
reason you're going to have to modify a
whole lot of other statutes because
there's going to be internal conflict
because you're going too far now the
state constitution was amended in 1942
to permit absentee voting and prior to
that there was none so I would argue if
there was an amendment that provided it
this is the correct this is the correct
resolution but it runs into too many
other conf conflicting Provisions like I
said the federal law it's got to be
equal if everyone who votes in person
has to be treated the same way why are
we going to create a new exception for a
second class of voter because that's
exactly what you have if you have a no
exemption voting right you just mail in
your ballot who's going to check it
right now
nobody any questions perfect timing 10
seconds left uh questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you um next up is uh David tremble from
my town of
wear good morning Mr chairman and
committee members my name is David
Trumble from the town ofwar I support
this bill for a few reasons first is
that voting is not just a fundamental
right it's the right that under Pines
all of our rights and that was held by
the US Supreme Court in the case of
Harper versus Virginia State Board of
Education New Hampshire is right now the
most difficult state to vote in every
year the election Law Journal publishes
a report on how difficult it is to vote
around the country Mississippi is 49th
New Hampshire is 50th we are at the
bottom making it the most difficult so
when you talk about finding The Sweet
Spot being between access and security
when you're at the bottom you're not in
the in in the place where you're looking
at The Sweet Spot the third thing is is
that eight states have all male voting
as you've pointed out 27 additional
states have no excuse absentee Bing
that's 35 States so if there was a major
problem by now it would have been
apparent but it hasn't happened around
the country there's been no problem with
the US Constitution it should be done
it's time for New Hampshire to catch up
the last thing is what about security a
study was done by some people at
Columbia Law School Steven bellan I'll
give you the uh when I submit my written
testimony explains all of the steps that
go through to get an absentee ballot
it's near impossible for an absentee
ballot to be fraudulent I'll just read
you the conclusion of their study he
writes every single study conducted on
voter fraud in the US shows that fraud
in absentee or mailin voting is
vanishingly small all but nonexistent at
the same time other Studies have
concluded that two strict requirements
disenfranchise a significant number and
that disenfranchisement
disproportionately affects historically
disadvantaged voters in other words the
choice here is between a very small
Improvement in integrity versus a
considerably larger harm to availability
and both are part of security I'd be
happy to take any questions thank you
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um I'm going to
temporarily recess um cacr 5 public
hearing and I'm going to open the public
hearing for House Bill 136 for the
purpose of introductions only um so
would I believe Maori Mr M who's
introducing 136 at I'm sorry not 136 418
excuse me 418 if I could read correctly
418 representative sellers this is for
introduction only folks then we're going
to go right back to cacr 5 I do this
because Tuesday is the busiest day for
State reps to meet so they're sitting
here not in their committee so it gets
them back to their committee and then we
go right back to the cacr 5 hearing
representative sellers I'm going to keep
you to five minutes please so no more
than five minutes on your introduction
okay I didn't know you want an
introduction or just to say I'm the bill
or you want my testimony on it right now
yeah go ahead and do it now so you can
go back to your committee if you're
meeting oh thank you uh good morning uh
committee members I'm representative
John cers from Bristol Bridgewater uh
graft and 10 and I'll I have handouts
for you and plus I also emailed you all
a copy of my testimony notes that I'm
just going to be talking to today so
this bill uh 418 I actually copied in
the uh New Hampshire Constitution part
one article 11 and I'm focusing on the
uh underscore area of the of the uh uh
part part 11 I mean article 11 and
especially on the part where it it's
actually bolded and it's saying they are
absent from the city or town of which
they are inhabitants or by reason of
physical disability I'm pointing that
out because it's in in this part here it
actually goes down to say the actual
reasons for an absentee ballot all right
we have qualifications and we have
reasons all right so I just want to make
sure that you you're looking at the
words and watching them because we have
qualifications and reasons and I also
listed here on my testimony all the
different years the this article 11 was
amended and also created and if you read
through those I'm not going to for
saving time if you read through those
you can see none of those have been
changed for reason doesn't mean it can't
be it's just none of them have been so
that's a Poss possibility that could
happen in the future and I also want to
state I'm not against absente voting
voting at all I just want to make sure
the people have the say and not just
legislators the governor attorney
general or Secretary of State I want the
people to say what are the reasons we
want for absentee ballots not just us
the legislators bring it back to the
people so again there uh our
constitution was clear only two reasons
to receive an absentee ballot it was
also clear changes were made to the
Constitution to expand who is qualified
to vote I'm just pointing these things
up because it's really different and uh
it goes down I'm just saying the general
court uh is required to make laws for
qualified voters to cast their ballots
and then the Constitution lists those
qualifications and reasons we should be
only we should be only legislating by
law all right we should be giving it
back to the people to allow them to
change that Constitution yes we have to
bring it up of course through a cacr
pass all through all the steps it has to
but then it goes on the ballot for the
people to decide all right from there
I'm going down to um ABS valot reasons
that have been expanded by law when only
in New Hampshire Constitution should be
legislators to be expanding the reasons
to vote by absente B in one pointing out
here is we're going from absentee from
the city or town in physical
disabilities this is what we have right
now that I could find whether concerns
about safety traveling in the storm the
pandemic which the Secretary of State
Bill Gardner and attorney general Gordon
McDonald issue a joint
memorandum uh on April 10
2020 again that that's they just said
they're going to change it in the how
it's going to be people weren't even get
a decision or or a vote a choice to vote
employment adult or child daycare
confinement prison and I didn't know
about this one attorney general's
address confidentiality program or are
protected by domestic violence so you
can see we've gone from two reasons in
the Constitution which clearly pointed
out to now we made laws saying these
things are in laws or we're allowing the
Secretary of State or the Attorney
General say hey this is how I'm defining
what disability is all right so going
down from there last two points if we
want to expand the eligibility
requirements who is eligible and reasons
to receive an El uh absentee B one we
should be bringing it to the people all
right again see it last
point we need to move uh HP 418 to UT to
pass to allow the people to consent to
changes control our reasons for absentee
voting and we may need to further def
further definitions around absentee from
the city in town and physical disability
what that actually means that's what
might need further uh
definition I hope that it was clear
enough and that's what I just want to
pass out and I do have literature if you
want to just have it excellent if you
could uh you you good good job on your
timing you get 20 seconds left your
literature just leave it on the front
table when you're done um are there any
questions uh for the sponsor of the bill
seeing none thank you represent put the
uh put that on that desk for me it's a
huge pet peeve of mind uh so I'm going
to recess the public hearing on um house
B 418 going to reopen the public hearing
on cacr 5 uh we're now on to Jean Barnes
welcome to election
law
hi good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Jean Barnes I'm
moderator of board two and conquered for
your information during the covid
outbreak we had over 500 absentee
ballots all wars in the city had
conquered with the permission of the
Attorney General's office and Secretary
of State met and counted our absentee
balance we took the register and we
highlighted every name so that we knew
that we had the absentee ballot for that
person it would have been literally
impossible for us on Election Day to
process over 500 absentee ballots during
the general election I had 142 we
started at 1:00 and we ended around
5: we take them very seriously each one
is
hang looked up opened carefully make
make sure everything is signed make sure
everything is in
order it would be almost impossible for
us if we had any more over 200 to
process so that's my testimony excellent
will you be taking questions from the
committee sure are there questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you Miss
Barnes thank you um next up is Kristen
Evans um Miss Evans you didn't write the
number five on your cacr so I'm gonna
without objection I'm going to put that
on your card for you I don't I don't
like marking up people's cards without
them knowing
thank you I'll be brief I have passed
out my testimony for your review so I'll
just go over some
highlights uh dear chair members of the
House election committee my name is
Kristen Evans and I am the policy
director for AEL New Hampshire an
organization dedicated to advancing the
civil and human rights of individuals
with disabilities across New Hampshire I
submit this testimony in strong support
of CAC c45 for individuals with
disabilities absente voting is often the
most reliable and accessible means of
participating in elections many
disability disab disabled individuals
face barriers to in-person voting
include Transportation difficulties and
health conditions that make public
spaces unsafe the current system which
requires voter to prove provide a
specific reason for requesting an
absentee ballot places an undo burden on
those who simply seek equal access to
The Ballot Box research demonstrates
that removing unnecessary restrictions
on absentee voting increases voter
participation particularly among
individuals with disabilities a report
from the US ele election assistance
commission found that in 2020 11% of
Voters with disabilities experienced
difficulties voting compared to only 4%
of non-disabled
Voters New Hampshire already employs
rigor means to verify absentee ballots
including signature matching and ballot
tracking systems these safeguards ensure
that every vote cast by mail is
legitimate while maintaining the
Integrity of our elections voting is a
fundamental right and the ability to
exercise that right should not depend on
one's health status Mobility or access
to Transportation the current
restrictions on absentee voting
disproportionately impact disab disabled
individuals seniors and those with
caregiving responsibilities expanding
absentee voting is not only a matter of
convenience it is a matter of equity and
Justice by passing cacr 5 New Hampshire
will join the majority of states that
recognize that no voter should have to
justify their need for an absentee
ballot this amendment would remove an
outdated barrier and bring our States
election laws in line with modern
principles of accessibility fairness and
inclusion for these reasons able New
Hampshire urges you to support C acr5
and ensure that all New Hampshire voters
including those with disabilities have a
fair and equitable opport opportunity to
participate in our democracy thank you
thank you and will you be taking
questions from the committee yes are
there questions from the committee
saying none thank you oh I'm sorry repr
PR Brian thank you uh I'm looking over
the form for requesting an absentee
ballot and there are a lot of options
here for why you need to request an
absentee ballot have you ever heard from
a person who said to you that they found
no option fit their need or they were
offended by any of them and could not
use this uh thank you for the question
um I have encountered people with
disabilities who don't feel that they
should have to disclose their disability
in order to receive an absentee
vote further questions from the
committee saying none thank you Miss EV
uh next up Kaylee
EST Kay it's so good to see you again so
good to see
um thank you chairman Barry and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Kaye of stadio I'm a Durham voter and
public policy fellow with open democracy
we're a nonpartisan nonprofit
representing 36,000 voters across the
state and I'm submitting testimony in
strong support of cacr 5 New Hampshire
is one of just 14 states that still
require an excuse to vote by absentee
this common Comm sense legislation would
bolster Democratic engagement in a truly
nonpartisan way policy change during the
height of the 2020 covid-19 pandemic
that allowed anyone concerned about the
virus to vote by absentee ballot Rec
resulted in record-breaking turnout with
roughly 60,000 more voters than the
previous presidential election
exercising their right to vote this is a
matter of meeting the needs of granite
Staters and not solely convenience in
the Live Free or Die State why should
the voter need to provide any reason to
vote by absentee ballot in 2018 57% of
Republicans across the country felt this
way compared to just 37% in
2024 citizens may have a variety of
individualized reasons that would
provoke them to vote by absentee ballot
whether that be because they don't want
to be bothered by either party
supporters on their way into their
polling place don't have the time to
stand in long lines or simply because it
enables them to ensure they cast their
vote before life gets in the way nobody
can predict a sick child a broken down
vehicle or a medical emergency that is
why no excuse absentee voting is a
uniquely bipartisan issue the ability to
vote by absentee ballot without an
excuse would allow hardworking BR
Granite Staters to more reliably perform
their civic duties and should be a top
priority for
Representatives state election officials
have argued in the past that this change
will be well within their capacity to
implement and oversee unless some grave
oversight has been made I therefore see
no reason not to support this bill and I
respectfully urge you to vote a to pass
on cicr 5 thank you thank you and will
be taking questions from the committee
yes are there questions from the
committee seeing none and
congratulations you are the closest to
your fully allotted time I think you got
within 3 seconds so it's going to be
hard to beat for other people um last up
is uh Henry kimowitz with the
ACLU good morning my name is Henry
clemento I'm the deputy legal director
of the American civil liberties Union of
New Hampshire I support cacr 5 um
historically about 9% of New Hampshire
voters vote absentee uh that number went
to about 30% in 2020 when we had
expanded absentee palting due to covid
so I expect that if this cacr passes
we're not going to see a dramatic
overnight shift in the number of people
using uh absentee ballots nonetheless I
think what we will see is reduce lines
on Election Day reduce traffic um the
the need perhaps for fewer election
officials and staffs which would uh
decrease cost for local election
officials
administering uh the elections because
they need fewer people I'd also say that
uh New Hampshire has a robust uh process
for uh evaluating absentee ballots
there's affidavits that people sign the
the processing is done in public the
ballots are counted in public um it's
it's um
and that process wouldn't change so we
wouldn't be like Washington and Oregon
where the votes would be counted in
Regional centers they'd still be
processed in the same place that they
are now just perhaps hopefully at a
greater scale this is really about um
moving New Hampshire elections into the
20th at least the 20th maybe the 21st
century and and to uh respond to a
question that uh representative prudo
O'Brien had asked a previous speaker
about missing reasons to vote absentee I
think the committee will notice that
illness is not uh an excuse to vote
absentee and so we just we really don't
want people coming in to vote when
they're sick but if you get the flu um
you're not disabled You're Not absent
you have no choice but to come in um
while sick spread germs and and vote in
person so I'm happy to take any
questions other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you I don't
believe I have any more pink cards does
anyone else wish to speak to cacr 5
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on CAC oh actually let me
read the let me read some some stats
here my apology I'm getting ahead of
myself all right CAC R5 online had 163
in support 70 opposition um in person
not speaking is 1 two 3 four five six
seven eight in support one against and
with that I will close the public
hearing on cacr 5 we will resume the
public hearing on uh HB
418 um and I'm going to recognize
representative Horgan uh for two
minutes thank you very much I continue
to be representative Timothy Horgan I
continue to represent straford County
District 10 the towns of Durham so I um
I oppose this bill I don't think there's
any need to eliminate such a large
number of the of the except exception
for absentee B voting I know it's a long
list but if you fall into one of these
categories uh you know it's you you uh
it makes a huge difference to you
because if you want to vote and you're
denied the right to vote that's an
extremely upsetting uh experience and
totally unfair although and actually I
actually have a bill which is in
criminal justice about guns at the
polling place um it's probably not going
anywhere but I even put in a uh a
provision in that one which would have
added another reason which is if you
don't want if you just can't bear to not
wear your gun at the polling place you
can vote absentee so but um you're
probably although that bill I can't
really speculate about what that
committee is doing but uh there's it's
more likely not to pass than the past so
I I the Constitutional argument which I
heard from the member a few minutes ago
I what it says in the constitution is a
it's a it's a floor so you at least have
to have absentee ballots for those two
reasons it's not that it's limited to
those two reasons and you know every one
of the these every one of these reasons
is extremely valid and they should stay
on the law books and of course uh I
would not and I would actually not be
totally opposed to no excuse absentee
voting but certainly um we should we
should certainly uh there's no none of
these excuses need to be delet deleted
from the the list of reasons why you
need an absentee ballot and
um yeah so that's uh so vote no on this
bill it's uh just it's uh was probably
also going to be challenged on
constitutional grounds because uh you
know people take the right to vote very
seriously I mean sometimes some
elections you wonder why I mean I know
sometimes I wonder why I bothered but uh
I'm still it's always better to vote
than not to vote so thanks okay thank
you will you be taking questions from
the committee are there questions from
the committee seeing none thank you okay
thanks next up is Betsy
Ferguson welcome to election law
why thank you this is my first time
providing public testimony so I'm happy
to be here and thank you for including
us I represent ex I represent myself and
I'm from exor New Hampshire I strongly
oppose uh HB 418 because it limits the
number of people that do need absentee
Bots from being able to vote as was
already mentioned uh um New Hampshire
ranks 50th among states that are have
access ease ease of access for voting
this would make make an already very
very very low barrier or bar even lower
it would it would remove um protections
for people that have work conflicts and
there are plenty of work conflicts going
around here people work two or three
jobs to be able to afford expensive
housing they uh have I members of my
family work
three-day uh 12-hour shifts which can
exclude ability to be in person and
that's a work conflict and people work
as commuters from uh Boston or other for
uh distances which make it difficult to
be here on that single day of
voting if we look at what uh What uh
excuses or permissions uh people in
states of 49 and 48 in terms of uh
difficulty in Access what they permit in
their uh absentee ballots in addition to
what we already have they allow anyone
65 were older to have an absentee ballot
these are number 48 and 49 Mississippi
and Alabama in terms of difficulty in
voting so excluding more voters is not
the way to go these states also provide
permission for caregivers those with
illness those with disabilities
caregivers of um individuals with or
family members of uh individuals with
illness people who have experienced
death in their family within 5 days
there's a whole host of reasons that
people cannot attend on the single day
of voting so making this more
restrictive is denying citizens rights
to vote thank you will you be taking
questions from the committee absolutely
are there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um next up is
fidelma McCain did I get that right no
not at all all right you're not the it's
not the first thing to be butchered by
me and it won't be the last probably not
even today my name's hard it's fidelma
McKenna good morning and I'm here to
oppose Bill 418 um I'm a certified nurse
Midwife in in New Hampshire and I work
in a hospital my sweetheart who can't be
here with me today because he's working
in the O is an operating room nurse we
work 12 and 24-hour shifts um and I'm
greatly appreciate the accommodations
Allowed by New Hampshire that have
allowed me to participate in the
Democratic process as well as show up
for my scheduled work shift in the past
I'm distressed that this bill would
remove accommodations for workers
scheduled to work long hours on voting
day as well as parents and elder care
providers in the imuno compromised I
have as much right to access exercise my
Democratic right to vote as anyone else
even if I'm required to show up to work
and protect the health and lives of
citizens on New Hampshire on voting day
additionally as a healthcare provider
the more options we provide for voting
so that fewer potentially contagious
people are in the same room at the same
time is just better health public health
and Common Sense thank you so much um I
won't be taking questions that's my
favorite okay uh with that we're going
to recess uh house B 114 I'm going to
open up the public hearing for house B
136 for the purpose of introduction um
uh representative meori we're only doing
five minutes because we have 75 bills in
election law um so you have five minutes
to introduce and then we're going right
back to
418 thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee my name is Jim
Maori from Northampton um introducing
this bill sending the um and and thank
you for the opportunity in all
seriousness uh the intent of this bill
comes from a real life situation it
happened in Northampton uh where a
resident came in uh his his wife had
just flown in with their son's absentee
ballot uh he ran to the polls got there
two minutes before it closed and he
wasn't able to hand in his son's
absentee ballot the moderator asked me
if there was any reason why we couldn't
extend the deadline for accepting
absentee ballots on the poll uh at the
polling location to the end of polls so
I looked into it there are two states um
as far as I can tell that uh that limit
the uh deadline for when you can submit
absentee ballots to 5:00 pm it seems
like most of them Most states extend
that period to 800 PM um a few uh and
and and I submit that everybody here
knows infinitely more than me uh it
seems that there's a wide range of times
where you could submit at the day of
poll so we're just suggesting here that
in order to get the greatest amount of
participation that extending the period
from 5:00 p.m. to the close of polls in
New Hampshire um will
infranca I'm willing to take questions
love it great testimony representative
PM O'Brien I'm I'm the question lady
today thank you very much did this
person who had the absentee ballot have
an opportunity to mail it in prior to
this
happening yes they did
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um thank that's it
that's simple all right with that I'm
going to recess the public hearing on
House Bill 136 we're going to resume the
public hearing on House Bill 418 uh next
up on House Bill 418 is Bonnie
Bruno welcome to election law
um I'm mean I am opposed to 48 excuse me
I'm opposed to 418 and other restrictive
bills when it comes to um
elections Republicans held legislatures
across the country and here in New
Hampshire on a crusade to restrict
suppress and disenfranchise voters as
demonstrated by House Bill age 418 and
the others that are going to be heard
today such subversive efforts have the
intent to undermine and weaken our
democra democracy not strengthen it
citizen voting is the Cornerstone of
democracy of our American
democracy a political party that
believes that their policies and
platforms are popular with the majority
of Voters would not attempt to restrict
suppress or disenfranchise voters but
instead that political party would
Champion making voting more accessible
to its citizens for its New Hampshire
voters that same political party sure in
their conf and conviction in their
political agenda and ideologies would
introduce voter bills that would
encourage early voting that would
encourage melin voting assist people
with disabilities to cast their votes
make it easier for parents working
people students seniors to vote make it
easier for residents who will simply be
out of town on vacation for Pete's sakes
to vote I mean pickle ball Camp voting
it's a tough
choice that same party may even go so
far is to protect against unlawful voter
purges pickle ball is a thing right um
prohibit voter intimidation in deceptive
practices ban partisan Jerry manering
and I mean ban Jerry manering such a
political party would Champion the
freedom to vote such a party sure in
their political agenda and ideologies
would have a rallying call let the
people
vote thank you will you be taking
questions uh no but one thing I did want
to say was um I appreciate that public
hearings are grueling and timec
consuming they you're a part of a
healthy democracy and I appreciate them
I I I'm totally with you and trust me I
wish I wish we could go longer because I
enjoy them believe it or not but um well
when you're in two minutes and you have
to read fast you're like you actually
nailed you weren't the best today you
had 12 seconds left um you weren't the
best you were almost there and I despite
the fact that we're probably on separate
side of the I love the fire anybody
knows me like I love I love the fire no
matter what side it's coming from so
beauti thank you for being here um I'll
take a question oh excellent look at
that and I've I've already derailed my
own hearing
represent I only have 12 seconds so okay
would would you not when I'm asking
questions go on go on um would you
submit your written testimony so we have
the full impact of it uh yeah you just
want to give it to the clerk you can
okay she's the she's the clerk my give
that to the clerk your right my left any
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you and thank you for
joining us I I hope I see you back thank
you um next up is Sue
nastasi welcome to election
law um if anybody has anything you want
to hand in for this bill if you just
bring it to representative gasovi now
that'll actually make things go a little
faster so if you have written testimony
you want to submit just bring it to the
representative now um and that'll save
us a little
time you get to press the center
button there you go welcome to election
law and uh Mr chairman Ross Barry and
election law
committee um thank you for letting me
speak these uh a couple minutes or so um
I am writing and hopefully I'm glad that
I'm able to speak to oppose House Bill
418 and I scribbled a Little Couple
notes I wanted to add
but the same way I vote is private who I
choose uh in the
voting um it should be also
reasoning that I must and I want to
request an absentee ballot is my uh
personal business and
choice um you know it's very um private
who I choose to vote
for and uh you know people do have uh
you know particulars that they really
have that they can't make it on that day
and it and can
change such as my own experience was
several years ago when I had to stay
unexpectedly at work and Miss voting day
and you know staying uh longer at work
every so often happened but it's uh was
fairly
unpredictable uh we kind of go in spurts
so if I was able to get
uh an absentee ballot without any uh
great
details that would have been so much
better it was upsetting that I didn't
get to vote that day and please do not
forget how voters who requested an
absentee ballot during the worst of
covid had to choose disabil even though
a voter right in front of me when I was
uh helping at Town
Hall um not
disabled and I realized uh you know
there was a lot of uh uh quick
decisions uh to
cover uh voting and procedures during
the worst of co uh but still uh when you
would have to tell a registered voter
they're definitely not disabled but it's
necessary to cross that check that
off and so you know voters were
apprehensive and kind of suspicious uh
of uh their personal
information and uh you know why do I
there was uh several why do I have to uh
check off disability I'm fine Mr s I'm
gonna have to ask you to bring your
remarks to a conclusion okay
sorry and if there was reasonable and
sensible options to choose from on the
absentee application I wouldn't have had
that experience I spoke of but I
appreciate your time and I'm an
Undeclared registered voter excent and
will you be taking questions from the
committee sure are there questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
thank you next up is Kristen Evans
thank you again honorable chair and uh
committee members I will be brief I have
passed out my written testimony for your
review um thank you for the opportunity
to testify in opposition of House Bill
418 for the record again my name is
Kristen Evans and I the director of
policy for AEL New Hampshire AEL is a
disability Justice organization and we
are nonp parters in nonprofit
organization that fights for the civil
and human rights of children and adults
with
disabilities this legislation is an
affront to the very Foundation of our
democracy the right to vote is not a
privilege reserved only for those with
the flexibility to stand in line on
Election Day it is a fundamental right
that must be accessible to all eligible
voters most concerning this bill places
an undue burden on people with
disabilities while the legislation still
allows absentee voting for disability
related reasons narrowing the law
isolates and stigmatizes voters with
disabilities the ability to access
absentee ballots should not require
individuals to disclose their medical
conditions nor should we create a system
that forces voters to prove the
legitimacy of their personal obligations
before casting their ballot restricting
absentee voting is a direct attack on
the civic participation of those already
marginalized in our electoral system in
a state that provi that Prides itself on
voter engagement and participation HB
418 moves Us in the wrong direction at
AEL New Hampshire we believe in building
a New Hampshire that is inclusive and
Equitable hb14 is neither I urge this
committee to reject this harmful
legislation and instead focus on
policies that expand rather than
restrict the right to vote our democracy
is the strongest when every eligible
voter can participate without
unnecessary obstacles standing in their
way thank you thank you and will we be
taking questions from the committee sure
are there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you next up
Joan Dari Dari
Dari welcome to election
law thank you to the chair and the
committee to give me give me this
opportunity to speak my name is Joan
dargy and I'm speaking on behalf of the
New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association and we are opposed to this
bill basically the language that's been
added um since 2020 has um allowed those
voters that are very black and white to
be able to find a reason on here I'm
taking care of a loved one I'm not out
of town but due to the fact that I need
to I'm a caretaker and can't leave that
person alone at all um it it a lot they
feel like they are doing they are
legally um able to request an app
ballot
um and taking these options away would
make it very um stringent and those
people that are that are very concerned
with doing everything legally would no
longer be able to request an
absentee that's it okay will you be
taking questions sure are there
questions from the
committee yes representative
Burnham thank you um you had mentioned
about uh a caretaker
um we all pretty much know when voting
is I personally take care of someone 247
but if I knew I had to be somewhere
would you be able to find someone for
the hour to two hours to go and vote is
my question so I I personally myself
took care of my dad for 15 years that
had Alzheimer's and there would come
those times when you could not get
anybody
else and when you're the sole caretaker
you you don't know what kind of
condition they're going to be in that
day and they might not accept somebody
that they do not recognize some days
were good some days were bad so really
in that case that that doesn't really
work with somebody say with Alzheimer's
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you next up is Liz
tantarelli the League of Women Voters
thank you chairman Barry for this
opportunity to speak I'm Liz torelli I'm
president of the League of Women Voters
of New Hampshire and as you can guess I
oppose this bill because our mission is
to empower voters and this bill does
just the opposite but I want to talk
since so many other people have cited
the specific instances in which people
uh need to vote absentee in in order to
exercise their fundamental right I would
like to point out that this legislature
has over the past 10 or 15 years enacted
some very positive legislation and I
would hate to see you now go back on
that for instance after we had terrible
storms for three years on town meeting
day you enacted a law that allowed
people to vote the day before at their
Town Hall a vote and absentee ballot
because it would have been too dangerous
or impossible for them if they drove
crappy little cars like mine to get to
the
polls sorry that was an an inappropriate
word to use I apologize and I will have
to apologize to my car when I get out
there too um you also change the form so
that people who are incarcerated for a
misdemeanor or a waiting trial can check
off an appropriate form uh box on the to
get an absentee ballot which is their
right you also recognized um that the
unpredictable work hours of people shows
they're being prudent when they apply
for an absentee ballot that is they're
not sure they'll be out of town but they
recognize this is a problem so please
don't go back on the good work that this
very legislature performed over the
years on my written testimony on the
flip side of it I have listed the the
description that's on the Secretary of
of state's website currently about who
may vote absentee and below that I
copied a letter uh that was given to me
by somebody where I now live I went to
the old people's home now I now live in
a Continuing Care retirement community
that sounds better and uh a few days
after the election one of the other
residents gave me this letter she had
sent it to the local ballot clerks in
Ward 12 in Manchester she she and her
husband wanted to vote in person and
they were really daunted by the long
lines I was in line for 90 minutes in
that same polling place that morning m t
emth ask you to begin to conclude your
remarks please I will so I urge you to
read that letter On The Backs side of my
testimony thank you and yes I will take
questions if there are any are there
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you thank you next up is Rebecca
sky with the New Hampshire Commission on
Aging hello thank you for your time uh
my name is Rebecca Sky I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire State
Commission on Aging it's a legislative
commission created to advise the
governor and legislature on issues
related to aging so uh the Commission on
Aging advises against removing several
previous abs voter justifications older
adults are a growing proportion of our
communities from 2020 to 2030 the
percentage of New Hampshire citizens age
65 or older will grow from 19% to 27%
becoming nearly 30% of our state's
population weather related concerns are
not an
insignificant uh uh for older adults
data compiled by from the New Hampshire
falls risk reduction task force
indicates that New Hampshire in New
Hampshire falls are the leading cause of
of death for older adults age 65 plus
with 249 deaths in 2020 in 2019 almost
13,000 older adults went to emergency
departments and over 4,300 older adults
were admitted to New Hampshire hospitals
for fall related injuries costing um um
uh cost exceeding $294
million uh this commission suggests
encouraging older adults to consider
absentee ballots when faced with um
encouraging more older adults to
consider absentee ballots when faced
with inclement weather rather than
requiring them to take a risk to exerise
exercise their right to vote moving on
to unpaid caregivers these are people
who care for their spouses their
children their friends um uh I mean it's
uh of older adults family caregivers
fill an essential role in our fractured
long-term services and support system a
2023 ARP report suggested that in our
state in 2021 there were uh 100 168,000
unpaid caregivers in New Hampshire
providing an economic value of collectiv
leave almost 2.8 billion many caregivers
cannot leave the person they are caring
for unless they can um uh find another
qualified person who can and this could
be exceptionally challenging as you
heard um many would not be providing the
care themselves if if they if there were
other options and finally I just want to
mention about healthcare workers that
was raised already many work 12-hour
shifts and and they care for all of us
thank you for your time thank you will
you be taking questions from the
committee absolutely are there questions
from the committee thank you um thank
you so much next up is Christina fatrick
actually hold on we're going to pause
because we're going to open up another
hearing we are going to be able to dig
out of this hole before lunch because
there's not a lot of pink cards to the
remaining bills we're just 418 is taking
a little bit of churn and burn um so I'm
going to recess the public hearing on
418 and we're going to open up the
public hearing on 158 for the purpose of
introduction only representative Hill I
think you've heard my speech about how
you get five
minutes you know you don't have a you
don't have one that I I would uh I think
I would trip
over you actually managed to have a name
that's shorter than mine which is
impressive thank you very much uh for
the record I am representative Greg Hill
I'm the chair of legislative
Administration uh although I used to
serve on this Committee in the vice
chair seat um I wanted to introduce you
and give you a opportunity to maybe
shift gears a little bit away
from absentee ballot on the day of
election or the week before this shifts
this bill shifts the thinking to 60 days
after the
election um and deals with a very small
slice of the uh of the absente ballot
world uh it Deals Only with
mailin um applications that are
requesting a ballot to be mailed to an
address other than the address on the
checklist and if on your package uh OS
kind of put together this in a strange
way but on the back of the first page
you'll see a chart and that's what I
want to uh concentrate my testimony
on um this is information actual
information from uh 2016 election um we
gathered it uh with at then it was the
dep um deputy secretary of state scandin
um so that tells you gives you a little
of the history um but we had uh we
noticed in the law while I was sitting
on Election law that um there was no
opportunity for the Secretary of State
to review um where absentee ballots were
mailed so we asked the uh help America
vote ACT people in conquered if they
would prepare an analysis of the 2016
absentee
ballots what you see here um is just the
absentee ballot addresses or information
gathered from those absentee ballots
that were mailed outside New Hampshire
to Common addresses and not including
Hava uh U aava um or diplomatic ballots
um these are just strict stly absentee
ballots that were requested by mail and
sent outside New Hampshire to Common
addresses and you'll notice from this
chart there are quite a few that are
sent to Common addresses so um the very
first line says 23 ballots were sent to
a single uh unnamed address outside New
Hampshire and then it goes all the way
down two times 21 ballots were sent to
the same address three times 19 ballots
2 * 7 17 ballots and we have no idea
where those ballots were being sent and
the and um Secretary of State's office
doesn't know where those ballots were
sent it is not as I've said here in
summary this is not proof of voter fraud
but it is certainly something that we we
should look into um I think either party
would be interested in knowing whether
those 23 ballots were sent to an address
that happens to be a um an
RNC um Committee in Dayton Ohio or uh or
even the 21 ballots being sent to a a um
a DNC uh committee room in Mobile
Alabama um CU un tighten um but it is uh
it's worthy of Investigation that's what
this bill does is it requires the
Secretary of State to have access in
order to prepare a report showing where
the 20 most common uh addresses were
where multiple ballots were sent and
with that I'll close my testimony and
take questions if you have them are
there questions from the committee
representative
Lane uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Hill for taking my
question um you focused your testimony
on the reporting piece but didn't really
address what's in Roman numeral one uh
which is making it available to the
public and my concern is with privacy so
I'm I'm asking if you considered privacy
concerns because this is an aggregate
report not an individual report that's
correct um thank you for your question
the um the idea of that um these would
be set up um privately was um back in
history when there was cons conc Ern
that people requesting absentee ballots
would be they used they actually used to
be posted right on the door of the
voting place um so it seemed logical for
uh nefarious people to take a look at
who's not going to be in town at the
time and uh and and rob their houses so
um that was that was the impetus with
the idea originally to to make the these
lists private that's why we've gone to
the 60 days quite frankly to make it um
after the time that uh the election has
has been um handled I have no problem if
the if the committee wants to make it
180 days or 365 days it really doesn't
matter to me the point is that um that
we would have the information be able to
look through for where these addresses
were that's the the critical part for me
I should also point out that in within
the legislation is the is the caveat for
those people that have um hidden
addresses for protective U Services so
that's in there further questions from
the committee seeing none thank
you repres
C yes thank you I was just wondering
whether this was intended
to um be available for the general
public to inspect or just Secretary of
State um
truly I
I thank you for your question I really
don't care um if it is available uh to
the Secretary of State you'll notice in
here um I've not indicated where that
report would actually be sent or given
um I I truly don't care if uh I want him
to prepare the report and I want him to
determine whether there are addresses
that are of concern and I would assume
um any any interest on his part um would
then be turned over to the Attorney
General's office so uh whether it's
private or not um if if the committee
would prefer that it remain strictly in
the secretary uh State's hands I'm fine
with that um but uh whether it goes to
the public or not doesn't matter to
me further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you very
much always a pleasure to be at an
election law yeah we got a much better
Vice chair now I'm just saying but um
going to uh it's okay representative
Hill and our are friends it's
okay I'm gonna going to recess uh going
to recess House Bill 158 the public
hearing and reopen the public hearing on
House Bill 114 418 Christina Fitzpatrick
is next with AARP
good morning chairman Barry and members
of the committee my name is Christina
Fitzpatrick I'm the state director for
AARP New Hampshire and I am here today
to testify against HB
418 and it would eliminate many of the
qualified reasons for requesting an
absentee ballot I want to focus on the
one about um people with caregiving
responsibilities there are 168,000
people people in the state who take
responsibility for caring for an adult
loved one with either a chronic or an
acute health condition these are people
who fill a very demanding role that can
be very difficult it can be um there
might be a case where somebody cannot
leave their loved one um because the the
person has such extreme needs and
finding somebody who can take care of
the person who can fulfill those needs
can be difficult if not impossible
especially given the workforce shortages
in our state in addition people with
chronic health conditions can easily
have something happen on Election Day
that would um require a doctor's visit a
hospitalization or otherwise impede the
caregiver from um going to the voting
Place life is unpredictable and people
who want to make sure that they can cast
a ballot should be allowed to do so I
urge the committee to consider the
negative impact that this bill would
have on family caregivers and vote
against House Bill
418 will you be taking questions from
the committee yes are there questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
next up is Olivia zinc with open
democracy on behalf of Bob
Perry uh good morning members of the
committee for the record my name is
Olivia zinc um from Franklin New
Hampshire um but I'm reading Bob Perry's
um uh testimony from straford uh it
should be in front of you so I'm just
going to paraphrase um he writes in
strong opposition to House Bill 418 um
citing article one of New Hampshire
Constitution the words are in front of
you um those 27 words lie an important
principle that is more guiding it is a
bold principle that establishes the
relationship between elected officials
and their constituents heavily weighted
towards the people ensuring that people
have
freedom however we've made progress
since
1784 um federal state local governments
case law Goodwill um have ultimately
allowed Americans to vote including the
inclusion of women um this bill um does
much more than just amend current law it
repeals existing statutes that have been
in place for many years um it makes
voting more burdensome for granite
Staters requiring in-person voting
except for
absentee um if except for if you're
absent on voting day or a disability um
repealing religious observers um
employment obligation storm related
consequences personal travel Child Care
obligation and care for infirmed
adults current law resulting from House
Bill
1569 repeals voting rights
eligible um to article one um together
they impact our health safety and
freedom this bill also eligible uh
impacts eligible voters especially young
and elderly Republican and Democrat and
Undeclared um that are among your
constituents this bill is a re reacted
of Rights generally have no place in our
shared democracy um Bob urges itl um and
I just want to share quickly a personal
story um my dad before he passed was a
retired veteran um he was not disabled
but he was wheelchair bound in his later
life and he would not check off a box to
say he was disabled because he felt very
strongly what that meant and so I do
think that restricting it just to those
D disabled will impact people um that
are in the category of my father a
retired veteran who is wheelchair bound
you know my my dad's now no longer with
us but um um people like him will be
harmed I'm happy to take any questions
thank you are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you next up
is David Trumble from
where thank you Mr chairman and
committee members my name is David
Trumble from where I just want to go to
the original speaker who said the
purpose of this bill was that the
constitution laid out two Provisions for
absentee ballots and that it shouldn't
be up to you to add anything on it
should only be up to a constitution it
should be up to the people that's what
the first Speaker said so I just was
checking the constitution of our state
there's a difference between a floor and
a ceiling in the Constitutional article
11 there is some things that are
ceilings no person shall have the right
to vote if they committed treason so the
Constitution has Provisions in there
that say no then the next provision is
the general court shall provide by law
for voting for qualified voters and lays
out the two categories for absentee
ballot that's a floor had the
Constitution intended it to be for those
two and only for those two it would have
said the general court shall provide for
these voting for only these two reasons
I mean they clearly did it when it came
to setting ceilings for treason and
other things there's nothing in the
Constitution that says you can't the
legislature couldn't
extend those categories and if the
Constitution wanted it to be that way
only two it would have said to just like
it has with the ceiling for crimes like
treason and things like that so I just
wanted to point out that the original
Logic for this bill doesn't really hold
the Constitution does not set a sealing
on those two examples it's a floor thank
you will you be taking questions of
course yes sir actually found your
argument to be very thought provocating
for what it's worth don't necessarily
say I agree with it but it's definitely
thought-provoking um other questions
from the committee it's just a new art
we haven't heard that one yet it's a
nice one all right thank you Mr Trumble
um next up is Kaylee
estra it's the E it's the EF gets me I
got the stutter is what it's what James
me up the EF gets
me I'm I'm gonna do it EST
esto esto esto yes
esto yay okay thank you chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Kaye of stro I am a Durham
voter and public policy fellow with open
democracy we're a nonpartisan nonprofit
representing 36,000 voters across the
state and I am submitting testimony and
vehement opposition to HB 418 this bill
is a blatant attempt to disenfranchise
voters across the state and it does not
seek to pretend otherwise New
Hampshire's eligibility requirements for
voting by absentee are already some of
the most restrictive in the country and
hp48 seeks to go even further it removes
religious observ work and child care
obligations and even extreme weather
events like snowstorms as valid reasons
for receiving an absentee ballot the
unfortunate reality is that not everyone
has the luxury to be able to take off
work to show up in person at their
polling place this does not mean they do
not still deserve to exercise their
constitutional right to vote this bill
is the latest in a flurry of attempts to
make it harder for granite Staters to
vote under the false pretense that
voting by absentee is somehow less
secure in fact as representative Lane
mentioned before the Brennan Center
notes that cases of voter fraud related
to absentee are so rare that it is more
likely that someone will be struck by
lightning enacting restrictions on
absentee voting just 5 years after
record-breaking voter turnout was
attributed to their widespread use is a
clear attempt to stifle the voices of
the electorate and I urge you to vote HB
418 at expedient to legislate thank you
thank you Mr sto um are will you be
taking questions from the committee yes
are there questions from the committee
from Mr stao
got it all right seeing n thank you I
was just trying to reinforce it in my
brain next up is Matt
amian with 603
forward morning chairman Barry members
of the House election law committee
happy to uh be here today for the first
time of the session my name is Matt
musian I'm the advocacy engagement
director for 603 Ford a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization dedicated to
educating activating and empowering
young people across our state I live in
Claremont myself I'm here to testify
today in opposition to House Bill 418
which would unnecessarily restrict
access to absentee ballots in the
circumstances under which New Hampshire
residents can vote absentee uh this
change would disproportionately impact
young working age granted Staters
especially with those uh who have
families or caregiving responsibilities
uh for example parents who work long
hours or have multiple jobs would be
forced to misw work in order to vote in
person which honestly just may not be
feasible for many especially those in uh
low income or rural areas and as you've
heard caregivers who are already
juggling demanding responsibilities at
home would face a similar challenge
these groups are already among the most
vulnerable when it comes to voting
access and House Bill 418 would create
further barriers making it even harder
for them to participate in the
Democratic process absentee voting has
been secure reliable process for years
doesn't benefit one party over another
but rather ensures that all voters are
able to have the opportunity to
participate regardless of their ability
to show up and vote in person winter
storms natural disasters and other
unforeseen circumstances can prevent
people from voting safely uh in this
bill's repeal of absentee voting during
winter storm warnings could strip of an
important Safeguard to ensure that f
have the ability to write uh the ability
to vote without putting their safety at
risk um by further narrowing already
restrictive qualifications this bill
could prevent people for who have
legitimate reasons for not voting uh at
all this bill could particularly hurt
young families working parents
caregivers who are already facing
challenges uh balancing their personal
and professional lives um and for these
reasons I ask you to vote against House
Bill 418 I would take any questions are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank Youk um is anyone here
to introduce 217 I didn't see
representative Lynn or um Senator gray
okay fine we'll keep going then um next
up is McKenzie Taylor from America
votes good morning R the committee uh my
name is McKenzie Taylor I'm the uh
campaigns director at the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights which is a
project of America votes um we are here
today in opposition to House Bill 418 as
a nonpartisan Coalition one of our core
goals is that ever in values is that
every Gran stator should have the right
to vote um under this legislation folks
who are unable to vote on Election Day
because of some of the provisions that
are being removed or would be removed
from the law may not be able to vote at
all uh because they are unable to make
it in person but they no longer have an
excuse under the law to be able to vote
absente um and we're very concerned
about limiting that access uh this
includes you know folks who have been
talked about today parents and other
caregivers especially who are full-time
caregivers or have unforeseen
circumstances come up as can happen in
full-time caregiving no longer able to
be a vote absentee um also people who
are working and have long shifts like
nurses and doctors um I've submitted
written testimony from Paul King III of
eing who is a career firefighter um and
talks about the lengthy shifts um under
this bill if folks are only absent or
disabled but think about the absence um
part of the bill um from the town they
are no longer able to vote absentee we
have folks like doctors firefighters
police officers other First Responders
who might be in the town they are not
absent from their Town however they are
working an extended shift or on call
beyond the hours of the polling place
and under this legislation those folks
would not be able to anymore have a box
to check to be able to cast ballot um
absentee so we already post this bill
because this simp it simply seems to be
just restricting who can vote
restricting the options of folks who
should be able to vote because they are
eligible to do so um and we ask that you
oppose it um and I'm happy to take
questions uh are there questions from
the committee none and you get the award
you had three seconds left so you you've
thank you I think that's that's uh roll
that over to later we we are doing you
can have your three seconds later sure
uh we are doing prices rights rules so
if you go over it doesn't count um all
right last up is Henry ktz from the
ACLU good morning good morning I'm Henry
clemento I'm the deputy legal director
of the American civil liberties of Union
of New Hampshire we oppose this bill for
two reasons um by removing all these
excuses that people use to vote absentee
this is an attack on the right to vote
it's also an attack on religious liberty
because it prevents people from uh
complying with religious obligations
that currently would allow them to vote
absentee and now would require them to
vote in person and then just personally
I'm a dad of a feral three-year-old um
who goes to school in the woods in Maine
and um on Election Day in 2024 he was
sick um I think those of you who have
small children in your lives know that
people get sick very frequently when
they are three and very frequently in
the winter time he was sick my wife
who's an assistant professor at uh UNH
law had uh full-time work obligations
and so there I was trying to figure out
how I was going to vote and take care of
a very angry and misbehaving
three-year-old um and how am I going to
get him to watch TV and drink uh drink
pedite while taking him to the polls so
um people have talked about the impact
that this has on caregivers but just
from personal experience it's real so we
oppose this bill I'm happy to take any
questions are there questions from the
committee seeing none um thank you Mr
Richard I don't have a card for you but
you did raise your
hand okay I still can't find it you U
please come give your testimony real
fast and then but if you could fill out
the pink card after you're done um so we
can conclude this but I don't want to
that's why you went after the lobby so I
didn't know about you the lobby always
go last in my committee no problem thank
you so much for hearing me again um let
me cover this quickly the backstory that
you need to hear is the Supreme Court
has already ruled on this matter and
before the Civil war or during the Civil
War the issue was raised can the
legislature authorize absentee voting
and they said no World War I same issue
they go back to the Supreme Court for an
advisory opinion and the court tells
them we told you 50 years ago the
legislature has no authority to create
absentee voting 1942 instead they got
the news and they went ahead and put the
provisions in there in 1942 to amend our
state constitution so uh PRI even though
prior testimony is alluded to the fact
that there are these other exemptions
they got there by Amendment so my point
to this committee this morning is simple
if it took an amendment to the state
constitution to change and create the
two exemptions we have then I would
recommend that regardless of what you
think about the those who are against
the legislation the solution is a cacr
simple if you want to change and Grant
more power look we're not a democracy
we're a constitutional republic part one
first uh of the Bill of Rights says very
clearly all government of right not some
all government of right originates from
the people is founded in their consent
the last sentence in the state
constitution provides that the document
can't be changed without the consent of
the people so that's really the Nexus of
my why I'm in support of the bill we
should only have the two Provisions this
body is only permitted to pass statutes
and regulations controlling the
elections that are contained in the
state constitution thank you questions
other questions from the committee
seeing none oh I'm sorry representative
Pro did you raise your hand are you're
putting your glasses on okay um thank
you thank you Mr Richard all right with
that was anyone else wish to speak to
House Bill 418 seeing none thank you I'm
going to uh signed up on the blue sheet
is one in favor seven against that did
not speak um I don't count we don't
count people if you speak you don't sign
the blue you're not supposed to sign the
blue sheet um and then online I'm sorry
I don't know why I clicked off of it
that was my fault online there were 57
in support and 1,82 opposed so a little
upsid online um with that I'm going to
close the public hearing for House Bill
418 going to reopen the house bill uh
the public hearing for House Bill 136
extending the time period for delivery
aty balance from 5:00 p.m. uh to close
of polls and I will recognize up uh we
only have two pink cards for
136 so I'm going to recognize uh we have
three pink cards for 13 meriz Tina gilo
from the town of
Daring Gilford Tina Gilford excuse
me and we're still on our two-minute
rule even though we're on a new bill
because we got to we got to play catchup
my name is Tina Guilford I'm the town
clerk in Derry
um thank you for hearing my
testimony so in November at 7:15 p.m. um
my pole workers threw their arm up in
the air looking for the clerk so I come
over and there's this woman who's in
tears so her daughter goes to college in
Rhode Island she had gone down that
previous weekend and she had picked up
her daughter's absentee ballot she had
promised her daughter that she'd drop it
off at Town Hall on Monday and she
forgot so she figured she'd bring it
with her when she voted she was supposed
to come earlier in the day to vote but
got caught up in something at work and
voted voted on her way home so she came
in she voted and after she voted she
wanted to turn in her daughter's
absentee ballot and I had to stand there
and tell this woman I am so
sorry I I I can't accept the ballot it
is after 5:00
p.m. and after she railed at me and
yelled at me about this arbitrary rule
that she seemed to think the town of
Derry had instituted um I explained to
her that it's state
statute and I encouraged her to reach
out to our state
representatives um to get the law
changed um and that if ever this uh came
up I would support it well last Thursday
she came into town hall she licensed her
dog and she goes do you remember me and
I said I do and she goes I heard there's
a bill and I said I know to extend SP
the time I'm going to be in conquered
anyway I will testify in support so I do
know that there are some clerks who
don't like this bill and some other
election officials who might not like it
all the way to the end of the polls um
for this resident who was
affected um trying to do the right thing
to hand deliver her daughter's ballot
because it probably wouldn't have made
it in time in the mail from Rhode Island
I am here in support and I will take any
questions are questions from the
committee representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh my question is do
you anticipate this um in the longterm
uh having a lot of ballots coming in at
the last minute that would delay the
close of polls I don't really think so
we don't get a lot of ballots I mean we
had over 18,000 voters in November and
we had a handful of ballots delivered on
Election Day um I think most people get
them into the clerk you know the day
before um I I I don't know that this is
going to be huge uh I just do know that
this poor woman was heartbroken for
herself and her daughter um and in
trying to get her daughter's vote in
just missed the deadline further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you next up is Joan Dari
uh after that will be Daniel
Healey Joan
dargy New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association and as Tina mentioned we are
in support of this bill there was
concern on behalf of multiple clerks
that having it up until the time the
close of polls could be um problematic
so we were just suggest ing an amendment
of maybe up to a half hour before the
polls
close because at obviously when the
polls are closing we're all very busy
trying to get ready for accounting and
if people are trying to find me to
submit an absentee that could delay the
process okay will you be taking
questions sure any other questions from
the
committee representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question and this is sort of a
followup to the previous speaker um if
you if we limit it in any way to before
the polls close are there going to be
some people that would be affected
because they came in at the last minute
or they were waiting in line at 7 o'cl
when the polls
close
um if well the poll if they're waiting
in line the polls don't close until
they've at the last person's voted well
until the last person's gotten through
the line I should say forther questions
from the committee representative P
O'Brien thank you for coming and thank
you for your testimony it's very
interesting this the situation um but if
we amended it to half an hour before the
polls close I think I have the same
concerns as representative C wouldn't it
create the same problem that we are
seeking to
fix that somebody could come in at 7:30
if the polls close at 88 and then be
told sorry you're too late and then
they' the same exact problem but there
is some responsibility on behalf of the
absentee voters I mean they can get
those ballots so much in
advance and I I do understand there are
issues and we we don't have that many
but if we say that we're going to allow
until polls close what I would be afraid
of is an entire group of say college
students and durm all saying we can drop
these off at 8 o'cl although it
shouldn't be them dropping it off
because they shouldn't be there but
I don't know there's I'm just trying to
look out for it is a very busy time and
we have a lot of forms to fill out at
the end of the night and we are
preparing to get organized so that we
are publicly counting all these ballots
in front of everybody and having even
three people show up with an absentee
ballot at 8:00 could be disruptive to
that process further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you next up
is Daniel Healey um after that is Kaye
esto uh Dan hilly nashwa city clerk um I
just want to kind of echo what Joan just
uh mentioned um I am in favor of this
bill I would like it to have some type
of buffer before the end of the polls
still giving the voters additional time
to turn in their ballots but also giving
the election workers um that little
buffer and I say that because in Nowa we
have Wards we have nine Wards and during
the state primary election the post
office um they were instructed to bring
the ballots to uh city clerk's office
and we would disperse them um they did
not do that at 5:00 p.m. they or close
to 5: they brought them all to one
location so my fear is that if the
ballots are dropped off at the wrong
location we need time to get them to the
other location I think 30 minute buffer
would allow us to do that so we had
ballots that were meant for say Ward one
brought to Ward seven the post office
not realizing that um there are
different ballots uh depending on the
location depending on the ward so I have
a fear that if it's right at the close
of polls and something like that happens
where they're all brought to that um one
spot that they're not going to get
dispersed to the other locations prior
to the close of the polls and to be
correctly counted that's why I would
like a buffer I would be okay with the
bill as is but my preference would be
some type of of buffer in there um for
little issues like that and as Joan
mentioned the election workers once you
start get to you know half hour to the
close of polls they're starting to kind
of gear up for closing out the election
getting their staff in line um and so
one of the questions ear we don't
typically have a ton of absentee ballots
that are hand delivered by you know the
delivery agent on Election Day I do not
like having to tell the voter it's 510
and we cannot count your spouse's ballot
because it's in RSA it's 5 it's 5:00 P
PM you're here at 5:10 so with that I'd
be open to any questions other questions
from the committee represent PR O'Brien
hi thanks for coming today it's always
nice to see the local folks
uh would this inhibit the ability for
the public to observe the counting of
absentee
ballots so the processing of absentee
ballots um on Election Day is 1: p.m.
unless otherwise notice you can do it
two hours after the polls open unless
there's the you know the
petition um and that is noticed once the
absentee ballots are all processed for
the the day the moderator if they get uh
an additional ballot dropped off they
would make an announcement um to the
voters present that we just received an
additional absentee ballot we'll be
bringing it over for processing um and
then the anyone there could observe it
at that time further questions from the
committee representative
gusov uh thank you U not receiving an
absentee ballot does it State on the
absentee ballot when it needs to be
turned in yes that is correct so are
instructions given to the voters um with
their ballot um we find these you know
we have people coming into the office
and doing the absente ballot in person
we're finding these instructions all
over the place so I don't while it is
the voter's
responsibility they see that extra paper
and I don't know how many of them
actually read that we get a lot of calls
on instructions that are on that slip
and so I know it it is partially the
voters responsibility but a lot of
Voters even with that slip included
they're not looking at it we get calls
constantly on things that could be
answered just by reading that in uh
instruction sheet and that's a standard
form um provided by the secretary of
state that all clerks should be
including with the absentee ballot when
they either hand it out or mail it
out further questions from the
committee represent
toner thank you um I just want to know
in your experience um doing what you do
how many times have you had to Discount
an absentee ballot because it wasn't
delivered by
five I would say
probably under five times I've done I've
been doing elections for nine years um
the last three years have been in the
city I not at the polling location all
day um but I know when we do the um
reports at the end of the night um there
might an occasional delivered after the
5:00 p.m. but it's it's a very low
number that actually bring them in after
5:00 pm from what I've noticed thank you
are there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you last up
is Kaye estadio um and we we already
have the blue sheet so we're good to go
on that thank
you um thank you chairman Barry and M
members of the committee for the record
my name is Kaye of stao I'm a Durham
voter and public policy fellow with open
democracy a nonpartisan nonprofit
representing 36,000 voters across the
state and I'm submitting testimony today
in support of HB
136 this Common Sense legislation is
long overdue by not accepting ballots
received past five the state effectively
disenfranchises the working parent the
disabled and elderly the eager New
Hampshire native college student who
jump through hoops to return their
ballot as we've heard the current
statute results in the votes of
countless Granite Staters being
blatantly cast aside these hardworking
individuals deserve to have their voices
heard regardless of whether or not they
are able to vote in person the reasoning
behind the original statute was probably
intended to allow election workers the
time to process absentee ballots which
it may be in doing on Election Day
however I find this reasoning to be
inherently flawed while we all know
election workers are faced with the
essential yet incredibly taxing job of
counting ballots late into the evening I
find it difficult to believe that
arbitrary 2hour stoppage does much at
all to alleviate this pressure New
Hampshire is just one of 14 states that
does not allow election workers to begin
counting absentee ballots until the
close of polls this means that the large
quantity of absentee ballots received
since becoming available 30 days prior
must all be safe for counting at the end
of the night anyway seeing that our
election workers have successfully
completed this task year after year I
wonder just how many absentee ballots
would have to come in past 5:00 p.m. to
completely derail the process and as
we've heard not many come in after 5:00
p.m. if the goal of the original statute
was intended to ease the burden of
election workers in addition to
supporting this bill I recommend
allowing absentee ballots to be counted
before polls close on Election Day by
supporting HB 344 later today and I
respectfully ask you to please vote a to
pass on hb136 to ensure that every
granted stator is able to exercise their
right to vote thank you two seconds new
record um any questions seeing none
thank you um last actually that's the
last one um so on the blue sheet there
were four in support uh zero opposed who
did not speak online there were 113 in
support and 66 opposed with that I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 1136 uh is anyone here to
introduce House Bill
464 yes you want want to come and
introduce House Bill 464 for us real
fast we have a 5 minute time limit today
just FYI cuz our colleagues decided to
file so many bills
I need you to turn your mic on and put
it in front of you there for us thank
you thank you very much sorry about that
uh my name is Erica de uh thank you very
much to the chairman Vice chair members
of the committee uh to testify today I'm
here to testify today in support of the
amended version of HB 464 which I will
has that been shared with you I'm
assuming not no the not the amendment
not yet but we do we are in possession
of
it thank
you uh this bill takes a common sense
step apologies this bill takes a common
sense step toward eliminating potential
conflicts of interest in the ballot
counting process by prohibiting
candidates except for those running for
positions essential to election
Administration from participating in the
counting of ballots before election day
HB 464 helps ensure that our electoral
process remains above reproach the
fundamental principle of any democratic
system is that elections must be both
fair and also be perceived as fair by
the public if voters see that
individuals with a direct personal stake
in the outcome of an election are
involved in pre-election ballot counting
it risks undermining trust in the
process whether or not any actual
wrongdoing
occurs even the mere appearance of a
conflict interest is enough to erode
faith in our democracy and HB 464
eliminates that risk by reinforcing the
impartiality of ballot counting some may
argue that town moderators and election
officials will struggle to manage the
counting of blank ballots in advance of
the election if candidates for office
are not permitted to assist in the
process however this concern is
misplaced Town Lacrosse New Hampshire
have long relied on trained election
officials volunteers and legally
designated ballot clerks to handle these
responsibilities
and they will continue to do so the
argument that elections cannot function
without candidates counting blank
ballots with their own names on them
suggested undue Reliance on those with
vested interests a notion that should
raise concern and not support by
enacting H Bill HB 464 we send a clear
message to the people of New Hampshire
our election our excuse me our elections
are conducted with the highest levels of
Integrity free from even the perception
of bias this billes does not make any
accusations it only seeks to make
improvements it safeguards our
Democratic Traditions while ensuring
that every voter has a reason to trust
the process as well as the results I
urge the committee to support HB 464 and
Advance it to the Full House thank you
for your time and I would be pleased to
answer any questions other questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you very much Mr going to recess the
public hearing on 464 and reopen the
public hearing on House Bill 158 we only
have two cards left uh next up is chase
eagleson after that is the nhma who
didn't indicate a person um Mr eagleson
you indicated 30 seconds so let's see it
let's let's see it I would love
it I promise to keep to that as uh
precisely as possible my name is Chase
seon I'm the policy and planning
coordinator for the New Hampshire
Council development disabilities where
he federally funded state agency
mandated by the American with
Disabilities Act uh I come in opposition
to this bill
mostly because the public list will just
kind of showcase mostly individuals with
disabilities their caretakers anyone
that just hasn't the time to be there uh
on that day uh and there's just a
privacy concern that we have uh without
outing that many people with
disabilities it also may include people
with disabilities who you
know uh may be early on set you know
Alzheimer's that kind of thing that they
may not be you know willing to publicly
disclose
I get on time uh you were a little over
but you had two minutes it's okay I was
just I was just hyping you up for a 30
second speech um any questions seeing
none thank you last up is the nhma I
need to know who's speaking for the nhma
because they didn't write down a
person no it's just and it's just the
the in fact it's just it's just initials
I know what they are but sorry
um my name is Sarah Burke Cohen I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association this is on HB 158 correct
yes ma'am okay um nhma opposes this bill
um we have a few issues with it um
certainly we have some issues with the
fact that um the the ballot clerk will
be required to uh identify confirm and
uh validate uh whether a 173 RSA 173b
protective order is valid or not um we
think that is well outside the scope of
uh what a ballot Clerk or a supervisor
of the checklist should be doing um
secondly we feel like adding the burden
on to our you know the municipality to
have these P these lists ready within 60
days is is burdensome and it also causes
um some issues with regard to the
protective orders um if th if someone is
left on the list and it goes public and
it's a mistake it could be problematic
for that person um safety and Welfare
wise um so nhma opposes this bill will
you be taking questions sure are there
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you I don't have any more pink
cards for house B 158 does anyone else
wish to speak to this subject seeing
none um there were one person uh in
support five opposed who did not speak
online there were 57 in support 94
opposed I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 158 going to
reopen the public hearing on House Bill
which is relative to absentee
ballots and only have oops three pink
cards I have three pink cards for this
we're catching up folks we are doing it
oh blue sheet y um so first up will be
David Trumble from
where you get the wear privilege going
first yes sir 217
I know it's a little confusing but I try
to get the state reps back to their
committees because otherwise they're
just hanging out
here can you please turn your microphone
on sorry just to make sure I'm on the
right bill this is the city citizenship
papers uh relative to absentee ballots
uh actually it hasn't been introduced
yet um so I apologize I'm have to sit
down um I don't think anyone's here to
introduce it I think he's I think
representative Lynn is chairing his
committee representative gusovsky can
you please go and just introduce how 217
all you have to do is say I'm resident
of gasi I'm here to introduce house 217
read the title and I'm taking no
questions unless you want to for a bill
you didn't sponsor for a bill you
didn't representative gazowsky
introducing
217 uh this bill requires absentee
ballots
voters absent ballot voters excuse me to
submit information demon rating
citizenship age domicile and identity in
order to qualify to vote and I will be
taking no questions thank you um and now
we can get Mr Trumble up here sorry
about that
procedural and if you could turn your
microphone back on please thank
you thank you thank you Mr chairman
committee members my name is David
Trumble and from the town OFW and I
oppose this bill I'll start with the
basic arguments this fold first is that
this deals with the right to vote it's a
right it's not a privilege and we should
be very careful about reducing people's
ability to exercise the right to vote
second is that there's no evidence of
fraud this has been demonstrated
throughout this hearing today the chance
of absentee fraud is less than the
chance of getting hit by lightning as
you just
heard the issue is the citizenship
papers the Brennan Center for justice
has been long active in this field and
they just put out a report in
2024 asking people about uh their
ability to access their right to vote
and whether or not they had the
documents to prove their citizenship a
passport a birth certificate
naturalization papers readily available
our they said quote our Research
indicates that more than 9% of American
citizens of voting age 21 million people
Nationwide don't have proof of
citizenship readily available there are
myriad reasons for this the documents
might be in the home of another family
member or in a safety deposit box at
least 3.8 million don't have these
documents at all often because they were
lost destroyed or stolen they also found
that while over 8% of self-identified
white American citizens don't have these
CI these documents readily available
that number is nearly 11% among
Americans of color so what is 9%
translate to in in New Hampshire if you
get about 800,000 votes in a major
election that's 70 2,000 people who
would not be able to vote now I don't
know which town you're all from you're
from different towns all over the state
but if you're from a town of 1,000
people that means 90 people in your town
will lose their right to vote if you're
from a town of 10,000 people that means
900 people would lose their right to
vote it doesn't make any sense there's
no fraud there's no reason for this bill
it would take away people's right to
vote there's nothing in our state
constitution that requires these papers
be provided in order to get it absente
Bel we already went through the state
constitution it doesn't have anything
like that in there there's no reason for
this bill but if you represent a
thousand people in your town you're
telling 90 of them that they will not be
able to vote in the next election thank
you thank you actually dead on zero
congratulations we have the winner for
the day um are there any questions for
Mr
Trumble um seeing none next up is Mr
Daniel Richard
after that we're going to have Christina
Lynch good morning
again uh let's address this from a
historical perspective the citizenship
question I I support the citizenship
requirement but you're asking the wrong
question in 1973 this body removed four
words that were in front of the words
citizen of the United States and that
was that you were native born or you
were naturalized now what were they
talking about State citizenship from
1808 chapter chapter 49 from 1808 all
the way to 1973 that's a long time folks
that was the requirement and I bet none
of you in this room know another thing
about federal law you know what that is
you can't attach any durational
residency requirement for someone to
vote in other words if you use the word
resident or you use the word doile you
can't attach a durational residency
requirement for that person to vote but
on state citizenship you can in other
words replace the word State citizen
with
domicile and the solution would take a
little bit more time that I don't want
to occupy this committee with a limited
time this morning but that is the
solution restoring State citizenship as
the prerequisite in order to vote okay
will you be taking questions from the
committee yes are there questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
thank you next up is Christina Lynch uh
on Deck will be Mackenzie Taylor
and and folks we may actually make lunch
Believe It or
Not hi for the record it's actually
chenda Lynch good morning chairman Barry
and committee members um I'm a resident
and longtime voter since 1981 in
conquered New Hampshire also um I have
functioned as a deputy registar for the
city of Manchester on a couple of occas
occasions having gone through extensive
training I was on the new voter uh desk
there so I've handled a lot of the
papers that are referenced in various
bills that are before your committee um
around citizenship and so on um I'm
testifying on 217 partly because my
meter ran out at 11:30 and this was the
first one up but I'm opposed to any
number of bills that have to do with um
absentee ballots um not only in 20120
because of the covid pandemic um when my
spouse and I voted absentee being
conquered um but also 2022 I was
hospitalized during the time of the
actual voting and my spouse was able to
go to the city clerk's office get an
absentee ballot for me no questions
asked I filled it out they had me on the
voter registration since you know the
1980s I was able to submit it following
the rules double signatures this and
that but there was no requirement to
submit any other paperwork proving who I
was or colored pictures that's here
somewhere in one of the bills another
one is notarization another one is you
know ask six months ahead of time I did
not know I was going to fall down the
stairs um six months before I did and
was hospitalized so I'm just saying that
a lot of these bills make no sense to me
they're more restrictive than um what is
required to register to vote um if
you're already registered to vote in the
city of conquer they've already had all
this information on you and they are at
least in my experience more than happy
to give you an absentee voter uh
application so I want to say my
experience with absentee voting was
wonderful both during the pandemic and
for those of you naysayers we are likely
to have another one um if you listen to
zoonotic researchers those are the
animal to human transition we've got
that going on with bird flu right now I
don't mean to be a uh a doom and gloom
person but there are going to be reasons
that maybe many of you sitting in this
room will need to vote
absentee uh voting so I would hate to
see any further restrictions put on it I
know there have been restrictions put on
just registering to vote which is
difficult enough for people but once you
get going to ask you ma'am to bring your
marks to a conclusion yes that I'm fine
okay um thank you very much will you be
taking questions I'd be happy too are
there questions from the committee
how did I fall down what happened to me
no I mean you you can get up and say you
can basically get up and say anything so
long as you don't impune a member you
can pretty much get for two minutes you
can read from Dr Seuss um next up is M
uh Sue
nsty and on Deck will be Mackenzie
Taylor
I think this was left on it
red okay well thank you Mr chairman and
the committee House Bill
217 I oppose this very strongly this
bill isn't necessary the bill is
questioning the Integrity of city clerks
Town clerks supervisors of the checklist
they are local elected officials that
are sworn to uphold their job with
honesty they are and when application
when absentee applications are
received in town or city hall the
information is
scrutinized before it's okay to send an
absentee ballot out so um if there's any
question um they do their best their
very best uh as serving the voters to uh
contact uh to uh maybe take care of that
question um may it be uh even due to
penmanship or the form isn't complete
but
um this uh this isn't necessary when all
of that
information is um on that particular
super uh particular
voter's uh um
registration thank you thank you will
you be taking questions yes are there
questions seeing none thank you next up
is Mackenzie Taylor and then after that
we have Kristen Evans it's our last
Kristen Evans is the last pink card I
have on 217 so if you wish to speak to
217 please fill out a pink card
now and for members for members
awareness I only have uh two more
members of the public signed up to speak
before we break for
lunch good afternoon again members of
the committee my name is Mackenzie
Taylor with new New Hampshire campaign
for voting rights and America votes um
this B we are opposed to um House Bill
217 um and specifically you wanted to
dig in this bill is about absentee
registration um this is something that's
used very very rarely in New Hampshire
really for folks who are unable to make
it either to the clerk's office ahead of
time ahead of election day or on
Election Day um at the polls so often
these are folks who are either out of
town for an extended period or someone
who truly is unable to leave their home
make it to their clerk's office or leave
their home and get to the polls um even
with assistance so folks who are some of
our most vulnerable for those
individuals under this bill we're adding
even more requirements currently under
the law you can see in the bill um those
folks would need to include ID we're
expanding that for these most vulnerable
individuals in this bill um and having
them also provide copies of documents
that they may not have if they are um
folks who are unable to travel to leave
their home easily proof of domicile like
a driver's license um and citizenship in
the form of a passport or birth
certificate are documents that if they
don't have would also require traveling
and costs to get um meaning that those
folks who are unable to get to the polls
are then also potentially
disenfranchised from registering and
voting absentee um that reason we are
opposed and I'm happy to take any
questions other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you I think
you have the shortest testimony today so
far so points uh chrisen Evans last one
up um representative gusowski can you
pass me that blue sheet for 217 if we
haven't
already thank you chair and committee I
will be brief since I'm the only thing
standing between you and lunch um thank
you for the opportunity to testify today
for the record again my name is Kristen
Evans and I serve as as the Director of
policy for AEL New Hampshire a Statewide
disability Justice organization
dedicated to protecting and advancing
civil and human rights of people with
disabilities in New Hampshire I am here
to oppose House Bill 217 at AEL New
Hampshire we work to enure that people
with disabilities have equal access to
all aspects of Civic life including the
fundamental right to vote this bill
creates an undue burden for many
eligible voters particularly those with
disabilities who rely on absentee
registration and voting to exercise
their rights for many people with
disabilities Gathering and submitting
additional documentation is not a simple
task obtaining copies of bir
certificates passports or other official
documents often requires travel to
government offices payment of fees
or access to technology for scanning and
printing barriers that dis
disproportionately affect individuals
with Mobility limitations cognitive
disabilities low-income residents and
those who do not have access to reliable
transportation this bill would also
negatively impact voters who require
support to obtain and manage their
personal records many individuals with
disabilities rely on Guardians
caregivers or other support networks to
assist them with administrative tasks
which can further complicate the process
and And Delay their ability to register
New Hampshire has historically been a
leader in Civic pre uh participation and
our state has worked to improve access
to absentee voting for those who need it
most this bill Mo moves Us in the wrong
direction rather than creating
additional barriers we should be working
to expand accessible registration and
voting options ensuring that all
eligible citizens regardless of
disability age or soci socionomic status
can fully participate in our democracy
for these reasons able urges you to vote
itl on HB 217 thank you well done one
second not not the record for the day
but really close um are there any
questions uh for the committee seeing
none thank you with that I'm going to
close the public hearing well I'm going
to read my results here we've got uh for
217 we had three in support 10 uh posed
on the blue sheet online there were 61
in support 536 again so with that I'm
going to close the public hearing for
House Bill 217 I'm going to reopen the
public hearing for House Bill 464 for
prohibiting candidates for public office
participating in the counting of ballots
going to recognize our only person
signed up to speak is Joan
Dari got get that microphone on that
works thank you Joan dargy New Hampshire
City and town clerks
Association um as many of you know many
of our volunteers that offer to come in
and count our uncast just received
ballots are just like yourselves they're
the ones that volunteer to run for
office um also many times the Town Clerk
and the moderator are on the bill at at
the on the ballot at the same time and
this could potentially make counting of
uncast ballots delayed and potentially
costly because we to would have to hire
people to count these ballots and with
that I'll ask I'll answer
questions are there questions from the
committee that was bizarre my my thing
was pink um represent Lane hi uh thank
you um for taking my question so are you
saying that there would not be enough
other people if we exclude this list am
I understanding you correctly poti in
some City and towns
yes okay thank you further questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
um late late intro here Tina Guilford
from the town of
dairy and I don't have any more pink
cards representative gasovi you pass me
the blue sheets for 464 thank
you uh my name is Tina Gilford I'm from
a town clerk from the town of Derry um I
did hear when this bill was presented
that there was an amendment um so that's
not an amendment that I've seen um I do
have issue with this uh we in Derry do
pay our ballot clerks to come in and
count the blank ballots many times when
it's primary time we pair we always pair
them up one person from each party to
count and and and you know um in Derry
we get lots of ballots uh for example
for the presidential election I think we
got 20 some odd thousand um so we it
takes us quite a long time um but
because we do especially the primaries
by party a lot of times um myself or the
moderator and
our um our version of Selectmen our
counselors step in especially to make
the parties even so that they can count
and a lot of times they're on the ballot
they're Counting a blank ballot with one
other person in public they're not
counting cast ballots there are no votes
on these ballots they're literally
confirming the count of the ballots we
got from the Secretary of State uh um it
is public it is we do it publicly
noticed we don't do it right before the
polls open I know there are some towns
that still do that uh I'm not sure what
people think that we might be doing with
those ballots um and in a town election
where we have the town and the school
ballots um probably about 10,000 ballots
are being counted every six years the
clerk and the moderator are both on the
ballot at the same time um moderators
are every two years clerks are every
three years so like I said you guys have
an amendment I haven't seen the
amendment maybe the amendment fixes
something I'm not sure uh but with that
I will take any questions other
questions from the committee
representative Wei uh thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question so
the um I think I have the amendment in
front of me it allows uh just I won't
read the whole thing but it allows for
election officials as being an exception
to the counting of these blank ballots
okay um if if that were to be the
amendment is would that be acceptable to
you oh yes um I definitely think that um
if a candidate is on the ballot uh but
they're not an election official and
they want to come and watch they're
welcome to
uh but we definitely wouldn't encourage
them um they you know but for our
election officials especially um we have
a lot of people that volunteer and do
double triple Duty in town um those
people need to be able to actually
execute their job okay further questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
I don't have any more pin cards in my
possession uh online house
bill please get those in a little faster
okay
go thank you Mr chairman for um
accepting our late pin card and thank
you to the committee for taking our
brief testimony um I'm just here to
testify to the amended bill which we
just read and um received some feedback
on um internally so House Bill 644 as oh
yeah sorry Brody Des is a represent the
Amire Municipal Association thank you
representative um House Bill uh
464 um as amended We Believe has
duplicative and unnecessary since it's
the the disqualification of certain
election officials is already addressed
in RSA 658 24 disqualification of
certain persons and RSA 659 colon 58
disqualification of officials and how
they're involved in the election the
vote counting process and the tabulating
of ballots prior to the election um we
understand the intent respect the intent
but we think it would create uh
confusion if you have these
disqualifications in multiple places in
the statute for election officials um
and for those running the elections to
be able to implement and with that I'll
take any questions if the committee has
any yes I have a question so you're
aware this is about the precount this
isn't about the counting of the balls
this is the pre- count yes okay so those
statutes that you cited I don't believe
apply to
those so I I give it a reread um okay
any other questions from the committee
other than mine not really a question
all right with that um there's no more
people sign up yes represent me youread
I would be uh grateful if the New
Hampshire Municipal Association if it
has a opinion would maybe email that to
the committee members would love to see
it yeah thank you okay we can do that
thank you all right uh with that I
managed to get us back to 11 only 11
minutes behind so not bad um going to
close public hearing on House Bill 464
uh the committee will stand in recess
until 1:00 um and we are amazingly still
kind of on track so I'll see everybody
back at 1:00 thank
you
e
e e
okay we're back going to open the public
hearing for House Bill 288 requiring
that absentee ballots be requested at
least 6 months to any election for which
the absentee ballot is requested I'm
going to recognize representative wuri
for the purpose of introduction of the
Bill thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members for the record my name
is Robert where I have the privilege of
representing Hillsboro District 13 the
great town of
Hudson House Bill 288 limits the time
period in which absentee ballots may be
requested in the November 2024 election
a total of
87,8 46 absentee ballots were requested
uh one aspect which is disconcerting
about that request process is that there
is no limitation as to when the absentee
ballot may be
requested um in the uh in the current
statutes so consequently um there were a
number of bills or a number of uh
absentee ballots which were requested
very early in the process so for the
November 2024 election in the third
quarter of 2023 there was a total of 38
ballots requested absentee ballots
requested in the fourth quarter of 2023
there are 314
in the first quarter of 2024 there were
12 uh
1,298 and then in the uh second quarter
of 2024 there were um
1,179 and then the third third quarter
there were 28,6 48 and then in October
there were a total of
56,3 69 so that's where the total number
of 87,8 46 absentee ballots came from
um and uh so this bill creates a modest
restriction which may be beneficial
administra because you won't have to
request you won't have to track the
request for as long a period of time but
it also just puts a uh controlled
variable here on the requesting of
absentee ballots and limits it just to
six months so a November election would
have a may cut off for the request a
March election would have a September of
the previous year cut off date and I'm
happy to take any questions okay
questions from the committee yes
representative
Lane hi thank you for taking my question
um the ACT I just wanted give you an
opportunity to explain in the where the
ACT is described it says that you have
to request a ballot at least at least
six months
before but the body of the text is the
exact opposite so I just thought you
might want to get that on record and we
may need to amend it is that correct
there's a
question that that is the joy of the um
OS I I think um it it was that specific
text that you see in the Bold italics
was
recommended um that was somehow I think
interpreted to come up with the title of
the ACT
but it it is restricting it to six
months before the actual
election yes followup representative
Lane are the ballots aren't even
available at that point correct that is
correct I mean they wouldn't have the
candidates identified at that point and
but but nonetheless there are a number
of requests that are still submitted for
those further questions from the
committee representative
Newsome just you may have to you're uh I
have a s man you're you're back lit for
me like crazy so you may have to like
weigh call catch yeah yeah cuz you are
basically a a like black blob okay duy
noted thank you um you said there are
87,000 total and how many of those were
prior to the six-month period uh 2% 2%
thank you yeah roughly so not not an
onerous number so further questions from
the
committee okay thank thank you
representative weary um next up is
representative
Horan and everybody knows we're still on
our two-minute clock and we we're still
on our five minute clock for
introduction representative where did
not use his full five
minutes oh thank you much I'm resident
Timothy Horgan same person I was this
morning still representing straford
County District 10 so apparently
um apparently only 2% of the uh absentee
ballot application is affected by this
but if you're one of those 2% it's a big
deal um since it's dis disenfranchising
and also I'm
um some I'm I'm uh so I just think this
is a this is a I think this is an
unnecessary bill so even if it's just 2%
of the ballots uh then um then that
that's makes a big difference and also
of course uh this isn't really the
sponsors also sponsor fault but for some
reason yeah the
uh the the sort of like Mast head of the
bill the title of it he just raised that
point yes I know I'm just say uh I don't
I think that's another reason to be
dubious about this bill the fact that
there's a the fact that there's such a
blatant drafting error in it so um so I
I Ur you this bill is unnecessary so I
urge you to oppose it and I oppose urge
you to oppose any attempts to like rest
the right to vote absentee if that's
what that's what works for you rather
than voting in person so other questions
from the committee I have one yeah how
far back should someone be able to
request one two three four five years
how far back well I mean when's the cut
off I uh I mean it probably should be
within the election cycle I mean even
this is so far back you might not even
some cases know like when the election
is going to be and especially there's
nothing in here for a special election
and those are only uh scheduled uh I
should know scheduled two or three
months in advance so this just so I just
urge you to vote no on this than that'll
be a common theme for me on this bill is
how far back should you be able to do it
all thank you uh next up is uh Dan Hy
actually he's up because we try to
alternate support oh actually I'm sorry
Mr Healey I missed uh deputy secretary
Hennessy's card I apologize and I do
like the the sos' office to go after the
representativ so my apologies Mr he but
you are
next good afternoon everyone my name is
Aaron Henson I'm the deputy secretary of
state I just wanted to bring to your
attention that uh via the federal
postcard application uocava voters are
able to request absentee ballots for an
entire year um and so that would federal
law would Trump whichever um changes
that you make to the state law for uova
voters uh questions from the
committee does the Secretary of States
have a position if we carved out the
uocava would they have a position or
would it be neutral yes no just neutral
on this bill understood thank you any
questions any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you now we
are up Mr Healey I apologize uh on Deck
is Sue uh
nastasi so Dan hilly nashwa city clerk
the uaba um issue is something that we
were going that I was going to mention
um so I support this bill as long as
that portion gets taken care of um I do
want to say that I like the six months
we have uh residents that drop off
requests in January for a November
election and maybe their circumstances
change um leading up to the election
that's a long time um to you know submit
an application in advance and we
actually had one resident well two
residents it was husband and wife that
requested an absentee ball in January
for the November election we had input
it into the system they never came in to
update their address Within josua and
were very upset when we mailed their
ballot to the the address on the
application that they gave us back in
January so you extending or allowing the
request to go that far back you're going
to run into issues issues like that
where a voter um might have put their
mailing address uh their mailing address
might have changed their address might
have changed and they don't notify us
and now they have that request on file
we have to send them the ballot because
they have that request so I think a cut
off time or a time that you know 6
months prior seems very reasonable uh
that gives the voter enough time it
gives us enough time to input it and get
it um the ballots out but you know we're
talking a year two years I've called the
Secretary of State's office before on
when I've received an application that
far in advance like what do we do with
this and it's you you know you need to
enter it into the system it's just I
think it's too long of a time frame
right now thank you I going need to
bring marks to a conclusion because I
got be fair everybody um any questions
from the committee yes represent Mirad I
have a question um I'm a teacher
sometimes I in some years I might teach
abroad for the year um I and if I were
to leave for a calendar year I might
rather go to town hall in January while
I'm physically present to request my
absentee ballot show my ID give them my
address sign any relevant forms then
then try to request it when I'm living
abroad um would you say that I should
not be allowed to do
that I wouldn't say you shouldn't be
allowed to do that but when you're given
the situation you presented you would
then qualify as a uaba voter and you
could submit that request to us um I
know you said you want to do it in
person but the U aava voters also have
the opportunity to receive their ballots
by email and being abroad um that would
be a quicker way to get your ballot and
get it back to us
um so I know entirely answer your
question being in person but you would
then fall under that specific category
as well further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Mr hey
next up is sunasi uh on Deck is
Kaylee
estadio well uh thank you you um Mr
chairman uh Ross Berry and committee um
I also should have uh realized about um
the front and back of uh M Miss uh Miss
Nasi can you introduce yourself I know
you've been before already today but you
have to it's like one of the procedural
things I apologize for interrupting you
I'm not going to take that against your
time sasia in
Rollinsford and I I do oppose um the
bill as this part said about at least 6
months prior to any
election um I just didn't think this
bill is uh it's not realistic with
timing of all
involved and um and even though you may
be um you know ahead of time um you know
it does cause some confusion but again
if I flip the page and then it's
um um an application form for an
absentee ballot shall be mailed or
delivered to any person who applies
for um to the ATT teny Town Clerk or
city clerk so um if it was
um uh six over six months then it's not
realistic at
all okay but uh thank you for your time
and did not mean to be uh repetitious no
that's it is a I said people can come
here and read from the Dr Seuss if they
want to um I assume you're not taking
questions by your actions so uh next up
is Kaylee uh
estadio oh all right cool so we're gonna
just want me to scrap it can you sign
the blue sheet thing because I'm not
gonna you're not going to get counted if
you do the P then last up is Betsy
Ferguson if anyone else wishes to speak
please fill out a PL there's one coming
uh please fill out a pink card
uh Betsy Ferguson from exitor New
Hampshire and I too was confused by the
mismatch between the title of of the
bill and the content of the bill um
which is very confusing um and with that
in mind I would oppose it and ask you to
resubmit a bill where the title is
consistent with the text so that there
is no confusion in the
future okay any questions from the
committee seeing none um I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
that's not 280 oh this 288 y'all it's
not oh we're on 288 good Lord sorry I
saw rep Penza I assumed she was here to
introduce her bill are you here to
testify on this bill okay I am sorry
that was my confusion representative
Penza thank you Mr chair and just for
the record my name is representative
Kelly Penza straford District 19
Rochester Wards 1 2 3 4 and six um so
quickly um I just wanted to speak on the
um the opening of the bill and having
that mistake in there so
um the same thing happened with one of
my bills and I've already put it in an
amendment so um I don't think it changes
at all the um the merits of the bill um
I know that this is an issue I've heard
it from constituents um in straford
county in regards with with uh the
six-month lag and um there were we had
some people that were requesting
absentee ballots before the first in the
nation primary and then that would be
for November election so um I think that
we should pass this I think it's a I
think it's a good bill um I also um knew
that there was a conflict with yukaba
but that's already been mentioned so um
I would love I would love this to go
through I've heard this from
um do Rochester and um Durham I knew
there was an issue there too with very
long um amounts of time in regards with
requesting absentees and especially if
you talk about college students uh those
those things change Apartments change
dorm rooms change things like that so
please pass this bill will you be taking
questions from the committee sure are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um online
testimony there was uh 5 4 in support 26
against um on the blue sheet oh Lord I'm
about to
count uh one
two 16 opposed zero in support I'm going
to close the public hearing on 288 going
to um open up the executive session for
the house election law committee um we
had an error due to a posting on a bill
that we
had I'm sorry what were the blue the
online
numbers again online was 54 support 26
opposed one neutral for
288 oh that was 498 excuse me I'm sorry
288 is oh yeah quite opposite uh 57
support 537 opposed um probably because
of the title um anyway so now we will go
into our executive session thank you
representative Newsome and thanks for
doing the the the wave um so we are in
executive session um due to a um posting
error um when we voted on 261 relative
to election audits the vote didn't count
um this was the unanimous vote 18 to Z
out of committee so we have to
procedurally we have to vote on it again
I noticed the ranking member and the
vice chairman that this votes was
pending so this isn't totally
unannounced um but anyways I'm going to
open the executive session for House
Bill 261 relative to election audits I'm
going to move the bill ought to pass is
there a second there's a second from
representative
wood it's okay
I'm way too fast for the clerk they say
I'm 261 um is is there any discussion on
uh again on House Bill
261 seeing none the motion is ought to
pass on House Bill 261 and when our
fabulous wonderful clerk is ready we she
will call the
rooll you cannot do a voice on Final
action
okay sorry about that final final
action representative qua
I representative pum
O'Brien yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harry Bo boa
sorry yep yes representative C yes
representative gski yes representative
toner yes representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
Gilmore oh sorry he's not here I didn't
get these sheets up yet sorry
representative Mirad yeah representative
Bay she oh she isn't here
sorry uh representative
Grill yes representative wilham yes
representative Nome yes and represent uh
chairman Barry chair votes yes and with
that the house bill 261 will be
re-reported out of the committee as op
to pass by a vote
of uh 18 nope no way is 18 16 to zero 16
I'm sorry I don't have my numbers down
and I will I've already written the
report at sent the report so I will
resend the report I've already written
and sent um so with that I will close
the executive session on House Bill 261
and we will re-enter the public hearing
session uh so we going to open up the
public hearing for house before 98 FN
relative to when a person may receive an
absentee ballot and I recognize
representative Penza for the purpose of
introduction of the
bill this committee is like Lightning
Fast thank you Mr chair um once again
for the record representative Kelly
Penza straford District 19 um so this is
a pretty simple bill um it actually uh
it came from a constituent uh that works
in elections um that couldn't get their
um representative to file it so I filed
it for them and um it's basically just
um making the time frame um you know
specific so that the secretary shall not
send absentee ballot applications of the
city or town clerks prior to 45 days
before an election um we've had issues
of course with um with curating ballots
and all of that kind of stuff and it's
good with chain of custody keeping the
time closer uh so that's the reason why
I put this bill in okay will you be
taking questions from the committee sure
are there questions from the committee
representative
Lane um with the previous bill that we
just P you know voted on uh or heard
sorry we did vote on one but it wasn't
the but so 288 would this really be
necessary yes this doesn't this um this
doesn't have anything to do with the
time frame about requesting an absentee
ballot these are actually when they're
sent from the Secretary of State oh okay
thank you you're welcome further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you representative patina next up
is representative Timothy Horan
um and we are now back on our two-minute
clocks just for those who weren't here
for lunch uh what I do is I allow the
sponsors five minutes I allow the
Secretary of State's office five minutes
if there's need for clarification um and
subsequent speakers are given two
minutes which no one has ever objected
to so I'm going to continue down that
path thank you very much I continue to
be representative Timothy Horgan I
continue to represent straford County
District 10 the town of Durham um I'm
not specifically with the specific issue
in Durham which he mentioned but we do
get a large number of absentee ballots
in in in Durham Pally partially because
we have like older people you know like
quote unquote snowbirds and like then we
also have lots of students in town but
um I think this I think this 45 day
window I mean there probably is a need
for some sort of window but um 45 days
seems like an overly short one um
there's the issue of U aava voters um
another overseas voters have to send the
ballots overseas um you you obviously
need an amendment to uh to deal with
that and so and then the last sentence
is fine but that's pretty much already
you're already mandating something that
they should already be doing so I would
just say this bill is this bill is
unnecessary and it just uh and um it
also cast guess further doubt on the uh
on the validity of our elections because
there's you know you mentioned there's
sort of like I think I think there's an
I think there's like a exaggerated fear
of like uh bogus ballots being
introduced into the into the uh system
although of course there shouldn't be
any at all so I would urge you I
probably urge you not to bother with
this bill for the reason as I said
before it's it's unnecessary so that's
so I vge you to itl it thanks thank you
you be taking questions from the
committee oh I'm sure are there
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you um next next up and I is uh
rep represent Secretary of State David
scalin and welcome to election law we
haven't seen you today so you get the
first welcome to election law for your
day okay thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee um David scanland
Secretary of State and I'm a little
puzzled by this bill and I'm wondering
whether the the language is actually
what the
sponsor uh was uh was looking for
because if I read the sends the
secretary shall not send absentee ballot
applications to city or town clerks
prior to 45 days before an election the
Secretary of State shall keep a record
of the date when and the manner in which
the absentee ballot
applications were sent to said
clerks and of the number of absentee
ballot applications so forwarded so
we're clearly talking about absentee
ballot applications
in today's world we don't print very
many of these we actually make them
available online for the city and town
clerks to download to give to voters who
would like to request uh an absentee
ballot and I'm I I'm sure those same
forms are email to the voter if they're
requested in addition to that third
parties can also distribute absentee
ballot applications there is no control
on that and I think all of you as voters
in the state have received received the
mailings from the political parties and
candidates and packs that actually have
an application for an absente ballot on
them you'd simply tear it off fill it
out and send it in and then finally
there is no requirment that a voter has
to fill out an absentee ballot
application to request one they can
simply write a statement to their clerk
with that request provided the statement
contains all of the information that
would otherwise be on the application so
from my perspective this would be a very
hard thing to control um I don't know
that the numbers that we would provide
really would mean anything and you know
that's why I'm wondering if what's
written here is actually what the
sponsor
intended be happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr secretary there
any questions from the committee uh
representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank thank you
secretary for taking the question I was
just wondering the 45 day time limit
isn't that the time when the SEC uh the
various clerks have to be able to send a
u a ballot out so they would have to
have the application before that so I I
agree that this sounds unusual I guess I
should have asked the sponsor yeah and
just to clarify that the 45-day deadline
applies because of a federal statute
related to our military and overseas
voters we have to send their ballots to
them no later than 45 days before the
election typically a regular absentee
voter starts receiving their absentee
ballots between 45 and 30 days before
the election based on the when the
request is
made any further questions from the
committee seeing n thank you very much
Mr secretary
I see one more red card here from uh
Tina
Guilford me oh uh may I get the blue
sheet
please thank you get there good
afternoon election law committee my name
is Tina Guilford and I am the town clerk
from Derry um I joined the Secretary of
State in his confusion um because this
does Clearly say absentee ballot
applications um so the absentee ballot
applications are provided by Secretary
of State electronically we put them on
our website electronically so that
voters can download them we email them
we also print them out so they can be
handed out we just heard a bill uh for
six
months um which I can work with 6 months
45 days is a really short window of time
if we couldn't even start accepting
applications to 45 days before an
election um we have lots of snowbirds
here in New Hampshire uh a lot of them
right after Christmas they head south
and one of their stops is at Town Hall
to fill out an application for the March
election so that's only a couple months
ahead of time it's about 3 months it's a
reasonable amount of time for they head
south so that we can mail them their
ballot and a lot of them are going to
Florida and it can sometimes take a week
for the ballot to arrive down there so
it's great that we get the application
early so that as soon as the ballots are
in um I placed my ballot order yesterday
uh because our school district had their
deliberative session on Saturday so we
were able to place our ballot order
yesterday I'm really hoping that they're
going to turn them around real quick and
by next Monday I'll have ballots to
start sending out I already have
requests so the 45 day timeline uh seems
a little odd for the
applications um and I will be happy to
take any questions other questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you um I oh
did I miss one I apologize for
SE U thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh do you keep up to
date if if the secretary changes the
form on the
online uh you know if we enact new
legislation it requires the form to have
some different information y the the
Secretary of State's office is
phenomenal it's sending out out emails
when they update the form and it's right
available on the online system for us to
download the most upto-date
forms all right sorry about that further
questions from the committee seeing none
I don't have anyone else signed up to
speak on House Bill 498 uh so there were
uh zero in support six osed on the blue
sheet online there were 54 in support 26
in support and one neutral got that one
right a little ahead of myself so I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill uh 598 I'm going to open
reopen our noticed executive session
um so blue sheet here you go Madam clerk
thank you uh I'm going to open up the
doce executive session for House Bill
107 relative to political advertisements
printed in newspapers periodicals or
Billboards and I will recognize
representative wood for a
motion thank thank you Mr chair I'd like
to make a motion to uh for House Bill
107 as OTP ought to pass is there a
second
second representative Harvey bullia
makes a second is there discussion on
the
bill House Bill 107 motion of V to pass
s representative Lane
um we will not be voting a to pass we
feel like especially given um the
situation where it is not clear and
there's a lot of disinformation and
misinformation being circulated it's not
clear necessarily what is coming from a
candidate only or whether it is in fact
um
uh information I don't was saying
article but perhaps something trying to
get facts out there we want something
that would differentiate that and we
think that the putting political
advertisement on there has been there
for a very long time and is not a
significant
burden further discussion on the
bill seeing none um when the Mad Madam
clerk is ready we'll call the role the
motion is ought to pass on house bow 107
relative to political advertisements
printed in newspapers periodicals or
Billboards hey
um representative
qua yes representative Pomo Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative har bolia Harvey
bolia says yes sorry representative
C yes representative goovi yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane no
representative Ward no representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Grill no Representative
willham no representative Nome no
represent uh chairman Rasberry chairman
votes yes and is that a I know it's a
divided bill but what is the so is that
10 to seven seven yes uh 10 to 7 okay uh
House Bill 107 will be reported out 10
to 7 representative Lane who will be
responsible for for The Minority Report
uh representative Mirad representative
Mirad and uh representative weary you'll
be responsible for the um majority
report okay
um and uh uh can we get those um I I
would really love to get those noticed
in next week's calendar so if we could
get those by
tonight um that would be excellent
because then I can send them by the way
the deadline is noon on Wednesday so uh
with that I'm going to but I have to
have them to the clerks at noon on
Wednesday so you have to give me a
little time too uh so with that I'm
going to close the executive session on
House Bill 107 uh I'm going to open up
the executive session for House Bill
336 relative to placements of political
advertisements on public rights of ways
uh and I am going to recognize
representative Wei for a
motion I'd like to make a motion to
inexpedient to legisl representative M
makes an motion of inexpedient to
legislate is there a second
representative Woods seconds is there
discussion on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
336 hearing none when our fabulous
wonderful clerk is ready uh she shall
call the role on the motion of
inexpedient legislate on House Bill 336
relative to the placement of political
advertisements on public rights of ways
sorry paper going on
here I can't
write all right let me get rid of these
lines and I think we can go all
right representative qua yes
representative Pomo
Brian yes representative Burnham yes
representative
weary yes representative wood yes
representative Harvey Bia yes
representative C yes representative
goovi yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative
Mirad I'm sorry could you just remind me
of the
motion I'm gonna vote Yes yes me too yes
okay we'll come back around I you I you
address it thank you we we are on the
voting mode so we have to finish the
vote the motion is inexpedient to
legislate um our practice of President
does allow members to change their vote
immediately afterwards which I will call
as a courtesy but we do need to finish
the vote we are in the voting mode
representative
Bay
no representative
Grill yes representative wilham yes
representative Newsome yes
uh chairman Barry chair votes yes would
any member uh like to change their vote
Yes representative Bay would you like to
change your vote from a no to a yes I
would would any other member like to
change their vote representative Ward
would you like to change your vote from
a no to a yes yes representative Lane
a no to a yes yes okay so this will be
reported out as I believe 17 to Z thank
you see we can do it we can do it we
still have three minutes we can get uh
the majority
report which is I guess is just the
committee report um representative Wei I
believe you are you made the motion so
you are
responsible um hold
on oh my go read my writing um I'm going
to open I'm going to close the public ex
public executive the noticed executive
session for House 3 both 336 I'm going
to open the house uh executive session
for 423 uh and immediately recess it so
we're going to hold on to 423 uh and
this is going to be the bill that we try
to figure out if we can figure this
problem out so it's the same subject is
336 which is why we it 336 is the same
subject matter so whatever we wanted to
do in 336 we wanted to do anything we
can do to 423 um or whatever but we have
the subject matter so we're not going to
vote on it today
um uh we'll go to we have two minutes
left so we'll go to uh open up the
executive session for House Bill 448
establishing a committee to study
violations found by the April 25th 2023
ballot law commission I representes
recognize representative Lane for a
motion um I move that this be um
inexpedient to legisl okay and I will
second the motion uh is there discussion
on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
448 seeing none the the clerk will call
the role on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 4
48 second
on Lost thank you I thought so but he's
speaking so
fast okay sorry you're all in my hear me
here we go I'm
sorry all right representative qua yes
representative P O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
Representative warry
no representative wood yes
representative Harvey Balia yes
representative C
yes representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward
yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Grill yes representative Wilhelm yes
representative Nome yes
and chairman Barry chair votes yes
what's the count uh
161 uh will this will there be a
Minority
Report there will be
okay uh representative Lane you'll be
responsible for the majority
report and representative W is the only
member voting in the minority you are
responsible for the Minority
Report I'm going to close the executive
session for House Bill
448 um and it's now 1:40 so we're going
to close we're going to recess the
executive session and I'm going to open
up the public hearing on House Bill 403
relative to weather conditions which
enable absentee voting um I don't have
any pink cards for 403
okay uh
okay thank you um representative sorry
put representative in front of your name
there representative Miller uh House
Bill representative Miller is recognized
for the purpose of introduction of House
Bill 403 relative to weather conditions
which enable absente voting
representative Miller welcome to
election law uh thank you chairman thank
you for having me uh for the records
representative Seth Miller from straford
21 in Dover um I am also a moderator for
Ward five at do um and have been in that
role for four years now
um and this uh is a relatively simple
bill I hope um came up as a result of
some conversations I was having with uh
my ward Clerk and others it at the
election last year uh in November um we
have our election manual I'm sure you
guys are familiar with this Beast of a
document um there are two lines in it or
two sections in it that I've excerpted
that I'll pass around uh a bits to share
um specifically around uh the policy
that we allow for absentee voting on
Monday prior to an election if severe
weather is forecast um this is an effort
to keep people who otherwise would have
to uh travel in unsafe environment off
the streets if they have there's a set
of examples that are given if Child Care
is going to be closed and then they'd
have to have the kid with them um all
those sorts of things but the gist of it
is and something I take very seriously
as my role in my role as a moderator is
to make sure that every uh cons every
voter has the opportunity to do so in a
safe Manner and the guidance we have
received uh from Secretary of State
scanland via Visa the election procedure
manual is very clear in that it says the
best practice is to apply the broader
authorization in RSA 657 colon one and
allow any voter with concerns for safety
traveling on Election Day to vote by
absentee on the day immediately prior to
the election um the current bill defines
three specific types of storms blizzard
winter weather and uh one other that is
similar and I forget exactly what it is
um my the purpose of this is to change
that to include any National Weather
Service warning or watch um again there
we have elections in September you're
not going to have a blizzard in
September but you might have a tropical
storm or uh other severe weather coming
in the goal here again is just to make
sure that it is safe for people to be on
the roads when they're doing it and if
there is a severe weather coming in to
give them an opportunity to get their
vote in safely without having to put
themselves and others at risk and with
that I will be happy to take any
questions other questions from the
committee restive
Ward we've heard from you today yet have
you not yet thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I realize
this
isn't you're not advocating changing
this in your bill but do you think it's
wise at this point to reference the
National Weather Service which I hear is
on its way out and perhaps substitute
Twitter or Breitbart or something like
that without getting into the X versus
Twitter debate thank you Mr chairman
um I'm going to reference what currently
is in existence should it change uh we
can revisit it thank thank you yeah I
appreciate that as as a prominent user
of X despite the speaker horror um just
want to make sure we clear it's X um any
other questions for the sponsor no
seeing none thank you I don't think I
have any cards for 4 three um oh you
never want to assume an election law
brother
um uh can I have the blue sheet is there
anyone else who wishes to speak on House
Bill
403 um seeing none we're going to read
the
counts when I can find
them and we're going to go back to
Executive session Madam clerk so just
prepare prepare yourself I know you want
like this
one okay House Bill 403 uh had 114 in
support online 58 opposed online and one
two three four five in support no
opposed uh speaking of person I'm going
to close the public hearing on House
Bill
403 we're going to reopen the noticed
executive session um we're going to go
to
um uh House Bill 6
26 uh directing the Secretary of State
to implement a vulnerability disclosure
program for certain election systems uh
I will make the motion of ought to pass
is there a
second uh representative wood seconds um
and I do have an amendment I would like
to move which oh Lord give me a second
I've got it okay uh so I'd like to move
uh
Amendment uh
202-
217h to House Bill
626 and I'm passing it out right now um
I did send it to the rank I gave it to
the ranking member this morning when I
got it um but here it is to send down um
so I'm going to speak is there a second
I need a second for that representative
wood seconds me uh I'm going to speak to
the amendment so the amendment addresses
the concern of the Secretary of State uh
about basically doing a disclosure when
the vulnerability is still hasn't been
resolved um so I attempted to solve that
I did send the language to the Secretary
of States uh to the Secretary of State
and it uh it got a
resounding um it got a resounding this
is fine for now so
uh so uh what I did was uh basically if
there's an issue the SEC so this in this
bill they reference the cyber security
advisory committee which is already
established in RSA 21- R16 basically the
secretary of state has to go to this
committee which is already kind of
handling the vulnerability anyways and
in consultation with them they discuss a
proper timeline um whe what is a
reasonable timeline to fix the
vulnerability and once it's fixed then
the rest of the bill kicks in as written
um
so with that I'm happy to take questions
on the amendment or discussion on the
amendment but there was the you know I
got I got the resounding this is fine
for now
so any other questions on the amendment
okay um we can adopt amendments by a
Voice vote um so we'll try that first
and see how it goes and then if not
we'll do a division and if not we'll do
a roll call so uh all in favor of
adoption of amendment
2025 217h say I I all opposed say no the
eyes have it oh wow that's our first
Voice vote so proud of us um all right
so now uh I'm going to amend my motion
make a motion of a to pass as amended on
house build 626 with Amendment 2025 0
217h is there a second second we are now
on discussion on representative wood
seconds we are now on discussion as the
bill of the bill as amended is there
discussion on the bill as
amended seeing none when our Fab Madam
clerk is ready she shall call the role
on the vote of ought to pass as amended
on House Bill 626 H uh me read the title
directing Secretary of State Implement
of vulnerability disclosure program for
certain election
systems okay representative
qua yes representative Poma Brian yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes yes representative Harvey bolia
yes representative C yes representative
gski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Grill yes representative Wilhelm yes
representative Nome yes repres uh
chairman Barry chair votes yes what do
the count Madam chairman 17 17 to Z um
and since uh I wrote the amendment I
guess I'll write the report um is there
any objection to this bill being placed
on the consent calendar I don't see a
fiscal
note which is surprising but um all
right so seeing no objection this bill
will be placed on consent calendar hold
on I'm updating that calendar I read to
you guys last week so I'm not going to
read my campaign website out again but
I'm updating it um with that I'm going
to close the executive session for house
bills 626
see what time it is uh where are we in
the hearing
schedule we've got no we've got 10
minutes um because we don't go till two
o'clock so with that
um let's just grind this one out um I'm
going to open up the noticed executive
session for
ca3
cac3 re uh relating to recall elections
providing that the general court May
authorize uh um excuse me General May
authorize recall
elections and I recognize representative
prud home obrien to make a
motion cacr
3 yeah I believe you wanted to make an
itl motion representative I moov itl all
right is there a second representative
Mirad will second us okay nice
bipartisanship uh is there discussion on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
on cacr
3 seeing none when our fabulous
wonderful clerk is done we are moving at
break next Beed even for election law um
The Madame clerk will call the role on
CA cr3 the motion of inexpedient to
legislate representative
qua yes representative Poma Brian yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative
Balia representative C yes
representative kovski yes representative
toner yes representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Grill yes representative
welham yes representative Nome yes
chairman Barry chair votes yes and with
that the moot thank you madam clerk um
the motion will be reported out of
motion in exped to legislative ined to
legisl Carries On a vote of 17 to Z is
there any vote objection to this bill
being placed on the consent calendar
here I N representative PR O'Brien will
you be able to produce the report for us
thank you um with that I will close the
executive session on house on sorry
House Bill cacr 3 um and how much time
we have eight minutes just trying to
see I'm going to open up the notice
executive session on
House Bill
6:30 um and I'm going to recognize
there's no amendments from your from
your side right okay I'm going to
recognize excuse me get ah head of
myself here now I know it's like to be
the
clerk um representative oh uh I will
make the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on uh House Bill 6:30 s second
representative wood seconds uh is there
any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislator on House Bill
630 preventing the dissemination of deep
fake materials of political
candidates oh I'm sorry uh uh yes
represent Nome sorry I was my my sheet
cut off the title so I was having to
transfer down here to read the rest of
the title oh thank you um no I just
wanted to say that this bill um would
close a loophole and by it Ling it it
allows candidates to uh propagate false
material
in nefarious potentially nefarious
Manner and um should not be it this this
bill um was also lopsided in comments
for support was 41 to1 and I think ought
to
pass thank you further discussion on the
bill and the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
630 seeing none um Madam clerk will call
the role
motion is inexpedient to legislate the
house bill is
6:30
okay I turned you off by accident oh
representative qua yes representative
pom O Brien yes representative Burnham
yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey bolia yes representative
C yes representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane
no representative Ward
no representative Mirad nay
representative Bay no representative
Grill no Representative wilham no
representative Nome
no and chairman Barry chair votes yes
with that the motion of inexp to
legislate carries on a vote of 10 to7 um
representative Burnham you will be
responsible for the majority report
um I made your motion for you cuz you
you were you were much you were digging
um and then representative Lane who will
be responsible for the Minority Report I
believe it'll be representative Newsome
that's correct rep Nome and I assume
representative Newsome your uh Minority
Report will be OTP correct thank you and
it will be done
tonight excellent
um oh and then and then there's the
caveat I'm going to close the executive
session on House Bill 630
uh and we got five more see you guys
didn't think it could be done hang on
here we are forms hang on a
second I might be okay we have an easy
one so um yeah I mean I can write it on
here if I have to going to open up the
executive session for cacr 4 uh relating
to voting eligibility providing that
only legal resident citizens who are at
least 18 years of age or older who
reside in the place they claim as
domicile shall be eligible voters um and
I will recognize um representative Wei
for a
motion I'd like to make a motion that we
retain this is a motion to retain is
there a
second I second representative Burnham
seconds there we're now on discussion on
the motion of retain on cacr 4
um is there is there any discussion on
the motion to
retain hearing n I I don't think this is
a dispositive motion but we'll do a roll
call anyways just to be safe but I don't
think it's because it's not final action
I don't think it actually requires a
roll call but yes representative L you
wish to speak to the before I call the
RO before I call the
vote um so a motion to
retain
um does that mean that we are carrying
it over next year mean sorry I'm
interrupting I apologize or is that like
a recess uh it's not a recess it is a
motion to car it can carry over to next
year it can also be
reconsidered okay we will be voting
against this since it
um would you like to speak to the motion
all or you just I don't I don't know if
they all heard you I'm sorry represent I
already R rudely spoke over you so I'm
trying to give you another opportunity
because uh well I I I think that um
there it uses it's a cacr and it's
changing um our Constitution and it's
including terms that are not defined and
which have been litigated for probably
the past 25 years so I just don't see
any necess any any reason to keep this
going but okay is there further
discussion on the motion to retain on
cacr
4 seeing none Madam clerk will call the
role which I don't think we have to do
but we're going to do it just to be safe
so uh the motion is uh to retain on
House Bill cacr
4 representative qua yes representative
Poma Ryan Yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative Mirad
representative Bay
no representative Grill no
representative willham representative
Nome nope chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion to retain carries on
a vote of 10 to seven retaining motions
don't go to the floor so there's no
report we just we retain the bill um
next uh two minutes I think we can do it
um we're going to do um going to I'm
going to close the executive session for
cacr 4 and I'm going to open the
executive session for House Bill
47 no no I'm talking I'm looking for the
one about filing for office here we go I
apologize we're going to open up the
executive session for House Bill 327 FN
relative to filing for office and
witnessing affidavits uh I will make the
motion of ought to pass is there a
second I second that representative pram
O'Brien seconds that and I do have an
amendment I want to move
um which I I think I've given to the
ranking member and I AP I did describe
it to her but I just got it that's why I
left earlier today so I'm going to send
that down and I'm going to send that
down so I'm going to move Amendment
202-237-7000 what the amendment does is
it gets rid of all that language in
there about how many days the clerk's
open and how many hours they're open in
a two-e period it just gets rid of all
that and just says that people running
for state representative can file at
their Town Clerk or at the secretary of
state so we're going to be able to do
just what the Senate can do and the
county people can do we will be able to
do um and the Secretary of State in his
testimony did not give objection to that
when I asked him if it was okay um and I
think this is a lot cleaner than a
certain number of days a certain number
of hours and trying to be in compliance
and then somebody suing because they
were open 19 hours and if that's
allowable I think it's just it's just a
lot cleaner if we're like yeah uh you
know Clerk or Secretary of State's
office so all it did was add in or the
Secretary of State at the end of the
bill at the end of the amendment so um
with that um further discussion on the
amendment oh that was was easy okay um
with that we can adopt amendments via
voice vote because it's not a a final
dispositive action so all in favor of
adopting um amendment
202-02 37h to House Bill 327 say I I I
all oppose say no the eyes have it um
I'm now going to amend my motion to be
octop pass as amended on House Bill 327
with Amendment
225-237 H is there a second I second
that representative 9 seconds me is
there discussion on the bill as
amended okay um hearing none when our
fabulous wonderful clerk who I'm
probably going to have
to I don't know if you like coffee or
beer or whatever I'm G have to give you
whatever it is you like after the end of
this one because running through the
we're running through it but um when the
clerk is ready we are on the motion of
ought to pass as amended with Amendment
2025 0237 H to House Bill 327 the motion
is ought to pass as amended
representative qua yes representative
pom O'Brien yes representative Burnham
yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey bolia yes representative C yes
representative goovi yes representative
toner yes representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative
Grill yes representative Wilhelm yes
representative Nome yes chairman Barry
chair votes yes and with that the motion
of to pass as Amendment as amended
carries on a vote of 170 since I wrote
the amendment I will deal with the
report uh and with that we will close
the executive session on House Bill 327
FN and we will o we will uh recess the
notice executive session and we will go
back into a public hearing stance um so
we are now on going to open up the
public hearing for House Bill
294 um relative to the processing of
ballots
and uh I
have
uh my God I'm like just had like a
massive brain shut down you're good to
come oh he's supposed to be filling this
out yeah oh Jim oh you've
been I've I've got it all for you I've
got it all written down I got you
but a representative Daniels is
recognized for the purpose of
uction I was trying like I kept saying
Senator
Senator my brain just get got caught up
for about no worries yeah if you could
fill out a pink card for us when you're
when you're all set and represent
Daniels we've um because of the pace in
which we move we do limit introduction
to five minutes um so just FYI I don't
think you're going to run over that but
heads
up Mr chairman I will not run over that
as long as there aren't a lot of
questions good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee for the reckon
my name is Gary Daniels I'm a
representative from Hillsboro District
43 representing the town of Milford I'm
also the prime sponsor of House Bill
294 uh House Bill 294 simply removes the
first sentence in RSA 659
492 a provision that postpones the
processing of all absentee ballots until
after the polls close and prior to the
counting of all ballots cast in
election if you receive a petition by 10
or more individuals this provision if
utilized has the effect of significantly
delaying the reporting of election
results a number of polls in the state
are open for 14 hours Milford is one of
those towns that have voting hours from
6:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. this last
election the last voter cast the vote
about 8:45 you'll see on on my testimony
I had 9 9:30 uh I was corrected by my
moderator who will be speaking that it
was actually around 8:45 that they
cleared the polls we didn't get official
election results till at least a couple
hours later if this provision had been
utilized it could have very easily been
2 am. or later before election results
were
announced asking volunteer resources to
stay at the polls until very late at
night or even worse into early morning
hours in case they are needed is a
burden we don't need to put on those
willing to freely give of their time to
the electoral process the main part of
RSA 659
49 to the second sentence stays intact
this is a sentence that directs the
moderator on the posting of the time in
which the processing of the absent B
ballots uh shall begin at the polling
place and at addition uh when the polls
open the moderator shall announce the
time at which the processing of the
ballot shall begin I would respectfully
ask the committee to look favorably upon
House Bill 294 and vote ought to pass uh
recommendation thank you very much Mr
chairman will you be taking questions
from the committee representative yes
Daniels are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um first
up to speak is going to be
Peter
baselier did I butcher
it
yeah that's trust me I can do
worse uh and represent Daniel can you
get a pink card for me oh thank you so
much and um Mr Peter I'm just GNA call
you Peter till we get your last name can
you turn your microphone on and when I
hear your last name then I'll call you
Mr last name you got you got to press
that silver button right in front of you
thank there you go thank you Mr chairman
my last name is pronounced baselier my
name is Peter baselier and good good
afternoon to the chair and to the
members of the committee I serve as
moderator for both the town and school
district of Milford I'm here to express
my support for H Bill house Builder 294
as it introduced Milford voters elected
me as moderator in March 2008 and since
then I have managed 39 elections
including five presidential elections
with 10,000 registered voters I oversee
one of the largest po single polling
places in the state and in the nation
our success is made possible possible by
the active participation of Our Town
Clerk and our elected officials along
with nearly 140 unpaid volunteers that
we had in
November RSA 659
492 currently permits 10 or more voters
to postpone absentee ballot processing
until after the polls close for Milford
that in that is oneth of 1% of the
voters could delay the processing until
after we have closed the polls and in
November as Mr Daniel spoke uh when
numerous people registered the vote on
Election Day we didn't uh have the last
vote of cast their ballot until
8:45 I had conducted a test prior to the
November election to estimate the amount
of time it would take for us to process
absentee ballot based on the numbers
that we had received and by adding that
data to the time I estimated it would
take to count count the Right End
ballots and hand count ballots u i
projected we would not finish the
election
until after 2:00 in the morning so I ask
you to please bear in mind two things
our polls open at 6:00 in the morning so
election officials like myself and other
uh Clerk and others arrive around 5:15
a.m. if we had delayed the processing of
absentee ballots our day would have
stretched uh to about 22 hours long and
I'm not as young as I used to be um we
were we would be exhausted and when we
complete the necessary paperwork for the
second Secretary of State and Report the
results to the media it would be early
morning
hours I I would also have to ask our
unpaid election officials and unpaid
volunteers to stay overnight or arrive
in the early morning hours in order to
count the rins and hand count ballots
good luck with that so like other
polling places across the state the
processing of absentee ballots is open
to public observation and takes place
successfully while the polls remain open
I ask you that you please support the
amendment to RSA 659
492 thank you very much for your time
today no worries and just to clarify
your um by representing the amendment
you're talking about the bill not
there's not an amendment right
referencing the amendment I'm not trying
to nitpick just no that that will that
will raise confusion very quickly um is
will you be taking questions from the
committee yes i' be happy to are there
questions from Mr baselier
representative C yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh do you uh have any
recollection or knowledge of this uh 10
person petition ever being implemented
not in Milford sir uh anecdotally I've
heard but cannot verify from personal
knowledge that it has occurred in at
least one or two other
towns further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh next
up is Autumn rash chick Godwin um no did
I butcher
it let's try did I get did I get Autumn
right all right there well you points uh
after that is Jonathan
Kip good afternoon um for the record my
name is Autumn rashik Goodwin very nice
attempt though from representative Barry
um I am the program coordinator for open
democracy um uh
503 C4 uh
C3 stumbling today
501c3 um I live in Manchester New
Hampshire and I'm testifying in support
of HB
294 relative to the processing of
absentee ballots um this bill is a
bipartisan effort in a landscape where
there's not a lot of those so love to
encourage that across the aisle
connection um HB 294 removes the ability
for small groups of Voters who are far
from representative of the entirety of
their Wards 10 people in districts of
thousands really shouldn't have that
ability to completely shift the timing
of these absentee ballots being heard um
um because it can extend the time that
those results are announced it can make
the moderators and all of our election
officials have to take long hours
and as the previous speaker mentioned
often spend overnight um finally
releasing that information in the early
morning
hours so um it is for these reasons that
I encourage you to vote a to pass on to
994 will we be taking questions sure are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you next up is
Jonathan Kip and then on Deck is Dave
Nelson welcome to election law Mr
Kip thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Jonathan Kip I'm
the town moderator in the town of
londonairy and and I will Echo what the
two previous speakers said uh Londoner
is a little larger than Milford we have
18,000
757 voters currently and uh to the prior
speaker's Point that's 500s of 1% of our
voters who have the opportunity to
completely disrupt our election
processes on Election Day with no
warning these 10 people can arrive one
minute before we're scheduled to process
absentee ballots and delay it until
after the polls close which leads to
Greater opportunities for errors because
of the time we would spend long into the
the we hours of the morning um and I
find it interesting that 500s of 1% of
our voters could uh could could make
such a change to our process when on any
ballot measure it takes 50% if not a
super majority it just seems like such a
small group of people who could make
such a major change
uh so my two big reasons are a prone to
errors if this is allowed to remain in
the law and second the disruption that
it causes among the election teams that
have spent weeks planning the election
scheduling the workers having shifts
assigned and then at the last minute
that go all gets thrown into disarray so
thank you for consideration and I
support this
bill are there questions from the we be
taking questions from the committee
absolutely are there questions from the
committee
Ed one representative Ward thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
are you aware of the incidents that
happened in Durham and I think Windham
last election I've heard about them yes
I don't have direct knowledge thank you
thank
you further questions from the committee
and I accidentally shut your mic off
because I pressed the wrong button so if
somebody does ask you have to turn it
back on I'm the only one who gets that
ability I can shut off everybody's mic
and it's right next to my button so I
mispress it all the time anyway all
right uh not seeing not seeing any more
questions thank you Mr Kip next up is
Dave Nelson from
dairy Mr Nelson you'll have to press
that silver button since I turned the
mic off thank you yes
sir thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee for um hearing my
testimony this afternoon my name is Dave
Nelson I'm the dairy Town moderator I
would like to Echo and endorse the
comments of my fellow moderators who
have um given their testimony
um all of the reasons they have given
are very good um I don't see any great
Improvement in the
transparency of processing absentee
ballots if it's done later at night um
it is done in an area that's publicly
visible there's an area specifically set
up for folks to uh witness um all of
those um
activities um during the most recent
presidential election um we started
processing absentee ballots um at 9:00
in the morning which was the earliest
time we were permitted based on when the
polls opened um and we did not actually
complete processing the absente ballots
until about 8:45 is um when the polls
nomally Clos at 8 um we were still
processing absentee ballots after the
last in-person voter
voted um with all of that we were there
till 3: in the morning counting all the
hand counts and rins there were a large
number of rins
um and these are these are paid um bull
workers but people um get tired and when
you get tired you tend to make more
mistakes and so if we had to do all of
that absentee ballot processing in
between um closing the polls and
beginning um the hand and and right in
count we probably would have been there
at 7:00 the next morning um as it was it
was a 24-hour long day for me so I would
um strongly encourage
enage um the committee to um approve
this bill I support it um and as to the
practicality um to my knowledge there
has never been um a successful petition
in der to delay um processing of of
absentee violence but I am aware of at
least one or two attempts that fell
short of the required number of
signatures I happy to take questions are
the questions from the committee seeing
none thank you uh next up is Dan Healey
and then on Deck is Sarah
Shard good afternoon Dan hilly nashwa
City Clerk and I'm speaking behalf of
the New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association uh we do support this bill
um in nashwa um I have my moderators
post the processing of the absentees two
hours after the polls open I think this
is a good practice to give them as much
time as possible throughout today to
complete uh that process especially the
last election the general election it
was very busy during the day um they
would start the process they'd be pulled
in a few different directions and
waiting until the close of polls just
delays the results uh the history on
this it was not um as far as I know I
don't recall it being um ever
implemented ever used until the past few
years where one specific Community has
been kind of targeted multiple elections
in a row in you know I've asked some
questions I've asked you know what what
is the reasoning for processing the
absentees the delay and the you know the
10 individuals that have been
repetitively doing this I haven't heard
of a a good reason to process the to
delay the processing the absentees until
after the close of polls um so I'm not
really quite sure what the argument is
on the other side of why you would want
to delay um I think up until a few years
was very uh it wasn't well known that it
was even in the RSA um last year there
was a pre-processing bill in part of
that um was removing this language and
um that got ited but this has been on
our association's radar um we don't
really see the need to delay the
processing of absentees especially by a
such a low threshold 10 voters uh most
of my well all of my Awards they have
the I think the lowest I think is 4,000
we go up to 7,000 voters just 10 showing
up is is a very very low threshold to um
make a significant impact on the uh on
the processing and the results for the
day have you open any
questions you nailed your time you're
the second person to get hit the zeros
um questions from the
committee seeing none thank you and last
up is Sarah shinard I'm I'm I'm probably
butchering butchering it so
did great yes it's the highlight of my
day to show you how sad my life is
sometimes hello everybody my name is
Sarah shanard and I am the voting rights
program manager with the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights which is a
project of America votes and the New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights um
helped convene and organize an election
Protection Program for the primary and
general elections last year and one of
the things that we heard most concerned
about from our election officials was
the attempts to move abs ballot
processing to the end of the day and the
impact that that would have on when
results would actually be ready absentee
ballot processing is public noticed and
the only thing that happens when you
delay it is to the end of the night is
the entire process is longer it's more
straining on our poll workers and our
election officials and the results come
in much much later that's it will you be
taking questions from the committee sure
are there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you I don't have any
more pink cards um so with that uh in
person not speaking one two 3 four five
6 7 8 nine 10 uh people here who signed
up in support who did not speak and then
294 online was 411 support 65 opposed
with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill
294 um and we've got 9
minutes so guess what we're going to
do going to reopen the notice executive
session for the house election law
committee and um going
to uh open the executive session for
House Bill 389 FN requiring candidates
to attest that they have not spent more
than 1,000 votes in an election and I'm
recognizing representative Lane to make
a motion I move that uh it be ought to
pass is there a second
I'm sure one of her caucus members would
love to Second I'd like to second that
motion thank you are there any
amendments to House Bill uh 389 FN my
understanding is that representative
Heath had an amendment did he is it is
Howard Howard I'm sorry representative
Howard he may have given it to us and it
may be lost on my desk but I see I see
it
here they did kind of fly away
fly around I don't have it here here's
here's the amendment you're trying to
move representative Lane okay thank you
I think it came I think it came
around sitting in the gallery there okay
so um I'd like to move uh Amendment 2025
d01
95h is that slow
enough she's got it she should R is
there a second to representative Lane's
motion I will second her motion as a
show of good
will um don't don't worry will I'm about
to vote against the bill
but L would like to speak to your
Amendment yes um the amendment addresses
some of the comments that were made
particularly by the Secretary of State's
office to make the um uh terms receipts
or expenditures consistent with what we
changed last year in the um campaign
Finance Reform Bill that we did so the
the change is to attest to the receipts
and expenditures and just to have it one
box that would be checked off further
discussion on the amendment uh I'm going
to be voting for the amendment uh last
term we had a very even though we were
split 1010 we had a very good agreement
that we allowed amendments to bills um
that were not you couldn't couldn't take
a bill and completely rework it but if
we allowed people to fix their bills in
in a show of good faith um so while I I
I think may have issues with the
underlying bill I am going to vote for
the amendment um because I think that I
would like to keep that tradition going
I I see no reason to end it um so with
that uh we can adopt amendments uh by
Voice vote um so uh representative Lane
has moved Amendment
2025-the
say no the eyes have it representative
Lane would you like to am amend your
motion yes I would like to move op to
pass as
amended representative Lane moves ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 389
with Amendment 2025 015h does she have a
second representative Mirad seconds
would you like to speak to your
motion no okay uh would anyone else like
to speak to the motion of ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 2025
015h hearing none when Madam clerk is
ready
the she will call the role on the motion
of ought to pass as amended on 389 FN FN
excuse
me representative qua
no representative p o Brian no
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Harvey bolia no
representative C no representative goosi
noes representative toner no
representative Lane yes representative
Ward
yes representative Mirad yes
representative
Grill Bay first yes yes for Bay oh I'm
so sorry repres oh yes representative
Bay yes representative Grill yes
representative wilham yes representative
Newsome
yes that's seven I'd like to vote
I I'd like to vote no oh I'm sorry I I'm
really and chairman Barry all right and
with that the motion chair votes no with
that the motion of opop pass fails um
representative qua is recognized for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move that
we find HP 389 inexpedient to legislate
thank you is there a second
representative toner seconds is there
discussion on the motion of inex
speeding to
legislate representative Lane
um I've yet to hear a reason against the
bill that's been voiced and maybe I
missed it I haven't been on my game as
much as I usually am today but I would I
would like to hear why people are
against this bill that would make it
transp it's making things transparent
and all you're having to do is check a
box would any member like to answer
representative Lane's questions I would
like to address her question
representative qua are recognized
I I believe that the law as presently
constituted is completely transparent
therefore I believe that this bill is uh
redundant and unnecessary now
6647 uh RSA 6647 registering and
Reporting by candidates has two
Provisions first it says prior to filing
any campaign Finance statements a
candidate shall register with the
Secretary of State through the online
camp campaign Finance
[Music]
system the second provision is that
additionally any candidate who has
receipts or expend is exceeding 1,000 in
an election cycle shall file
statements that implies quite clearly
unambiguously and transparently that
anyone who has receipts or expenditures
over a thousand or less is not required
to uh file a campaign Finance report and
this is not an oversight in fact up
until I think it was 2021 someone
correct me if I'm misremembering but the
threshold you had to exceed to file be
required to file a report was $500 we
raised it to a th000 at that time with
no discussion about the basic concept
now the reason I say this is perfectly
transparent as currently uh as as the
RSA currently reads is the only reason
that one can legally not file campaign
Finance system report is
their expenditures or receipts did not
exceed a th000 so therefore if a
candidate does not file a report the
clear implication is that they did not
exceed that
threshold I think that's very
unambiguous if someone has a candidate
they wish to check out there's no
report they should assume that they were
following the law we are a society where
we believe in innocent until proven
guilty they should assume that the
candidate followed the law unless they
have evidence otherwise in which case
they should pursue a
complaint so the bill is redundant it's
therefore unnecessary and it therefore
imposes an unnecessary administrative
burden upon many candidates for public
office I'm most familiar with um
representatives of the New Hampshire
house we heard a statistic from the uh
witness for the bill at the public
hearing I don't remember the exact
number but it was in effect about 800 U
excuse me candidates for the New
Hampshire house and over 400 did not uh
submit a campaign Finance system report
in some recent election therefore we
would be imposing this unnecessary
burden on over 400
candidates I see that as and that would
be with no additional benefit to the
public so those are my reasons for
recommending in expedient to legislate
on this Bill thank you for your time
forther discussion on the bill
representative Lane I'll just say that
when we heard this bill last year there
were some uh comments made that uh
people had in fact uh spent more than a
thousand and there's no way to have them
affirm that they in fact did not spend
so there's no information those of us
who have to
file those of us who have to file um we
have to affirm and representative quy
and I I guess respectfully will just
disagree on whether or not this is an
unnecessary burden and whether it's
clear so thank you okay um is there any
further discussion on the bill as
amended I just want to say that I agree
with representative Lane that we
respectfully disagree
awesome um all right with that we are on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
correct uh on House Bill 389 FN and when
Madame clerk is ready she shall call the
role representative qua yes
representative purum O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey buia yes
representative C yes representative
kovski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Grill no Representative willham no
representative Nome nope and chairman
Barry chair votes yes with that the
motion of exped to legislate carries on
a vote of 10 to 7 uh representative
quaale will be responsible for the
majority report representative l who
will be responsible for my Minority
Report on on an otpa motion um I don't
you do it no you're
driving I'll do it unless representative
behead squeezes it in got it and it's an
otpa motion just for my records right
your minority reports otpa okay okay uh
with that going to close the executive
session uh on House Bill 389 and close
our executive session we're going to REO
we're going to go back into a stance of
public hearing uh I'm going to open the
notice public hearing for house B 686 FN
requiring a voter to approve
identification requesting an absentee
ballot and I'm going to recognize
representative Penza for the purpose of
introduction of the
bill representative Penza didn't think
I'd be able to stay on time today I just
want to point that out and and here we
are wow you like I said you're a
rockstar at moving this along my hearing
which is going to probably be going on
right now that I have to introduce
another bill so I'm going to be as quick
as possible for the record uh
representative Kelly pend us Stafford
District 19 um this bill has been needed
for a long time um we haven't been
following uh we haven't been following
our constitution for one thing but in
the meantime we need to get something
done we have
unqualified and um unqualified and
unchecked absentee voters that's going
on um our our clerk in our town excuse
me City Clerk in Rochester um basically
told me that she cannot ask for ID for
someone it is uh she was actually um a
few years ago was um landbased because
someone came in that was a clerk or
worked in the clerk's office at another
city and uh told her that you can't do
that so this changes that um and it
changes of course people that are
requesting uh an absentee ballot as well
um so right now in the city if you go in
to request an absentee ballot you do not
have to to show an ID if you do which
most people do um they'll take it and
write it down but they can't ask for it
um
so and then you let's say you take it
home you do whatever you need to do and
then you bring it back you also don't
have to show an ID to bring it back
unless you're someone that's dropping it
off for them so the person that's
dropping it off that isn't actually the
voter um has to show an ID it's it's in
pure Insanity um the other piece is um
basically if you're calling you know
you're calling for an absentee ballot or
you send in an absente ballot
application and you're calling for it to
have one sent to you um that in filling
out that application that you're not
required to show an ID as well um you
should be just like anything else um you
should have your ID it it should be a a
real affidavit um not just signing a
piece of paper anybody could sign that
piece of paper
and excuse me we need um we need it
notorized so that's what this bill does
it makes um uh basically unqualified
unaccounted for mail and ballots um
legit and we need this for another
reason as well we're creating we what
we've created in the state of New
Hampshire is two class system so if I go
in person and I vote I have to to show
an ID to vote we have that and it's a
law but if I request a um an absentee
ballot I don't we created two classes of
Voters and that's illegal as well so
this bill fixes that and that's pretty
much um all I have to say about that
will you be taking questions from the
committee sure are there questions from
the committee repres new thank you for
the he's not being obnoxious I can't see
him because of he's back he's not he's
not trying to like mock you he literally
I can't see him so than than you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh voting in person do you need
anything notorized when you go in to
vote in
person uh no unless thank you very
much the member make answer the
question okay so are you're saying like
if you come in with an ID no you
wouldn't need to notorized that would
you like a follow person new some and
please and and I I please accept my
apology for cutting you off I do
apologize for that that's fine um your
complaint with the ID versus was an
illegal two class system wouldn't the
requirement for notarization create that
just in the opposite direction how that
how are you going to prove if it's if a
a ballot is coming by mail that someone
showed an ID that's what the that's what
the notary would be is someone check
that ID they said who they were before
you sent in your
ballot further questions from the
committee representative
Lane are you aware that you're signing
an affidavit that if your to fraudulent
sign it you're under voter fraud laws
currently it's up to $5,000 and a
misdemeanor I'm I'm quite aware of that
but an affidavit is not an affidavit if
it's not verified by by someone that um
is in a sense showing an ID and all you
an affidavit means nothing if you're
just signing a piece of paper and it
doesn't get followed up on we have we
have thousands and thousands of of sworn
affidavits that don't get followed up on
at all in the state further questions
from the
committee representative C uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
um is it possible then that if later on
we require that uh the absentee balance
be notorized that then then a person
would have to be uh getting two
different
notorized ballot would have to be
notorized it would be just in requesting
it you are just when you're when you go
in person you give your ID they check
you off they make sure everything's good
to go address is all lined up and you're
handed a ballot we should be doing the
same way it's the same exact process but
it's just going to be done
via
absentee further questions from the
committee representative Lane have there
been any recorded instances of fraud in
New Hampshire in connection with this
problem um recorded incidences there's
been I don't know if you recorded
incidents as as uh um yes I'm going to
say yes I'm going to say yes on on all
of that and and things have been brought
to um the AG's attention things haven't
been followed through there's going to
be some testimony behind me that will um
hopefully um tell you about that as well
um we did so for example uh in the 2020
election uh I lived in Rye and so these
are my firstand examples uh we had we
had over a 100% voter turnout that's
statistically impossible when they most
that they've ever had was in the 60s so
we did canvasing
afterwards and the the voter roles were
manipulated people were sent ballots
that didn't even live at those homes as
you can imagine in Rye um some of those
people are just renting them out of
course for whether the summer or winter
rental so we canvased afterwards and I
knocked on doors and I asked to speak to
Mr Mrs Smith who lived there that voted
in that election they didn't live there
and they hadn't lived there for three or
four
years that happened more than a dozen
times so yes I have firsthand knowledge
further questions from the
committee representative Wei we we tend
to we alternate we just had a Democrat
ask now we're a republican ask then
representative William you can be up and
we can all have our
turn uh thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question so the the issue
as you see it is at the polling place
you have identity verification going on
by the election officials right then
when the absentee ballot is sent in
there is no identity verification at
that point and so you're proposing that
the notary republic or or some
notarizing entity would verify the
identity and that's what you're seeking
to accomplish here right correct thank
you further questions from commit
representative Willams
recognized thank you chairman
representative thanks for taking my
question is there a reason that the
photoc copy needs to be in
color photo copy needs to
color hold on sorry
that's
right page two line page line 15
okay no I mean that was so I told OS
exactly what I needed and they that was
written in by them that was not
specified by me I can kind of understand
I guess um why um it's a color copy of a
valid govern government issued photo
identification with this form to receive
an absentee ballot um if the applicant
does not include a color copy uh the
applicant's ballot would be rejected um
I think it's probably has something to
do with it's easier to
um to have a or to manipulate an ID if
it's in black and white versus it being
in color so that must be the reason why
that was put there I didn't I didn't
write that language the attorney did an
OSS but if that's a problem we can look
at that I
I I I glassed over that whole thing my
whole point was just we need to have
people show an ID in person when they go
to a clerk's office to request their ID
to request their ballot as well as when
it is mailed in or dropped off further
questions from the committee representa
C you'll be next but representative girl
has not asked a question yet so so you
guys know when there's a lot of
basically what I do is I try to
alternate party and if I can't do that
but who if somebody has not asked a
question first they will always go to
the front of the line so new people
speaking will always be in front but I
try to alternate so we'll go to
representative Grill because she has not
spoken yet thank you um there's a lot of
identity verification technology that's
currently in use you know for example
for online baking there has to be some
sort of system when you scan in a a
check um certain Healthcare Services
have ID scanners what it might
streamline things perhaps might not be
the most coste efficient but maybe with
people requesting ballots online more
and more often would an online
verification system might be a more
streamlined and um you know some some
sort of either scanner or um or way of
matching that to the data that's on file
um with the ID would that be a more
streamlined and better in the long-term
solution especially with a lot of people
who uh you know might not have a
photocopy or a lot of people are going
more and more
digital I hear your um I hear your
concern and um I am you know a
hand-counted paper ballots kind of gal
so I'm going to say no on that because I
believe that we were able to do it for
um you know over a hundred years and I
think we could do that again I'm not for
like an online portal um just because I
think that that opens us up for other
problems um in my in my um not every
city has this but in our city we have
pole pads and um and so basically you
can give them your license and it scans
it right in and it pulls up um those are
supposed to be a a closed system um so
you know if that is the will of the
people then for something like that I'd
be okay with it but for right now it's
not I don't believe that that is going
to be something that we're going to be
able to push forward so in the meantime
um we should be able to do this the good
thing is is that if you're going in
person or you are going to pick up a
ballot for someone that is disabled when
you show your ID um so for example at
the city clerk's office that's all
written down and noted and they have
that option as well they have that
option to get notorized right then and
there they could bring in the person's
ID with them like that whole piece can
can already happen so for example there
was a woman she was in her car um her
daughter um brought in her ID um she
waved at her from the car I mean it was
you know it we're not trying to um we're
we're not trying to make it more
difficult we need to have the same
process everybody should be on the same
playing field whether you're a mailin
vote absentee Vote or if you're voting
in person we should all be showing our
ID just like we need to do for
everything in this you know
I was just uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative for taking my
question uh if somebody's got to get
this application notorized do they need
to show their actual ID to the notary
and not have to send in a copy of the U
of their ID
correct further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative Penza um next up is Linda
Bundy from antrum
Miss money I don't I don't know if we've
seen you yet this year if we have my
apologies oh welcome to see very good
memory welcome to election
law uh and next up of that is Liz
tantarelli
good afternoon chairman Barry and
members of house election law my name is
Linda Bundy I'm Miss Bundy can you pull
your microphone down just a little bit
yes thank you you're welcome uh my name
is Linda Bundy and I'm from antrum I
oppose hb6 86 requiring a voter to
provide identification when requesting
an absentee ballot at the present time
absentee ballot applications must be
signed by the voter and anyone who
assists them with completing the
application this bill requires
authorization of the application as well
as inclusion of a color copy of a valid
governmen issued photo ID these steps
would be inconvenient for any voter who
is eligible to vote absentee but for
senior citizens and people with
disabilities they are a significant
undue
burden there is also a monetary cost for
these requirements which would be borne
by the voter eligible voters may decide
that it is simply not worth their time
energy and money to vote absentee voting
in New Hampshire is secure and safe HB
686 places unnecessary hurdles in front
of Voters that may prevent their
participation in the democ Democratic
process of voting I ask that you vote in
expedient to legislate on this Bill
thank you for your time thank you uh
will you be taking questions from the
committee sure all right questions
saying none thank you Liz tantarelli um
after that is Autumn rashik rash I got
it so close the first time go Godwin and
then then I'm I'm like going in the
wrong direction
thank you for the opportunity to speak
I'm Liz tenelli president of the League
of Women Voters of New Hampshire and
we're trying to empower voters not to
deter them I'd like to address the
notorized in this bill and the Very
people who might want to vote absentee
such as those with health and disability
issues uh being out of town um being at
home caring for someone who can't be
left alone those are the very people for
whom getting to a a notary would be
difficult I was talking with a League of
Women Voters member from the North
country and so I looked up notaries
online for her town and the nearby
larger town and nothing came up there's
a a website called National notary.org
that supposedly lists them now we know
that some banks have notaries but not
all their hours that are open we know
that some post offices but not all serve
as notaries some Town clerks do but for
some of these people who have a
legitimate reason to try to get an
absentee ballot getting to those
notaries during The Limited times when
they're available could be a real
problem in New Hampshire according again
to a website about notaries it's
permissible to charge from10 to
$25 for notary services I know that some
sources Do It free my town clerk did in
my former town of
Newbury uh but that doesn't mean all of
them would do it for free in fact just
the opposite some would
charge so in both this bill and 608 that
require notorized
and IDs you're essentially creating a
pole tax for some people who have a
legitimate reason for getting an
absentee ballot this is just wrong thank
you thank you we be taking questions
from the committee Miss tanelli no okay
thank
you uh up next uh M uh rashik good
one I know my handwriting probably
doesn't help the
situation push the button um for the
record my name is Autumn rashik Goodwin
the program coordinator for open
democracy and I live in Manchester New
Hampshire I'm testifying in opposition
to hb6 86 um as was pointed out by the
speakers before me many voters decide to
vote absentee ballots due to physical
limitations due to being out of town and
this makes getting something notorized
exceedingly difficult and creates a
barrier for them casting their
ballots they may not have the reliable
transportation they may not have a
notary in their Town
um additionally there's a cost involved
when it comes to getting something
notorized in many cases um according to
the National notary Association on
average it costs $10 in New Hampshire to
get some a form notorized
so this bill doesn't address that and
how that would be paid would that be
waved by the state would the individual
have to cover that would that then be a
pole tax um it between the burden that
this creates and the potential cost
ramifications it
really has the potential to
disenfranchise voters particularly ones
living on fixed incomes who don't have
the budget wiggle room to pay this sort
of
notorized to vote itl on HB
686 thank
you thank you will be take will you be
taking questions from the committee
are there any questions from the
committee not seeing anything any thank
you very
much next uh Kingston
Evans I got that right yeah oh okay oh
I'm sorry Kristen
Evans thank you Dear honorable chair and
committee members again my name is
Kristen Evans and I serve as the
Director of policy for AEL New Hampshire
which is a Statewide disability Justice
organization dedicated to protecting and
advancing the civil and human rights of
people with disabilities in New
Hampshire I am here today to strongly
oppose HB 686 HB 686 erects unnecessary
and discriminatory barriers to absentee
voting by mandating that voters submit a
color copy of a governmen issued photo
ID with their application and requiring
not notarization of absentee ballot
applications these Provisions impose
undue burdens on voters with
disabilities older ad adults and others
who rely on absentee voting as a
fundamental means of civic
participation requiring voters to submit
a color copy of their in identification
creates significant accessibility and
financial barriers many individuals with
disabilities lack uh reliable
transportation making it difficult to
access Loc s where they can make color
copies the financial burden of printing
or copying documents in color further
compounds this issue particularly those
for those on fixed
incomes additionally not all individuals
have access to the Necessary Technology
to scan and print a color copy at home
further disenfranchising voters who
already face systematic barriers
mandating notarization of absentee
ballot applications introduces yet
another hurdle for voters with Mobility
impairments those in rural areas and
individuals in congregate care settings
accessing a notary can be a logistical
and financial challenge while some
states have implemented virtual
notarizations New Hampshire has not made
this option widely available for
absentee voting leaving many without a
feasible means to comply with this
requirement the additional burden of
finding traveling to and in some case
paying for a notary creates an undue
barrier that disproportionately impacts
disabled V voters New Hampshire has a
long history of upholding the
fundamental right to vote including for
those who cannot vote in person due to
disability HB 686 undermines this
principle by making absentee voting an
already essential accessibility measure
excessively difficult to navigate these
requirements will have a
disproportionate impact on individuals
with mo mobility impairments who cannot
easily travel to make copies or visit a
notary individuals who are blind or have
low vision and may not be able to
independently copy their identification
individuals with intellectual and
developmental disabilities who may
require assistance when comp with
complex administrative tasks and
residents of congre care settings who
have lied excuse me could you please
conclude your testimony thank you
limited access to external Services
thank
you almost okay next up Mackenzie
Taylor and then on Deck is Dan Healey
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Mackenzie Taylor um and I'm
with the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights and America votes and we
oppose House Bill 686 um wanted to I
know a lot of points have been brought
up today but wanted to start off by
reminding folks that like other
affidavits affidavits on absentee ballot
forms are signed under penalty of
perjury with serious consequences um
many folks as talked about vote absentee
you know for a lot of different reasons
but a large group of them are uh folks
with disabilities including seniors um
and under this legislation not only
those folks have to go through the
multi-step process of requesting an
absentee ballot and then getting it or
also adding in having a color or black
and white printer um and scanner to have
that copy of their ID and finding a
notary um earlier it was mentioned that
folks could maybe go in you know bring
the the application in with a with the
IDE or a copy of the ID whoever the
legislation requires that the applicant
signature is notorized so it's not just
having the ID brought in or having
someone who's dropping it off notorized
the person who is applying for the
absentee ballot who potentially cannot
leave their home cannot travel that
person has to have the notorized
signature um and as I was reading this
bill and thinking about my testimony I
really thought about my grandmother who
uh voting meant a lot to her she worked
at the polls in marac year after year
would talk to all about it would talk
about volunteering on political
campaigns calling voters in the French
side on the west side of Manchester and
speaking French to them uh and she loved
voting but as she got older and she lost
her sight um and wasn't able to stand in
line and vote as easily wasn't able to
work at the polls um she started voting
absentee and my dad would help her that
with that um and even though she was
someone who had voted her whole life and
it meant so much to her she often felt
like it was really a burden to have
assistance with getting the application
sending it in filling out her ballot
having someone help with that having
them deliver it um and thinking through
this adding these extra requirements
maybe having a notary come to her home
or going to the bank um you know having
someone having someone have to make a
photocopy of her ID I am fearful of you
know what that would mean to her in
terms of additionally feeling like
voting was a burden and maybe sitting
out for that reason and I hope that that
does not happen to other voters in the
same way um so thank you so much and I'm
happy to take questions thank you other
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you uh next up is Mr Richard Mr I
apologize your your car got uh lost in
the bottom you should have gone earlier
as a member of the public I
apologize all right thank you for your
time members of the committee chairman
um on this affidavit issue first and
foremost I just submitted to all of you
a copy of the
overvote uh when people claim that there
is no disenfranchised or vote delution
they're not telling the truth and here's
why first of all I'm in front of the
state supreme court on this very issue
the state supreme court has found I have
standing on this issue which is everyone
must be treated the same now the
affidavit requirement is a matter of Law
and it has usage and custom in 1942 when
the state legislature saw fit to write
the statutes to establish absentee
voting in the process they put in in the
affidavit requirement which is statute
which I testified to earlier
65950 colon B the moderator of every
town is required to examine that
envelope and make sure that the
affidavit was properly executed that
definition in law has been established
by this body so you have first the
courts of law every Court in this state
in order to submit evidence into a court
of law has to have a sworn affidavit
before an official authorized by law to
administer an oath the legislature has
seen fit that there are 262 places where
a stat where an affidavit must be
executed the the word and the usage is
well known it's 500 years old we can't
redefine the word affidavit for
convenience sake if we're going to amend
the process then amend the process but
what I'm pointing out to you is that we
have a disparity in the equal
application of the law which is everyone
in the state has to produce an ID in
order to vote if you apply for a mailin
vote and go to your local municipality
they're going to check it for you and
they're going to take your ballot again
the problem isn't uh the problem isn't
whether I'm for or against it I'm simply
pointing out that we have laws on the
books that are binding and more
importantly this committee last year
passed House Bill 1569 there is no
excuse voter ID everyone who votes must
produce an
ID thank you Mr Richard questions um
other questions from the
committee saying none thank you last up
is Dan Healey thank
you good afternoon Dan Healey nashwa
city clerk um I am opposed to this bill
uh for the same reasons as a lot of the
previous speakers so I don't want to go
over those again I do have a point um to
make that I don't believe was brought up
so absentee uh ballots they can be
requested currently with the application
we can receive that back by mail email
fax or in person so if you add a notary
we can no longer receive them by facts
we can no longer receive them by email
and I would say a good amount of our
requests were actually uh emailed to the
clerk's office so you're taking out that
aspect of uh the voter being able to
email the request in I see in here too
there's if um the absentee request is
not notorized they don't provide the ID
it says that we shall reject it but I
don't see a procedure in here for if we
do reject it are we to notify the voter
is the clerk or responsible then for
some communication with the voter saying
that we received your request but now
it's been rejected because you did not
provide um all the documentation or have
the um the request notorized
um in addition notaries aren't always
free so someone that needs a notary
might have to pay for that notary
service if the notary comes to their
house because their homebound it might
be an extra charge for that notary so
you're now basically charging the voter
to submit this absentee
request um and then my last thing is if
someone comes in person to request an
absentee ballot why that point would
they need their application notorized if
they're in person because we talked
about uh um similar to inperson voting
on Election Day provided your ID you get
the ballot they're not having anything
notorized on that day when they're
giving the ID and they're getting the
ballot from the ballot clerk but this
now would say someone coming in to
request an absentee ballot say a few
days prior to the election they show
their ID now their application needs to
be notorized now you're treating the
absentee voter different than the voter
on Election Day which I don't think we
want to be doing and you open any
questions uh are there questions from
the Committee hearing none thank you um
Mr Mr ah resent gasovi can you grab that
uh blue sheet for me um I don't have
anyone else I don't have any of the pink
cards for 686 do anyone else wish to
speak on House Bill
686 um online for House Bill
686 there were 411 in support and 65
post um and then on the blue sheet
uh representative Daniels are you in a
committee meeting right now or you are
we your only thing would you mind if we
EXA one bill before we did your I have
members that need to leave soon um I I
don't want to be rude to your time in
considerer of your time thank you so
thank you so much one two three four
five six seven eight nine uh there were
nine people uh who did not speak who
were signed in in opposition to the bill
with that I'm going to close the public
hearing for House Bill 686 I'm going to
reopen the executive session uh I'm
going to open up the executive session
for House Bill
474 um which is requiring a second
witness at the counting of right in
votes and I'm going to recognize our
clerk representative Burnham for a
motion yes I'd like to make a motion um
to adopt Amendment Let's do an OP to
pass motion first don't mind sorry is
there a
second representative Harvey buia
seconds um representative Burman sounds
like you have an amendment you'd like to
move
yes I do um it's Amendment and I this I
don't know if everybody has a copy but
it's um Amendment 2025
d216 does everyone have a copy of the
amendment that needs
one give us just a second we'll get it
distributed it's
okay that's it right there in it 474
yeah yes there it is sorry it's a trying
not to pass papers in between but
so we're have we're have to figure out a
system of people putting their submit a
testimony up there because like it what
happens it just concentrates here and
it's like I'll be here till 6 all right
so we can you read the number again for
us represent it's um 2025 d
0216 uh there was question at the we
need a second is there a second to the
amendment representative Harley bully is
second representative Baron would you
like to speak to your
Amendment yes
I would uh so this just kind of cleans
up in line eight um where there was some
question about who should be present as
a second witness witness um it's been
changed to this counting shall take
place in the presence of another sworn
in election official um I was told by
Deputy Hennessy that um they're they're
fine with this um it still requires that
there's a sworn in elected official and
um um that would include if if the
selectman or town clerk were there or
someone else that's not necessarily busy
I think that was the the issue that may
come up during this process is that
perhaps the clerk or the selectman may
be busy with another
task further discussion on the
amendment yes representative Grill so
just to clarify this replaces the
requirement that they be of two separate
parties yes okay yes we remove that as
well okay thank you further discussion
on the amendment
hearing sorry representative Ward I
apologize sorry uh thank you I just H I
think in my ward we been moderator clerk
for 20 years all our elected officials
are sworn in and the tabulation of
everything is in front of them including
W in votes so I think this is
exceptionally
unnecessary further comments on the
amendment hearing none um we'll try a
Voice vote we'll see how it goes if not
we'll do a vision and a roll call so all
in favor of adopting Amendment one more
time for me I the number I just don't
have it front me so I can't read it is
d216 uh all in favor of adoption of
amendment 2025
0216 H to House Bill 474 say I I all
opposed say no the eyes have it
representative burnam you recognize for
a motion ought to pass with amendment
can you read the amendment number please
yes it is
202-21 6h representative Burnham moves
Amendment 2025
0218 uh to House Bill two uh House Bill
474 is there a
second uh representative Harley bolia
seconds there discussion on the bill is
amended okay uh hearing none the clerk
will call the
role representative qua hi
representative Pomo Brien yes
representative Burnham yes rep
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative gski
yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative
Gilmore I'm sorry I'm getting
tired representative Mirad no
representative Bay no Representative
willham
no did I miss one representative Grill
no representative Nome
no and chairman baring chair votes yes
with that the motion of op to pass
Amendment carries on a vote of 10 to 7
um representative buram you'll be
responsible for the majority report who
will be responsible for the Minority
Report representative Lane uh
representative Ward would you do that
report thank you word all right and
that's our last noticed executive
session for the day uh so I'm going to
gabble that down uh as a notice to the
chair notes to the members I will not be
calling any more executive votes for the
day so if you do have to go um obviously
I would prefer you stay for the public
testimony but there will be no more
votes today um with that uh thank you
representative Daniels for indulging us
as we dispense with our last bill um and
I I do appreciate uh you allowing us 10
minutes of your time to dispose of that
um going to open up the public public
hearing on House Bill 344 enables the
processing of absente ballots before
election day recognize representative G
Daniels for the purpose of
introduction oh thank
you okay yes representative C do you
have a procedural question yes don't we
have three more after this that are on
the yes but some some members they have
commitments and it's just a notice that
there will be no more
votes so if they were if they were
waiting to vote they may leave obviously
what they do is is is their business but
I feel it's a matter of um courtesy
there will be no more votes today so if
that's what they're basing their day on
then they can do with their time as they
see fit yes representative weary would
there be any objection to um I know we
execute uh House Bill 448 would there be
any since it was a 16 to1 vote would
there be any objection to putting that
on the consent calendar yeah let's just
thank you for noticing that let's just
dispense that quickly representative
Daniel just a moment I apologize I'm
going to reopen executive session uh
representative Wei would you like to
State your
purpose it's there's no voting it's just
consent calendar and it's procedural
entirely yeah uh just uh I would request
that the committee uh put put this on
the consent calendar since it was just a
16 to1 vote okay so you will not be
submitting a Minority Report as earlier
indicated correct okay is there
objection to house bill for
474 was that 48 was there is there any
objection to House Bill 448 being placed
on consent given that representative
weary is withdrawing his Minority
Report hearing none the bill will be
placed on consent thank you now we now
we're going to leave executive session
and now we're going to recognize
representative Daniels uh represent
Daniels thank
you thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
me members of the committee for the
record my name is Gary Daniels I'm a
representative from Hillsboro 43
representing the town of Milford I'm
also the prime sponsor of House Bill 344
a bill that has bipartisan support under
current law the opening of absentee
ballot outer envelopes can only be done
on Election Day in 2020 during covid the
house passed House Bill
1266 in part changing RSA 6594 NB to
enable the opening of absentee ballot
outter envelopes prior to election day
but House Bill 1266 only applied to the
September 2020 primary and the November
2020 general election numerous towns
requested that certain provisions of
House Bill 1266 be reenacted on a
temporary basis to apply to 2021 Town
meetings and elections in response to
these requests the general court
introduced Senate Bill 2 and inserted
the house language from House Bill
1266 relating to the opening of absentee
ballot out of
envelopes the the governor issued
executive order number 83 relating to
Temporary Provisions to respond to
timing challenges related to the
enactment of Senate Bill 2 to bridge the
gap between the then current date in the
final enactment of House Bill excuse me
Senate Bill 2 in the 2021 legislative
session in December
2021 the election law committee voted
Senate bill to itl acknowledging that
the
elections which Senate Bill 2 addressed
had already taken place under the
procedures specified in executive order
number 83 and therefore are no longer
relevant at the termination of the
executive order the statute reverted
back to the requirement that abcy ballot
outter envelopes could not be opened
until election day whereas the early
opening significantly benefits all
absentee ballots to ensure their vote
counts Senate House Bill 344 seeks to
reestablish that process very simply if
you were to submit an absentee Bell and
forget to sign the affidavit that
envelope would not be opened until
election day because you are away which
is why you voted by absentee ballot you
would not be able to correct the
deficiency and your vote would not be
counted on the other hand if you were to
submit an absentee ballot and forget to
sign the affidavit and the deficiency
were noted prior to election day there
may be the opportunity for an election
official to notify you and have the
deficiency corrected prior to election
day thereby ensuring your ballot vote is
counted let's face it we all make
mistakes but our right to vote is too
precious to be thrown away because of a
mistake or omissions especially when we
the legislature have the ability to
offer Grace by affording a few days
before election day to to determine that
everything is in order and that an
individual's vote is secure to that end
I respectfully ask the committee to vote
House Bill 344 ought to pass this
concludes my testimony and I'd be happy
to answer any questions thank you Mr
chairman are there questions from the
committee representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
the last sentence in that uh uh
paragraph 659
49b says you open the ballot uh open the
outer envelope but you can't remove the
inner um envelope so how can you check
the um completeness of the application
without being able to take the ballot
out or the inner envelope
out could I ask that you uh refer that
question to my town moderator who will
be speaking after me I'm I'm sure he's
he's been through 39 elections so uh I'm
sure he could tell you how the process
is done thank
you further questions from the
Committee hearing none um thank you
representative Daniels next up will be
Dave Nelson from dear oh actually
representative Nelson you wanted your
good Lord I'm tired um we're gonna I'm
tired
well uh we're going to go with Peter
basilir Basel first because that's a
representative d
wanted um and maybe I'll pick up who
knows probably
not sir you're you're doing well Mr
chairman you remembered how to pronounce
my name so I appreciate that thank you
um good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh my name is
Pete baselier and for 17 years I have
been moderator for both the town and
school districts of Milford and I am
here to express my support for House
Bill 344 as it has been
introduced um RSA
5949 B currently permits the opening of
absentee out of ballots on Election Day
either at 1:00 p.m. or no earlier than
two hours after the polls open the
Amendment grants communities the
authority to carry out this process any
time up to one week before the
election due to CO's impact as
representative Daniels pointed out
Governor Sun sununu authorized this
pre-processing of absentee ballots
during the week before the fall 2020
state and federal elections in Milford
we took over the selman's SEL board's
meeting room and set up tables where we
opened and read aloud the names of the
voters who had submitted their absentee
ballot members of the two political
parties as well as other interested
observers could watch and hear the
process very easily allowing them to
challenge an absentee ballot when
necessary importantly as representative
Dan Daniels pointed out the town clerk
or her assistant was able to reach out
to the voters with incomplete ballot
affidavits inform them that their ballot
would not be counted as is and provide
them with the opportunity to corre
correct the
deficiency absentee ballots that were
received after this pre-processing were
process as normal on Election
Day currently the processing of absentee
ballot is open to public observation and
Aur successfully while the polls are
open this amendment reaffirms that while
also adding another layer of convenience
for those who may challenge absentee
voters as well as for the voters who
have made an inadvertent mistake on
their application and would like to have
the opportunity to correct that that
ends my testimony and I am welcome to uh
take your
questions if there are there questions
from the committee representative Ward
and thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question would you say that
this gives absentee voters the same
chance to correct a mistake that a voter
in person has when they vote when they
can take three ballots if they it's
they're not quite the same I think
representative in the sense that um if a
person when they check
in immediately if there's a question
about that person's uh Identity or
residence and so forth that can be
corrected but in neither case are we
suggesting that they correct the ballot
it's only that the affidavit which has
not been signed and which should be
signed um has has not been signed so
therefore we can they can correct it but
that exists that circumstance does not
exist with a person who comes into the
polling place I just a followup
followup yeah I agree with you I think a
person who screws up their ballot while
they're voting can get another ballot
two times you can do it three times that
that's correct so that's a remedy in the
same way you're talking about reming the
absentee ballots I'm sorry could you
reate your question they're basically
saying that an absentee voter has a
chance to cure or remedy their ballot
they have
a correction the they have the ability
to sign the affidavit which they had not
done prior so they're not having another
opportunity to change their ballot right
but it fixes a mistake yeah on on a
ballot you're
right which is what exists today and and
the current law also enables that yes I
was trying to get rid of two classes of
Voters oh I hear you but it sounds like
there might be two um always are further
questions from the
committee uh representative weary uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so just from a
logistical standpoint would there uh
this says more than one
week would you understand this to be a
single time one week prior where all
absentee ballots received up to that
point are then processed but then
anything after that would have to be
processed on Election Day as per
normal uh practice currently I'm just
I'm trying to avoid a
long uh extension of Daily Review of
absentee ballots prior to the actual
election day uh thank you for that
question um the the proposal is no more
than one week earlier so we're talking
about the the Tuesday through the
following Monday um and yes I do
anticipate that would be a day properly
noticed uh so anyone that wishes to
attend could do
that um and you're correct
that as in in 2020 the Thursday before
the uh uh November election we had uh we
did the pre-processing on a Thursday the
ballots that were received Friday
Saturday Monday and on Election Day
would have been processed on Election
Day further questions on the committee
representative
C okay all right thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh this
is a question I posed to sponsor of the
bill um when you're doing this do you
have to take the inner envelope out of
the remove it from the outer envelope in
order to check the affidavit and
everything because the last part of that
sentence a last sentence in this
paragraph which is the existing law
which is not changed says you can't do
that that's that's correct what happens
what what happens is when we we slit the
the outer envelope the mailing envelope
with a stamp on it if it was mailed as
posted delivered in hand um then you you
can look at the affidavit envelope on
the inside um you may have to turn it 90
180 degrees in order to to see it
depending upon how the person put their
their affidavit envelope containing the
ballot into the envelope but you're
right we don't take it out at that
point representative
weary uh yes um I'm again I'm just sort
of p uh puzzled about the logistics
um is there a do you do you forese a
need
to you specify the discussion that we
had about the single day and then uh any
accumulated after that single day review
of the affidavits would be done on
Election Day or you know do we let that
be handled by the election
manual well um I I suppose clarification
that that said one time within that that
period of no more than one week that
could be added uh I think as a practical
matter most clerks town and City would
not want to do it more than once um and
uh so that's that may be the constraint
that actually occurs but um so you might
wish to consider that as as a a slight
change U but the intent certainly is for
the um process to occur one time one day
duly noted and
posted further questions from the
committee seeing none thank
youcome Mr Dave Nelson is up next
actually uh we are a little behind
schedule
now um representative Panic are you in
Committee hearing right now are you in a
are you in a committee right now are you
would you mind if we finish this this
one first okay thank
you okay awesome we're going to continue
on um representative Nelson Nelson wo Mr
Nelson we're getting there a couple more
we're getting there yeah thank you um Mr
chair and members of the committee um
good afternoon um Dave Nelson um Town
moderator from from Derry
um I think this would be um a great help
um especially for towns like d that tend
to have significant numbers of absentee
balance we have well over 20,000
registered voters so the process can
take time um and the ability to um
notify folks that they can remedy their
their ballots is is certainly a boom to
the voters while we were processing them
on Election Day I would period
periodically go over and if there were
ones that were rejected for a cure able
defect I would actually call um the the
voter if we have the phone number and
and let them know that if they were to
come down to the election um polling
place they could correct the defects but
very few people were available to take
advantage of that and so doing an
advance would help um with respect to
doing that on one day yes um we want to
make that a formal correction um I don't
think we would want to do it more than
once you have to get the staff you have
to do the notice I think it'd be very
cumbersome um to do the advanced
processing on more than a single day um
I support this um bill and I thank you
for your time I will take questions
other questions from the committee
saying none thank you next up is
Jonathan Kip after that on Deck will be
McKenzie
Taylor Mr Kip welcome
back thank you Mr chair chairman members
of the committee Jonathan Kip I'm the
town moderator in the town of londonairy
um I also am in favor of this bill and
uh recommend that it uh that it it pass
um I won't repeat what my colleague my
two prior colleagues have said because I
I agree with them however there are a
couple of um I think unintended positive
consequences of this
practice um one is that it gives us a
great opportunity to educate voters when
we pre-process absentee ballots it's a
much calmer environment it's open
there's not a crowd and uh I know when
we did it in 2020 for the general
election I had the opportunity to chat
with voters who came in to observe and
poll Challengers who were there and we
just established a great line of
communication and I'll respectfully
recommend that if you haven't already
that committee members review the final
report of the special committee on voter
confidence that was released on December
22nd
2022 one of their recommendations was to
expand voter education efforts and I see
this as a um a great opportunity to do
exactly
that and another benefit that others
mentioned was the opportunity for
absentee voters to come in if they're
available to remedy whatever the
deficiency was in their submission and
it may be unique only to London Derry
but I doubt it if we do it on a day
other than election day they can find a
parking place quickly and come in and do
it um a second recommendation of this
special committee was it addressed in
uh under recommendations Roman numeral
ey number four absentee ballot
improvements and with uh with your
permission I will read the short segment
they wrote on this you have you have one
minute M um s so just be judicious
consideration should be given by the
legislature to allow for the
pre-processing of absentee ballots by
opening the outer envelopes as was
allowed in 2020 for all elections
testimony stated that it worked well
aided local officials in completing
their jobs and did not affect accuracy
or security and we can attest to that in
London Derry when we pre-processed 5,800
absentee ballots the day before the
election in November of 2020 I'll be
happy to entertain questions questions
from the
committee representative we uh just uh
one quick question uh did you then
secure those open uh uh ballots
envelopes to you know in the normal uh
securing process as you would after an
election yes sir we keep our ballots in
the town hall vault which is directly
across the street from where we hold the
uh hold the elections police escort we
took the ballots over the day before the
election day pre-processed them and then
with the police escort took them back
and placed them back in the vault until
election
day further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you uh next up
McKenzie Taylor uh and on Deck Autumn
rosic
Goodwin like like a b b
minus I know all
right good afternoon I'm Mackenzie
Taylor with New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights and America votes um we
are in support of this legislation um
and in support of uh pre-processing
absentee ballots it's been a priority of
ours for um basically since 2020 or
before um one thing I wanted to kind of
reemphasize is there are you know a
level of envelopes and ballots there's
the outside envelope that gets mailed to
the town There's the envelope inside
where the voter signs that affidavit and
then the ballot is inside that so
reemphasizing that um that ballot itself
is still in that sealed envelope and not
coming out or being opened until
election day when they're going through
the machines so there's a good level of
security there uh one of the other
reasons that in addition to things that
have been said today um in addition to
um the support from election officials
that we support pre-processing is
greater transparency um being able to
have more noticed sessions ahead of time
where voters acoss the town can go and
watch the processing of absentee ballots
watch the envelopes be opened and
checked versus sometimes the chaos and
kind of just busy days on Election Day
um having that additional time on the
front end um to have greater
transparency and voter confidence um and
finally like other said an ability for
voters to cure their ballots if they
somehow on that form forgot a signature
forgot to fill in some information to
make sure that they can have that ballot
count ahead of election day um
especially because with our absentee
voting process uh most folks who um are
voting absentee are not able to go to
the polls on Election Day so it gives
them the chance to have the extra time
to do that ahead of time and ensure
their vote counts um and I'm happy to
answer questions if there are any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you thank you uh next up is Autumn
Rost
Goodwin uh that's the last up
representative gy can you grab me that
blue sheet for 344
all right uh for the record my name is
Autumn rashik Goodwin program
coordinator for open democracy I live in
Manchester New Hampshire and I'm
testifying in support of HB
344 um in the name of expediency several
of the points that I was going to make
in my testimony today have already been
made by previous speakers so I just
wanted to highlight two things here and
then I'll yield um first is when people
are filling out their absentee ballots
it's incredibly easy for someone who
who's distracted or in a rush to forget
a signature or make some slight mistake
on that outer envelope so having this
method of curing in advance is crucial
um and additionally this is a very
popular idea there are 43 States and the
Virgin Islands that permit election
officials to begin processing absentee
ballots in mailing ballots in advance of
Elections
so with that I encourage vote
OTP there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you I don't
have any else any other pink cards um
signed up in person 1 two three four
five six 7 8 9 10 12 in favor zero
opposed online 428 in support 63 in
opposed uh with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 344
we're going to reopen executive session
for a statement
um so I'm going to reopen executive
session without objection I've shown
this list to the ranking member we are
going to place house bills 336 relative
to the placement of political signs on
rways House Bill 448 establishing a
committee to study violations by the
April 25th 2023 election law bout law
commission uh House Bill 626 directing
the Secretary of State to implement a
vulnerability disclosure program for
certain election systems and cacr 3
relating to recall elections providing
that the general court May authorize
recall elections on the consent calendar
without
objection yes representative c u i was
under the understanding that cacr could
not go on consent they can when they're
being defeated okay thank um and the
reason that 327 is not going on the
consent calendar is it has a fiscal note
so it cannot go on the consent calendar
um but without objection those four
bills be placed on the consent calendar
because I don't want a nasty note from
the clerk so no objection all right and
I'm closing executive session all
now we're going to open the public
hearing for house B 608 uh requiring the
moderator to inspect absentee ballot
affidavits for full execution including
use of a notary election officer or any
other person authorized by law to
administer Oaths and I thank
representative Panic for her patience I
apologize we're running a smidge behind
and thank you for letting us defer your
introduction all right uh good afternoon
members of the committee and thank you R
uh chairman Barry uh for this
opportunity I'm going to defer some of
my speaking time to hand it over to uh
Daniel Richards is that okay U that's
fine I'll out within the same five
minute rule for introduction we've had
okay objection all right
um HB 608 is being introduced to address
uh three uh critical areas where New
Hampshire election law and procedures uh
fall short constitutionally and
legislatively in regards to absentee
voters um New Hampshire passed House
Bill
1569 in 2024 which requires all voters
to present
identification um it was an oversight
that this aspect of our election on
unverified absentee voters was not
corrected when this legislation was
codified uh HB 608 will fix this
um in 2020 before
2020 uh with historical absentee voter
rates hovering around 3% this issue went
unchecked it didn't seem to be a big
deal uh in 2020 even though we can't fix
what happened in 2020 we certainly can
learn from it uh with the expansion of
uh reasons to vote absentee under covid
the number of absentee voters ballooned
to 32% imagine 32% of the ballots were
cast with no ID postco in the 2024
presidential election the Hampshire had
just under 100,000 absentee voters at
12% more than four times the historical
Norms preo this is a growing problem
that is not going away and as we as
legislators we need to uh fix this and
HB 608 will take care of that uh that
list that you received uh on the prior
bill showing all the towns that were uh
overvotes like Waterville Valley had a
192% voter turnout um that's from the
actual work that uh we all did uh after
the 2020 election and those numbers um
are shocking and we're trying to protect
everybody's votes here um you know this
is um bipod is an issue and we're just
trying to protect everybody's votes
thank you and I'm going to give the
remainder of my time to Daniel
Richards chairman members of the
committee thank you again for your time
I want to address this issue from a
different angle what we're dealing with
here is an unresolved conflict in 1979
when the modifications to our election
laws were put in place they removed the
notary certificate so it had Bill
Gardner convinced the legislature to rec
codify all our election laws which they
did and so the absentee affidavit
requirement was simply omitted when they
when they uh amended the physical
disability clause and when they did so
the state Secretary of State's office
has been calling the return envelope an
affidavit instrument there's a big
difference between the current envelope
which is self- attestation self-
attestation again would be permissible
if the legislature chose to make that be
the rule the problem is you make the law
the Secretary of State and the Attorney
General's office don't make law
separation of powers but this is where
the conflict lies what they did is they
removed the previous duty of the voter
when this when the affidavit requirement
was put in in 1942 also was the
statutory requirement for the voter to
repeat the in-person process the
in-person process is you show up you
produce an ID you're given a ballot you
mark your ballot in the vicinity of the
election officials you deposit it in in
a box or a machine under a secure
environment to your point sir about the
the verification right and so what they
did is they made it equal so it would be
the same and so after marking the ballot
then the voter would put the ballot
inside of his envelope with an
eyewitness that eyewitness would sign
the notary certificate so that when the
moderator got the envelope and he looks
at it and says is the affidavit properly
executed he could see that it was or it
wasn't and another gentleman mentioned
the issue of um not being able to check
these things well like I said earlier
32% that's 260,000 absentee ballots were
counted in the 2020 election none of
them were verified since
1979 we have not had any verification of
any absentee ballots except for those
people who return to their polling
districts and turn them in in person
because if you do that today your
election staff is more than happy to
take that in and act as a notary under
under the previous law that was just
repealed they went ahead and had that
provision so you had five people notary
JP moderator selectman and clerk all can
act in that capacity the local banking
center I my bank doesn't charge me to
notorized anything so again this issue
all has to do with the equal application
of the law we have a problem and it's a
loophole if you have the moderator who's
required to make sure the affid was
properly executed and he's not doing his
job the step the follow statute says
he's got to dispose of that ballot
65953 defective material right across
the face ballot defective for failure to
execute a proper affidavit again if
we're going to require attestation let
the legislature make that change but not
the Secretary of State's office because
that's what we're doing now thank you
thank you your time has expired Mr
Richard um any questions questions i'
love to answer you question hearing none
thank you next up is secretary scanland
Mr secretary welcome
back thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm Secretary of State
David scandin and I understand it's been
a really long day for you so I'll try
and be as brief as I can on this um what
the bill calls for if you look at the
bill itself is responsibility of the
moderator when processing the absentee B
ballots to make sure certain things are
correct U when they do that that's RSA
659 colon
50 uh and this deals with Roman numeral
1 B and so if you look at the statute
completely it just says that the
moderator is supposed to do this Duty
and it says if the name of the voter is
on the checklist and the affidavit
appears to be properly executed and the
signature uh on the affidavit appears to
be executed by the same person then the
then the absentee ballot gets processed
what this bill
does is adds the
language when the Moder is looking at
this that the affidavit on the absentee
ballot envelope is a fully executed
legal affidavit that is witnessed and
signed by a notary election officer or
any other person authorized by law to
administer
Ro now if if that's the policy that the
legislature wants that's one thing and
I'm not going to take an opinion on that
today but what I am trying to point out
with this language is that this will
cause Mass
confusion because the the the language
that we need to be looking at for what
is contained on the so-called affidavit
envelope is in RSA
657 col 7 and that language says that
the Secretary of State State shall put
the following language on the affidavit
envelope and there is no provision in
the statute that says that there's
supposed to be a place or an opportunity
on there for a notary or some other
person to take the oath of office to do
that so if that were added then this
language that is being proposed in this
bill might be appropriate but
um it's it at this point I don't believe
it is
so the other thing that I'd like to
point out too is that you know absentee
balloting really started uh taking
place uh in the Constitution and
statutorily in the area of the
1940s and in 1943 in in the law book in
the election laws of that time um there
was an opportunity for the voter to sign
the the statement that they were who
they say they are uh and as Mr Richard
said have a witness watch
them uh uh not Mark the ballot but take
the marked ballot the done in private
put it in the the uh envelope which
contained the affidavit on it and then
sign a witness oath that you know they
did in fact observe the voter following
through that
process in
1955 the law was changed to remove that
provision
and in that time that statement on the
affidavit envelope was not called an
affidavit it was called a
certificate and that language has
continued up until the legislature
really started addressing the a the
absentee ballot
laws within the last 10 years or so
1979 was when the legislature recodified
a lot of the election statutes but those
Provisions that I'd mentioned before
kind of carry
beyond that and so uh today the the
language is you know has changed
recently but it calls the affid the
envelope with the statement on it an
affidavit envelope but I believe it
still calls the statement that is on
there a certificate bottom line is the
secretary of state has directions on the
language that shall appear on the
affidavit that's what we do and that's
what the moderators are supposed to be
uh watching for when they process the
absentee ballots and with that I would
be happy to answer any
questions questions from the
committee repr Lane um what do you
consider them to be an
affidavit
well I think in this case the affidavit
is what the legislature calls it
um but I mean that I'm sure sure that
there is a legal definition of what a an
affidavit constitutes and and I think uh
Mr Richard is well uh schooled in that
but I but I think the legislature can
say something and mean something else
the bottom line again is
that maybe I should rephrase
[Laughter]
that but but but I I think I think in
this case it it was it was just uh uh um
Loosely throwing around words and what
they actually mean um
um I'll leave it at that further
questions from the committee to take him
a little bit off the hook we experienced
that last year we went through the
campaign Finance reform a lot of
conflicting definitions and a lot of
terms used that were not defined so yeah
it we we amend things on and off and it
sometimes it's really hard to catch
everything so thank you um further
questions seeing none thank you Mr
secretary next up is Linda
Bundy uh is anyone here for to introduce
269 okay after this we'll have an
introduction of
269 can you fill out a pink card
represent talk please if unless it's
made
it oh never mind it just made it to my
desk my
apologies Miss bunny can press that
button there we go okay thank you good
afternoon chair Barry and members of the
committee my name is Linda Bundy and I'm
from antrum I oppose HB 608 requiring
moderators to inspect absentee ballot
affidavits for full execution including
use of a notary election officer or any
person authorized by law to administer
Oaths currently absentee ballots must
have a signed affidavit from the voter
and anyone who assisted the voter in
completing their ballot by adding the
extra step of getting the ballots
notorized or signed by an authorized
official HB 608 places an undue burden
on absentee voters many of whom are
senior citizens or people with
disabilities obtaining
notorized authorized signature will
likely prevent a significant percentage
of these populations from voting I
searched the New Hampshire attorney
general's website for absentee ballot
fraud I didn't find fraud per se but
there were letters concerning absentee
ballots that were not counted in the
towns of Bedford marac and Nottingham in
the 2020 election there were no
instances of fraud by individual voters
I believe that HB 608 will prevent
eligible voters from casting absentee
ballots and is unnecessary legislation I
ask that you vote inexpedient to
legislate on this Bill thank you for
your time thank you will you be taking
questions Miss Bundy nope ex I love it
um we're going to recess the public
hearing on House Bill 608 I'm going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
629 represent rep recognize
representative katab for the purpose of
introduction
[Music]
amend
that okay well we're going to reopen the
the hearing on 608 we're not done with
608 we're just letting representative K
present and then we go back I try to
respect the representatives times you're
good you're you're fine representative
K yeah I I have a thing I have a huge
pet peeve when committees run behind and
then I have to sit there for three hours
and it's like all I have to do is
introduce the bill so I let
Representatives introduce it and then I
go back to the
hearings thank you chairman Barry and
members of the election law committee
for the record I'm representative
Caitlyn cab and I'm here to introduce
House Bill
269 which is a very simple change which
is
removing the word Saturday um from
when for the last date to to correct the
voter checklist so to just give a little
background on this back in 2016
representative Bates had a
bill to remove all the references to
Saturday and to only say it used to say
that it had to be the Saturday 10 days
prior to the election and then he made
it some changes which went
into 654 27 which made it say that they
the supervisor of the checklist were
able to designate a day six to 13 days
prior to the election and the real
purpose of this is because we live in
New England and there's snowstorms so we
don't want to pin down the supervisors
of the checklist to have to
have a meeting during a big blizzard
because they have to do it on Saturday
that just doesn't make sense that's not
helping the voters
and or anybody so this is just simply
making that one correction to that last
reference to Saturday that should not
have been in there and that's all this
bill is doing and I'm happy to take any
questions questions from the committee
for representative
kab seeing none thank you going to
recess the public hearing on House Bill
629 and reopen the public hearing on
House Bill 608 going to recognize Dave
Nelson uh next up is McKenzie
Taylor thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh my name is Dave
Nelson Derry Town moderator thank you
for hearing my testimony um I want to be
clear what it is that moderators need to
actually inspect and verify with respect
to the content of the affidavit
so-called that as listed in this bill um
we already know that moderators are not
allowed to do signature comparison
between the signature on the affidavit
and the application because of a New
Hampshire Supreme Court decision that it
holds that we don't not have we do not
have that technical skill um in cry
Crypt analysis to um compare signatures
and so I would ask for some guidance
um in terms of determining that it had
been notorized
um or witnessed by either a not election
officer or any other person authorized
by law to administer Oaths um if we
can't compare two signatures that are
sensibly of um the applicant how are we
to verify with any level of certainty
that those witnessing signatures whether
they be notary Justice of the Peace
Office of the Superior Court whatever
are actually who they say they are um
just concerns me that the moderators are
asked to again do something that is
probably beyond our our skill set thank
you will you be taking questions from
the committee um absolutely all right
are there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you next up is Daniel
did I say Mackenzie Taylor I Daniel Hill
you're up next then we have Mackenzie
Taylor and after that Autumn rashchi
goodwi one thank you uh Dan Hy Nash City
Clerk and I oppose this bill I have uh
similar concerns that I mentioned
previously with the notary
um homebound residents are going to have
a tough time getting getting the
affidavit notorized
um and you know my office we charge $2
for a notary if someone comes in I
believe we' probably wave that if we're
notorized absentee envelopes but there
are fees associated with notaries um and
again especially if they're coming to
someone's house and then my second
concern which I don't believe has been
mentioned is um speaking with a few
other clerks we have some concerns that
a notary might put their notary stamp
right through the ballot the ballots
already in the envelope it's they sign
it in front of the person and then they
stamp their seal and it presses down
into the ballot so uh those are the the
two big concerns um uh that I have and
may be open to any questions questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
next up Mackenzie
Taylor good afternoon one final time
today uh Mackenzie tayor with the New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights and
America votes um we oppose this bill um
echoing the points we've brought up
earlier about notarizing um and the
number of or the number of uh the cost
and difficulty in having not a notary
potentially come to a home for people
who are voting absentee because they
aren't able to travel um and the cost
and kind of different steps there for
something that is um someone's right to
vote and to be able to vote absentee if
they are unable to go in person uh the
other concern I wanted to bring up with
this bill specifically is because it is
on the envelopes themselves that go uh
to the polls without pre-processing um
if those ballots or those inside
envelopes are only looked at on election
day if folks make mistakes with a new
process with a pretty high burden of
having something notorized um most of
those folks because they have attested
that they can't vote on Election Day be
unable to go to the polls un and fix
their ballot um and be able to vote in
persons the number of ballots that could
potentially be rejected um because they
uh weren't you know there was a new
process there was more difficulty and
things weren't necessarily notorized um
in the number of Voters who would be
disenfranchised for that reason um and
happy to take any questions questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thank you last up is Autumn rashik
Goodwin ah yes did
it eventually I mean poor uh poor Kaylee
she's gone through many iterations of
name
AB all right uh for the record my name
is Autumn rashik Goodwin I'm the program
coordinator for open democracy and I
live in Manchester New Hampshire and I
am testifying in opposition of HB 608 um
many of the points that I aimed to make
have already been made by other speakers
and since we're behind time I'll speed
it along uh so basically again
reiterating that this can put undue
strain on absentee voters who largely
are members of the disability Community
the elderly and having to find a notary
to
make sure that their ballots are counted
puts an extra step into their process
for casting their ballot um and could
lead to the disenfranchisement of those
voters
potentially um so it is with that reason
that I urge the committee to vote itl on
HB 608 will you be taking questions from
the committee sure are there questions
from the committee no oh yes
representative wey uh thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so
um I'm
sure the populations that you've
mentioned are not immune from having to
verify their identity in other
circumstances is there any
recommendation you would have for the
committee that we would be able to
verify the the identity of these people
and in in a way you know that would have
an equal treatment of of
Voters I would have to look into that
further and get back to you i' welcome
that
you'll punt okay
um later I do it all the time it's
another wrong with that I do all the
time yeah I'll get back to you um
exactly yeah yeah you know yeah it's not
you know I I have no hate for the game
so um nothing but love for the game all
right anyone else who have any questions
thank you so much um on the blue sheet
there was uh zero in support nine in Opp
opposition and um online was a little
lopsided nine in support and 533 in
opposition so little lopsided uh with
that I'm going to close the exec uh
public hearing on 608 going to reopen
the public hearing on 629 and recognize
Eileen mashimo
mimo
269 269 relative to the dates of
Corrections for the voter PR list which
has already been introduced
hello my name is Eileen moshimo and I
have just entered my 13th year as a
supervisor of the voter checklist in the
town of
wiam when then State Rep David Bates
joined me as a supervisor I relayed to
him that some of the rsas were very
outdated one was the RSA that
supervisors were notified of a voter's
death by the town clerk but only if the
person died in my town the law was
written long before the age of computers
David submitted a bill for the Secretary
of State to notify supervisors of
matches between recorded death records
and voter records anywhere in the state
we are now notified through the state
voter registration system within days of
a voter's death anywhere in the state
David also submitted a bill giving
supervisors more flexibility in
scheduling their last sessions prior to
elections prior to any state federal
primary Village district meeting or town
election we were required to hold a
session between 11:30 11 a.m. and 11:30
a.m. on the Saturday between 6 and 13
days prior to the
election David put in proposed
legislation to take out the words 11:30
a.m. to 11:30 uh 11: a.m. to 11:30 a.m.
on the Saturday the bill was legislated
and passed unfortunately it was not
discovered until the next year that the
word Saturday was not taken out in one
of the five or six places that were
located in the
rsas the word Saturday remaining in the
section of the law pertaining to town
elections has C caused some major
inconveniences and safety issues none
worse than March 4th
2023 when the state was hit with a major
snowstorm when snow was falling at a
rate of 1 inch an hour some areas of New
Hampshire had well over 18 to 24 in of
snow in the days preceding the snowstorm
the secretary state's office has sent
out a memo requ uh requiring all
supervisor or informing all supervisors
that the rsas required us to meet that
day no Exceptions there was no way to
postpone to another day our town had to
have snowplow snowplow diverted from
cleaning the streets to Our Town Hall
Parking Lot in order for the town hall
parking lot to be cleared enough that we
could hold our meeting in other areas of
the state supervisors had to choose
between personal safety or violating the
law all this could have been avoided if
the word Saturday was not in the law
where it is right now I simply ask you
to pass the law to remove the word
Saturday keeping the word in the RSA
hasn't was an apparent oversight but
keeping it in can continue to cause
supervisors great difficulties thank you
okay will you be taking questions from
the
committee okay hearing none um thank you
and last up is Tina
Guilford and representative
thanks good afternoon again uh Tina
Guilford Derry town clerk um for a lot
of the reasons that the previous speaker
spoke um is why I came up um in 2023 we
also had to divert resources from
cleaning our streets to keeping the Town
Hall Parking Lot clear for for our
supervisors and any members of the
public that may attend the
session um I've also found that very
often the week before the election seems
to be when people really get interested
in the
election and the Monday and Tuesday be
you know before that week before often
seems to be when they come in and they
remember that they never registered to
vote in our town or they never uh you
know and they you know and they remember
ooh I need to do this and and basically
what happens is we end up making telling
them they either need to go on Election
Day and register which
causes you know one wonderful lines or
you know they have to register absentee
if they're not going to be able to be
there uh so the flexibility would be
great so that our supervisors could have
their session you know the week before
the election when people are actually
finally interested especially in the
town election CU they just don't seem to
show
up and I will take any questions
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you um there was one person on the
blue sheet who signed up who didn't
speak that was deputy secretary of state
Hennessy by the way online there was 12
people in support 13 opposed with that
I'm going to close the public hearing on
6:29 and I'm going to open the public
hearing on
3:45 29 26 are we on we're closing 269
yes okay I'm sorry we're closing 269 and
we're opening 345 which I want to note
is only three minutes behind nice nice
job I am so proud of that you should
be represent Perez is recognized of the
pur of introduction of house bu 345
enabling selectman to add additional
polling places and requiring selectman
to give no to voters 30 days before
providing such additional polling
places thank you thanks for hearing um I
for the record I'm representative
Christine Perez London da Rockingham 16
so last November the country the state
and our towns all had unprecedented
turnout of residents who cast their
right to vote in that election uh we
were blessed here in New Hampshire that
the weather was also unprecedented no
snow no rain that being said we had
lines in towns that required 2hour
weights and More in most cases if not
all it was caused by too many people
trying to cast their vote in one spot
one polling place this is a simple
change to the existing RSA
658 uh semicon 10 presently it takes the
vote of the town to add or subtract
polling places this simply allows that
decision to be made by the Selectmen
this is a
May and not a shall but helps the voters
in each town the people that we serve so
for example for your town election if
you only needed one polling place that's
not a problem but when we come up on an
election every four years like we do
like we did this past November it might
be in the best interest of the town to
create two polling places so that that
people are not in line for 2 and 1/2
hours then they can go back to their one
polling place I say this because I live
in London area and our lines were 2 and
1 half hours long they went down the
down the parking lot up the parking lot
around back to the other side and people
were waiting in line and I just think
that this would be an easy fix that the
towns may choose to do this type of
thing with that I'll accept any qu
questions you may have questions from
the
committee uh representative
Lane um thank you for taking my question
I guess I I don't I live in a city so we
have Wards and it's a little different
so I'm just trying to
so and I know when we changed our Ward
polling places two years ago it was and
everybody got notice and everybody got a
letter because and people showed up up
still at the wrong place right so I mean
it sounds like 30 days is enough but
um
logistically what do we do with the
people who inevitably are going to show
up at the wrong place particularly near
closing time so I'm just trying to
figure this out how that would all work
and the notice would work and and maybe
you're not the right one to ask I don't
know well um thank you for your question
we know when the next election
presidential election is we know when
the next one is after that and after
that and after that um 30 days was an
arbitrary number actually this
legislation was actually um um formed by
um secretary scandin who will speak next
so I'm sure that he might be interested
I will ask him yes he might be
interested in saying that we could do it
a year in advance and mind people every
two weeks yeah okay thank you and he he
is the only one signed up to speak so um
any other question question Nome thank
you very much thanks for taking the
question uh in your testimony you
mentioned the possibility for the big
elections going to multiples and then
going back does this change allow to go
back and how would then the same notice
requirements to go back yes and wouldn't
that just add to
confusion well I live in londondary and
we have approximately 18,000 people we
have a news we're fortunate we have a
newspaper that goes out every single
week to every single residents in the
town um you know I think we need to
think about the the voters and the
convenience of the voters I mean we had
elderly and I use the
term um that waited in line for two 2
and a half hours there was no they did
did allow um people with small children
to go ahead but many of the PE my I live
in a 55 community they wouldn't go ahead
in line because they just felt that they
needed to be there I think this would
help also I think people are going to I
think people walked away from voting not
only because of the lines but because of
the traffic to get there if you have to
go to work and you think you're going to
show up at the polls at 6:00 a.m. to
make it even to 8:00 or 9:00 being at
work some people were not able to do
that
so all right uh further questions from
the committee see n uh thank you for
filing this um just this is a serious
problem and we are going to look heavily
this is this is a serious problem thank
you uh last up and the last card of the
day iron perfect enough repres
representative godo he was a
representative at one point point at one
point uh secretary scalin
honorable well let's not go that
far thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee uh I'll try and choose my
words
uh carefully this um I would like to
thank representative Perez for
introducing this piece of legislation it
is similar to one that was heard in the
Senate today although significant
variations but it addressed is the issue
of really high voter turnout uh which is
a great thing and New Hampshire
consistently turns out record numbers of
Voters but because the state is growing
and the polling the number of polling
places really hasn't increased uh we are
seeing lines that we would never have
seen you know 20 years ago uh and in the
last election the lines were long uh you
know some were an hour some were two
hours and there were a few that were
even longer than that and um that's not
fair to the voters so there are these
tools that we can put in place to help
address those issues one is uh creating
an opportunity for towns to easily have
additional polling places so that they
can spread the voters out uh uh over
different sites um I think it's
important to note that this bill and the
one this morning is not directed at a
specific town or group of towns towns I
can tell you that the largest towns in
this state run
incredibly uh efficient
elections and um you you heard from them
earlier today New Hampshire does have
the distinction of having the smallest
polling places in the country and it
also has the largest and that's a neat
distinction to have as long as you know
everything runs smoothly and and so you
know I want to make sure that if a
community is up for it and they plan
well enough that they can continue to do
that but there are other towns in the
state that struggle and so in addition
to additional polling places you we can
do more training we're always doing
training but help moderators and
election officials identify the choke
points in a polling place so that things
can move technology will help out making
sure that you we have enough ballot
counting devices in the towns that use
them in towns that use e Pole books
making sure that they have appropriate
numbers of those um but clearly this is
an area that we have to look at
for the future and with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions other
questions from the committee represent C
I'll go the ranking Member First it's
okay take somebody else all right okay
btis thank you for taking questions and
it's similar I just want want to make
sure you're confident that this language
would be able for them then to pull back
and go back to what they had for the
non um not the small elections the local
elections those kind of things you're
that they'll be able to do that with
this language yes
okay we were debating
it is that okay repres
C thank you Mr chairman thank you
secretary for taking my question um Can
the electronic Pole books be coordinated
from two different locations so if
somebody shows up at the wrong location
that they can still vote because within
a town the ballot should all be the
same they could probably be set up for
that I that's something that I think I
would oppose and typically when an
additional polling place is set up it is
set up
for a distinct group of Voters that will
be assigned that polling place and so I
mean that does come to the other issue
that you raised communication will be a
really really important part of this
getting the word out you know
fortunately with technology it's easier
to do that today than it was 20 years
ago
but representative we yeah uh just a
rhetorical question would this give the
supervisors of the checklist enough time
to sort into multiple polling places if
it's only 30
days I I think it can be done because of
the way the database is set up however I
I think 30 days is kind of tight I I
would be okay you know making it 60 or
90 we know when the big elections are
going to happen so there's plenty of
time to gear up for
it further
questions represent PR O'Brien I
apologize if this has already been asked
but with the electronic poll books if
you know in my community that's what's
used maybe some other
speakers other guests that are here
could speak to this but would there be
communication between the two polling
places with the electronic poll books so
conceivably somebody could go to one
polling place vote and then go to
another polling place and no
okay each polling place that the poll
books would have the checklist for that
polling place
y further question from the committee um
that's it all right well I I'll end with
this one um does your office recognize
that these lines are an issue you know I
think Bedford had one that was like an
hour and a half um I know I waited in
wear like tiny little town of wear for
almost an hour
um it's it's an issue and I'm hoping
your office I guess what I'm looking for
is the rhetorical question of does your
office recognize this as an issue and
that we need I believe we need to do
something agree with that 100% the
answer is yes okay all right thank you
um I don't have anyone else signed up to
speak on House Bill 345 uh there was one
person signed up uh in person on the
blue sheet that did not speak online it
was 12 in support 13 opposed one neutral
um so with that I will close our uh
public hearing at 3:45 we did it 4:15
they said it couldn't be done I said it
couldn't be done
um thank you guys for your patience on
today I we did land the plane on time
which is nice um sorry to the members of
the public that it's two minutes
testimony but that's what it's going to
be like so this is what election law
will look like for the next six
weeks um so I hope you liked it uh we uh
we did four
hearings and 11 execs so not a bad day
thank you guys I'll see you next Tuesday